GOOD EVENING EVERYONE IF I COULD.
ASK FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND CALL
THE MEETING TO ORDER I WOULD.
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR BEING
HERE FOR THIS IMPORTANT MEETING.
I WANT TO PARTICULARLY THANK --
GOT MONSIGNOR JOHN FATHER JOHN
AS I UNDERSTAND HE'S CALLED I'VE --
AND THE RESURRECTION CHURCH THE
PRISONERS OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
CHURCH FOR OFFERING US YOUR
HOSPITALITY.
UP FOR THIS EVENT TONIGHT.
THIS IS THE STATE ASSEMBLY
SUBCOMMITTEE ON RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION WE ARE HOLDING AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON THE EXITE
RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP.
I'M THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
IN THIS COMMITTEE PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL WHICH
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW IS THE STATE
AGENCY THAT IS IN CHARGE.
OF THE OXIDE RESIDENTIAL
CLEANUPS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN IN RESPONSE TO
THE PLEAS OF THIS COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MIGUEL SANTIAGO IN
PRISTINA GARCIA.
OUR COMMITTEE TOOK AN ACTION TO
SEVENTY SIX POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO
CLEAN UP THE CONTAMINATION FROM
BACKSIDE.
AND THEN JUST THIS PAST YEAR WE
ALSO SECURED AN ADDITIONAL SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR CLEANUP
WORK OF PARK WAYS.
THAT WERE FOR REASONS OTHER
COMPLEX AND STILL UNCLEAR TO
SOME OF US.
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE INITIAL
CLEANUP ORDER BUT THE MONEY IS
THERE NOW TO BEGIN NOW WORK.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS A DUTY TO
OVERSEE STATE ENTITIES AND THE
MANNER IN WHICH THEY CARRY OUT
THEIR DUTIES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL IS WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CLEAN UP EFFORT THAT'S LED BY
DTS SEE AS A MASSIVE UNDERTAKING.
AS I KNOW YOU ARE EXPERIENCING
RIGHT HERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
OF IT IS IN FACT CONSIDERED THE
LARGEST EVER CLEAN UP OF LEAD
CONTAMINATED HOMES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH ANY PROJECT AT THIS SCALE --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT OTHER --
ARE LIKELY TO BE INEVITABLE
SETBACKS AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
WITH THIS PROJECT AND I'M.
HOPING THIS HEARING TODAY WILL
PROVIDE US WITH A BETTER SENSE
OF WHERE WE ARE WITH THE CLEAN
UP.
OF WHAT SOME OF THOSE SETBACKS
HAVE BEEN HOW TO OVERCOME THEM.
THEM IN THE FUTURE AND WHERE WE
PROCEED FROM WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW.
AND A MINUTE I'M GOING TO TURN
TO THE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY
MY COLLEAGUE ANTHONY RENDON AS
WELL AS MY OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO
WERE IN ATTENDANCE TODAY.
HOWEVER I AGAIN WANT TO TAKE A
MINUTE COMMITMENT TO THE LARGER
COMMUNITY HERE THE COMMUNITY
THAT HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY THIS
CRISIS.
MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE THAT THE
WATER CRISIS IN FLINT MICHIGAN A
FEW YEARS AGO WHERE.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT CRISIS
WHERE THE ENTIRE CITY WAS
EXPOSED TO DANGEROUS LEVELS OF
LEAD IN THEIR DRINKING WATER.
THE INCIDENTS BECAME A NATIONAL
HEADLINE AND HIGHLIGHTED
UNFORTUNATELY GOVERNMENT AT ITS
WORST.
AND WHY WAS IT IS AT ITS WORST
BECAUSE IT REALLY FAILED TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE.
OF THE EXIDE BATTERY PLANTS IS --
THIS COMMUNITIES FLICK MICHIGAN.
FOR DECADES THE OWNERS OF THIS
PLANT AND OUR GOVERNMENT.
FAILED TO PROTECT THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMUNITY.
BUT JUST TO THIS COMMITTEE AS
THIS COMMITTEE IS WORKING TO
PROVIDE.
CLEAN DRINKING WATER TO A SMALL
RURAL AND POOR COMMUNITIES UP
AND DOWN THE STATE THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED TO DANGERS LET
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF NITRATES
CHROMIUM SIX IN LAD.
JUST AS THIS COMMITTEE IS
WORKING TO INVEST HEAVILY IN
PREVENTING FIRES THAT HAVE
RAVAGED COMMUNITIES IN BOTH
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THIS COMMITTEE IS GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR COMMUNITY GETS CLEANED IN A
TIMELY FASHION AND THAT YOU AND
YOUR CHILDREN ARE SAFE.
NOW AND IN THE FUTURE.
SITTING UP HERE ON THIS DIES
WITH ME OR SOME OF THE MOST
COMMITTED ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
THE STATE.
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
FIGHTING FOR THOSE IN NEED THESE
PEOPLE HAVE LIVED THERE.
AND THEY HAVE FOUGHT JUST AS YOU
HAVE TO MAKE THINGS BETTER --
THEY'RE HERE TO LISTEN AND TO
HEAR YOU CLOSELY AND TO HEAR
THOSE WHO ARE PRESENTING --
AND PROVIDING US WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE
PROVIDED THIS EVENING AND WITH
THAT I WANT TO INTRODUCE THE
SPEAKER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE.
MISTER ANTHONY RENDON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK THE CHAIR NOT ONLY FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING FOR BUT FOR
HIS LONG LONG TIME COMMITMENT TO
THIS ISSUE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
HE IS --
CONTINUALLY ASKED ME ABOUT
CONTINUALLY BEEN ENGAGED ON TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I ALSO
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES --
THAT CHRISTINA GARCIA AND MISTER
SANTIAGO BOTH OF WHOM.
REPRESENT PARTS OF THE AFFECTED
AREA THEIR COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN --
HAS BEEN A LONG STANDING AS WELL --
WINDY CAREER WHO JOINED THE
ASSEMBLY EARLIER THIS YEAR HAS
JUMPED IN RIGHT AWAY ONE OF OUR
EARLY DISCUSSIONS.
SHE ASKED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THIS ISSUE SO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK A
SUPERVISOR HELD THE SAUDIS WHO
HAS.
BEEN.
WHO ALSO HAS BEEN ENGAGED ON
THIS ISSUE MULTIPLE VISITS TO
SACRAMENTO TO TO TALK TO ME AND
MY STAFF ABOUT THIS SHE AND HER
STAFF?
HAVE BEEN QUITE ENGAGED AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR FOR FOR
CARRYING THIS WORK FORWARD FOR
THE PROTECTION OF OUR COMMUNITY.
IT'S SAD THAT WE'VE BEEN AT THIS
FOR SO LONG AND I BELIEVE THAT
MS GARCIA AND I SAT IN A HEARING
IN THE CITY OF COMMERCE OUR
FRESHMAN YEAR THAT --
THE FIRST YEAR OF OUR OUR
FRESHMAN TERM --
AND AS I SAID ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR TWO YEARS AGO.
EXCITED PUT IT POLLUTANTS IN FOR
DECADES AND IT'S THEIR JOB.
AND OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THAT IT'S CLEANED.
I ARGUED THEN ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THE STATE HAS TO
ADVANCE A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR CLEAN UP.
AS MISTER BLOOM MENTIONED
THERE'VE BEEN ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT SINCE THAT TIME.
EXCITES TOXIC LEAD EMISSIONS ARE
SPECIALLY HARMFUL TO CHILDREN
WHO ARE IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT.
AND I HEAR THAT THERE'S NEW
EVIDENCE FROM USC OUR FRIENDS IN
EAST YARDS AND COUNTY RESEARCH
THAT LED IS PASSED ON TO
PREGNANT MOTHERS TO THE BABY
EVEN.
BEFORE IT IS BORN.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO REMEDIATE
THE LEAD POLLUTION CAUSED BY
EXCITED NOW.
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT OTHER
LEAD EXPOSURE IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND WE NEED TO DO THAT NOW AS
WELL.
AS WE ALL KNOW WE CAN'T WAIT ANY
LONGER THE KIDS CAN'T WAIT FOR
LIABILITY CLAIMS TO DRAG THROUGH
THE COURTS.
SO THE COMMUNITY IS FINALLY
SEEING RESIDENTIAL ENOUGH
PROCEEDING ON A LARGER SCALE
UNDER DGSE.
IT'S APPROPRIATE NOW TO LOOK AT
A FEW THINGS NUMBER ONE WE
CANNOT AND WILL NOT LET EXCITE
OFF THE HOOK FOR THE PROBLEMS
THAT THEY ENGENDERED.
SECOND WE HAVE TO KEEP AN EYE ON
HOW THE RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP GOES
AND DISCUSS HOW PARK WAYS WILL
BE TESTED AND CLEANED UP.
FINALLY THERE IS MUCH TO BE DONE
WHETHER OUR NEXT APPS WHAT'S THE
FIRST TWO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
HOMES HAVE BEEN CLEANED UP.
THE DEPARTMENT THE COUNTY
OFFICIALS NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
ON THIS AND MAKE SURE THAT THIS
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
HEALTHY DIRECTION.
AND AT A FAST PACE.
THE PEOPLE IN THESE COMMUNITIES
HAVE WAITED LONG ENOUGH THERE
CAN'T BE ANY MORE DELAYS.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU AROUND AND
UNFORTUNATELY SPEAKER AND IT HAS
A EXTREMELY BUSY AND A CONGESTED.
SCHEDULE THIS EVENING AND IS NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE I HAVE ALREADY
PROMISED HIM THAT I WILL PROVIDE
HIM WITH A FULL REPORT.
OF OF WHAT TRANSPIRES HERE
TONIGHT AND HE WILL BE FULLY
APPRISED SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SPENDING SOME OF YOUR TIME
HERE -- THIS
EVENING AND I AM GOING TO NOW --
IN A MOMENT TURNED TO MY THREE
COLLEAGUES AND ASK FOR THEIR
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS WE ALSO ARE
HONORED TO HAVE WITH US HERE
SUPERVISOR HELD THIS LEASE AND
TO COUNCILMEMBER CLOSE A WHO IS
OUR WHO WILL AND I ALSO PROVIDE
SOME INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS.
OF BEFORE WE DO THAT I WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE
INFORMED EVERYONE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO IT HERE TO SOME.
PRETTY STRICT TIME CONSTRAINTS
HERE -- THIS
EVENING.
AND THAT IS BOTH MY COLLEAGUES
AND THE PANELISTS WHO ARE HERE.
BECAUSE OF WE ARE GOING TO LEAVE
SUFFICIENT TIME TO HEAR FROM ALL
OF YOU WHEN IT GETS TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I'M.
SO PLEASE BE PATIENT WITH US BUT
IF YOU SEE ME PRODDING GOT MY
CALL REASON THAT I GET SO THAT
WE CAN GET TO ADD TO YOUR
TESTIMONY AND HEAR FROM YOU
BECAUSE AT ITS.
MOST FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL THIS
HEARING IS FOR YOU AND ABOUT YOU
AND ABOUT THIS COMMUNITY.
I'M SO I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
COLLEAGUES MIGUEL SANTIAGO WINDY
CORREO AND CHRISTINA GARCIA WHO
WILL EACH PROVIDE SOME
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS AND I
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO IN.
REVERSE ORDER HOWEVER YOU CHOOSE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE PROBLEM.
JUST THE WAY.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN FOR
HIS CONTINUED COMMITMENT ON ON
ON THIS ISSUE YOU KNOW A LOT OF
TIMES WE FIGHT.
FOR OUR DISTRICT AND THAT
BECOMES A PRIORITY EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE PERCENT AND WE WORK FOR
THE WHOLE STATE --
BUT IT IS SPECIAL WE HAVE
SOMEONE FROM OUTSIDE OUR
DISTRICT HAS BEEN THIS COMMITTED
TO THE ISSUE.
SO I THINK YOURSELF AND YOUR
STAFF WHO ALSO HAVE BEEN I
INSTRUMENTALIST AND THIS WORK.
AND ARE MY PEERS AS WELL OVER
HERE WHO HAVE ALL BEEN CHAMPIONS
AND THIS ISSUE.
LIKE THE SPEAKER SAID WE'VE HAD
MULTIPLEHEARINGS AND HER FIRST
ONE WITH ALMOST SIX YEARS AGO --
AND YOU KNOW THE FRUSTRATION IS
CLEAR IN THE COMMUNITY AT TIMES
IT FEELS LIKE IT'S A DOG AND
PONY SHOW AND AND ARE WE REALLY
GET ANYTHING OUT OF THIS THING
WE'VE SEEN SOME.
SOME IMPROVEMENTS ALONG THE WAY
RAY PARK WITH THATTHAN
SOMETHING THAT THE COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN ADVOCATING.
FOR AND WE SAW SOME MOTION AND
THAT FINALLY IN THIS BUDGET --
WHEN I THINK ABOUT?
THE REQUEST THIS SEEMS PRETTY
PRAGMATIC AND AND SOMETIMES I
ASK MYSELF WHY IT WAS SO HARD TO
GET THAT ONE ITEM TAKEN CARE OF
I HOPE THAT WE REALIZE THIS IS
ONE OF MANY ITEMS THAT WE NEED
TO DO.
INCLUDE AS WE HAD JUST BEEN WE
LEARN FROM THIS TIME.
ALONG THE WAY I THINK FOR MYSELF
I DON'T EXPECT.
AFFECTION BUT I I DO EXPECT THAT
WE'RE GOING WE'RE LEARNING AND
WHERE JUSTIN AT A AT A MUCH.
QUICKER RATE OUT THERE ONLY TAKE
A MOMENT AND THANK THE COMMUNITY
AND THE ACTIVISTS IN THE GROUPS
THAT HAVE BEEN.
A VOICE LONG BEFORE I JOINED
DESPITE.
YOU HAD FOLKS LIKE MOTHERS EVERY
SALLY EAST YARD CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AGAINST TOXICS.
THE RESURRECTION CHURCH WHO IS
ALSO HERE HEALTHINESS TODAY BUT
ONO AND NUMEROUS OTHER GROUPS
AND INDIVIDUALS.
TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT THE FIGHT
TO MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE PROVIDE
AN AND NO ONE'S LEFT BEHIND.
THERE'S A BIG FEAR THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CLEAN UP HE'S BEHIND WE
KNOW THAT A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS LEAVES
COMMUNITIES BEHIND.
THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSIONS OF HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE WE DON'T DO THAT
AND AND A COUPLE OF YEARS WITH
THE HELP OF LEADERSHIP IN BOTH
HOUSES IN OUR SPEAKER.
WE PASS A BATTERY FEE BILL TO
HELP INSURE SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS THEIR I THINK WE NEED TO
MOVE FROM THIS ISSUE TO ENSURE
THE FLYERS ARE LEFT THERE FOR
CLEAN UP AND AND NOT FOR OTHER.
THINGS ALONG THE WAY. FOR THE
COMMUNITY.
I WANT TO SAY THAT I UNDERSTAND
YOUR FRUSTRATION WHEN I SEE THE
PLAN THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS AT THE RATE
WE'RE GOING TO CLEAN UP THE JUST
THE FIRST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
BONES.
I WORRY ABOUT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT CONTENIDO IN THOSE HOMES WE
THOUGHT THAT WE ARE AT A WOMAN
FELT HER NAME IS ANGIE SHE WAS
MY CONSTITUENTS.
USUALLY HAPPY THAT HER YARD HAD
FINALLY BEEN CLEANED UP.
I ASKED HER HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS AND SHE SAID WELL I FOUND
OUT OVER TWO YEARS AGO.
THAT I HAD OVER ONE THOUSAND
PARTS PER MILLION AND HOT TOPIC
THAT WAS.
IN FOR TWO YEARS ACTUALLY DID
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON I HAD TO DO SOME FOLLOW
UP AND I JUST HAPPENSTANCE
WRITING TO SOMEONE THAT WAS ABLE
TO HELP ME TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
IN ITS CLEAN NOW AND I ASKED HER
FOR TWO YEARS HAVE YOU HAD YOUR
DOORS CLOSED IN YOUR WINDOWS
CLOSED IN THE STATE INCITING YOU
MAKE SURE THE DOGS ARE TRACKING
ANYTHING IN AND YOUR KIDS AND
YOUR GRANDKIDS ARE LIKE IN THEIR
SHOES IN YOUR TESTING EVERY DAY.
AND SHE WAS LIKE OF COURSE NOT
THAT'S NOT FEASIBLE OTHER FAMILY
SERBIAN SOLDIERS CLOSE YOUR
DOORS JUST CLOSE YOUR WINDOWS.
IN THIS HEAT ON ANYTHING --
IN KEEP WAITING KEEP WAITING TWO
YEARS FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS
WHATEVER IS GOING TO TAKE AND I
START THINKING MAYBE WHEN YOU
START THINKING OF SOME OTHER
ALTERNATIVES MAYBE WE NEED TO
START MOVING SOME PEOPLE OUT
WHILE WE DO THIS IF THIS IS.
THE REALITY OF HOW IT'S GOING TO
BE AND IT'S NOT GOING TO GET ANY
BETTER.
ALL AND SO I WORRY ABOUT THE
HEALTH IMPACTS ON ON THESE
COMMUNITIES AND WHILE ANGIE WAS
HAPPY THAT WE CLEAN THE PER YARD
AND SHE FELT SATISFIED.
AS ALSO MAKES ME SAD THAT SOME
SAY THE COMMUNITY WHO HAS LEFT
BEHIND HAS BEEN LEFT BEHIND WHO
HAS BEEN TREATED LIKE A
WASTELAND.
THIS CONTEST YOU IN THREE LIKE
WITH DISPOSABLE.
ARE GOING TO BE SATISFIED WITH A
LITTLE WHEN WE KNOW THAT THE
REALITY THAT DESERVE A LOT MORE.
I AM CONFIDENT IN THE TALENT
BETWEEN THE STATE THE COUNTY THE
CITY SAID THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
WE CAN DO IT BETTER I AM EXCITED
THAT WE DO HAVE SOME AMAZING
COLLEAGUES.
A C. HAVE A PEER WHO HAD BEEN
CHAMPIONS --
AND AND OUR COFFEE TRYING TO
FIND WAYS TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE
AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO TO
CONTINUE WORKING VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF OUR SPEAKER --
AND OUR CHAIRMAN MISTER SOMEDAY
ONE MISSED GOTTA GO FOR THE
ADVOCACY THAT THEY DO ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE WE WE DO IT
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE CARRY ON THANK YOU.
A GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME IT'S
A PRIVILEGE TO BE UP HERE WITH
CHAMPIONS OF IN MY FAMILY
JUSTICE TONIGHT I WISH THAT IT
WERE BETTER CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
MAYBE PERHAPS FOR MEETING FOR
THE FIRST TIME AS I AM.
RECENTLY ELECTED INTO THIS ROLE
THE EXIDE BATTERY CLEAN UP IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT I
WANTED TO JUMP IN THIS IS A
COMMUNITY THAT I HAVE GROWN UP
IN THAT I LIVE IN I HAVE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS THAT LIVE HERE.
AND EVEN IF I DIDN'T I'D STILL
BE FIGHTING BECAUSE I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT IT'S ONE OF THE WORST
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTERS AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN.
AND YET.
THE VERY PEOPLE VERY FEW PEOPLE
ACTUALLY KNOW ABOUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE
THAT MADE TONIGHT POSSIBLE
INCLUDING RESURRECTION
RESURRECTION CHURCH FOR OPENING
ITS DOORS AND ALLOWING THIS FACE.
AND THIS DIALOGUE TO ACTUALLY
HAPPEN.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES
EXIDE BATTERY RECYCLING FACILITY
HAS EXPOSED FAMILIES AND
RESIDENTS TO DANGEROUS LEVELS OF
LEAD.
WE KNOW THAT EVEN A SMALL
PERCENTAGE SON OF LETTUCE
DANGEROUS SO THE LEVELS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
THEIR HORRIFIC FOR THIS
COMMUNITY IF YOU THINK ABOUT
CHILDREN PREGNANT MOTHERS OR
PREGNANT WOMEN X. SOON TO BE
EXPECTING.
AND WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL PREVENTION
IDENTIFIED LED TO BE THE POTENT.
NEUROTOXIN WITH NO SAFE LEVEL OF
EXPOSURE.
THAT IS EXTREMELY HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCE KNOWS KNOWN TO CAUSE
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
LEARNING PROBLEMS AND EVEN SLOW
PHYSICAL GROWTH IN YOUNG
CHILDREN.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE CLEAN UP
THIS HAZARDOUS THIS HAZARD AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THE NEGLIGENCE THAT HAS BEEN.
PREVAILING IN THIS COMMUNITY
THAT HAS FOR QUITE TOO LONG BEEN
DISENFRANCHISED.
IS CRIMINAL AND SO WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND NOW THAT
WE ARE.
NOW WE HAVE TO ASK THE QUESTION
WHY IT'S TAKEN SO LONG.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN MENTIONED THE HOMES THE
PARKWAYS THE GRASS THE SOIL THE
SIDEWALKS HAVE ALSO LARGELY BEEN
NEGLECTED.
I WAS TOLD WHEN I FIRST.
GOT INTO OFFICE AND STARTED
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT EXCITED
THAT EVERYTHING THAT COULD
POSSIBLY BE DONE HAD ALREADY
BEEN DONE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT TO BE TRUE.
SCRATCHED THE SURFACE OF WHAT IT
TRULY MEANS TO LOOK AT THIS AS
AN ENVIRONMENTAL --
HARM TO THIS COMMUNITY AND WHAT
WE CAN DO TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF LEVELS
HAVE SAFETY AND DIGNITY AND
PROSPEROUS HEALTHY LIVES IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
WE'RE NOT ONLY LOOKING AT EXIDE
OVER LOOKING AT EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT HAS IMPACTED THIS COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY FOR FAR TOO LONG.
THE UNFORTUNATE MINIMAL PROGRESS
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF TALK TALK
THAT SUBSTANTIAL.
THAT HAS BEEN MADE WITH THIS
CLEAN UP IS REALLY QUITE FRANKLY
UNACCEPTABLE IF THIS COMMUNITY
LOOKED ANY DIFFERENT.
THAN THE COMMUNITY THAT LIVES
HERE.
I CAN ALMOST GUESS THAT THAT
CLEAN UP WOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
MUCH FASTER.
AND THAT IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
TO CONSIDER.
DISCOURSE IS IMPORTANT OVER THE
BRIEF TIME THAT I'VE BEEN IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY HAD BEEN
COMMITTED TO LISTENING.
LEARNING ESPECIALLY ON THIS
ISSUE I HAVE ALSO SPOKEN TO THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
LEADING THE CHARGE OF THIS CLEAN
UP AND I WANT TO THANK FATHER
JOHN READ UP FOR LEADING THAT
CHARGE HIM FOR OPENING UP SPACE
BECAUSE THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN DO.
IS LISTEN TO THE CONSTITUENTS
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE THAT WE
ACTUALLY REPRESENT.
AND HOPEFULLY DO THE RIGHT THING
AND DO IT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN LIVE HEALTHY
LIVES.
DR JILL JOHNSON IS ALSO A LEADER
THAT I WANT TO RECOGNIZE SEEKING
ANSWERS OF BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY HER STUDIES.
HAVE FOUND TO BE ALIGNED WITH
THE HEALTH CONCERNS THAT EXIDE --
HAS PREVAILED IN THIS COMMUNITY.
I AM DETERMINED --
WITH THE COORDINATION BETWEEN
OUR COMMUNITIES STATE LEADERS
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT FUNDS
ARE BEING USED IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO MISS GARCIA'S
POINT TODAY WE DID MEET WITH
RIGHT WHETHER WHAT WITH THE
PRESIDENT TODAY.
WE ALSO MET WITH WORKERS.
SOME OF WHOM HAVE STUDIED UNDER
LABORERS LOCAL THREE HUNDRED
SOME HAVE.
JOIN THE UNION FOR THIS WORK
SOME HAVE AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
WORK IS BEING DONE TO A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT MOVING FORWARD THESE
WORKERS.
ARE ACTUALLY USING THE SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
DO THIS WORK IT'S CONCERNING TO
ME.
THAT A PROJECT THAT HAS HIGH
LEVELS OF LEAD.
IS BEING DONE.
WITHOUT THE PROTECTION NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT THE PEOPLE DOING
THIS WORK.
ARE PROTECTED AGAINST ANY
ADDITIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS
TO THEMSELVES.
SO I'D BE VERY INTERESTED IN IN
LEARNING ABOUT THAT PROCESS AND
LEARNING TO ENSURE THAT THE THE
WORKERS WHO ARE DOING THIS CLEAN
UP.
ARE ALSO OF FOLLOWING THE SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT THEY NEED SO THAT
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT CANCER
LEVEL RATES.
ARE BASED ON THE PEOPLE THAT DID
THIS WORK SO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
IT FROM POINT A TO POINT C. AND
EVERYBODY THAT'S INCLUDED IN
BETWEEN.
SO AGAIN I THINK YOU FOR COMING
HERE I THINK ON THE THE CHAIRMAN
FOR PUTTING THIS.
THIS HEARING TOGETHER AND I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC ON WHAT
WE CAN DO TO ENSURE THAT WE MOVE
THIS FORWARD AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
AND FINALLY WE GO FROM HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK YOU --
FOR BRING IN THIS --
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IT'S IT'S
AN INCREDIBLY POINT ONE MISTER
SPEAKER WITHOUT DOUBT UP YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN HELPING US TO
SHEPHERD --
THE DOLLARS TO MAKE THIS CLEAN
UP AVAILABLE TO US AND BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES MISS CORREO AND MISS
GARCIA FOR CHAMPION IN THIS
ISSUE --
YEAR AFTER YEAR UP BUT THERE'S
NO DOUBT THAT THAT THIS
COMMUNITY --
WHO HAS SUFFERED FOR OVER THIRTY
THREE YEARS OF WHAT'S NOW KNOWN
AS THE WORST ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER ON THE WEST COAST?
AND LET'S CALL FOR IT IS.
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM THIS WOULD
NOT HAPPEN ANYWHERE ELSE.
IT WILL NOT BE TOLERATED
ANYWHERE ELSE.
AND WE WE HAVE NOW FOX.
NOT ONLY TO STOP IT.
BUT WE NOW FIGHTING TO CONTINUE
TO CLEAN IT UP.
AND WE OWE A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
TO EACH AND EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY MEMBER WHO HAS BEEN
HERE.
YEAR AFTER YEAR MEETING AFTER
MEETING.
TOILING CAN TO CONTINUE IN THE
FIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD IS CLEANED UP.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE I'D LIKE
TO THANK WHO WERE IN IN THE
AUDIENCE --
BUT ONE IN PARTICULAR WHICH IS A
FATHER MORENO.
WHO HAS BEEN THAT ONE CHAMPION
OVER AND OVER AND OVER IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD WHEN THERE'S BEEN
AN INJUSTICE DONE?
HE'S NOT ONE TO TALK ABOUT
HIMSELF ON BUT I THINK IT'S
WORTH MENTIONING --
THAT IF THERE'S MODERN DAY
SCENES WE WE ARE CERTAINLY
SEEING ONE ON IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND SO THANK YOU.
FATHER MAHRATTA FOR HELPING THAT
TO BE THAT CHAMPION NOT TODAY'S
BEEN A LONG DAY WHAT WE HAVE
GONE OUT AND WE ARE VIEWED --
HOMES ARE BEING TESTED HOMES ARE
BEING CLEANED UP AND TALK TO
NEIGHBORS --
AND SEEN HOMES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE THAT ARE IN THE PROCESS.
I END UP FOR THAT I WANT TO
THANK THE COUNTY WHO WORKED WITH
US TODAY AND SUPERVISORS POLICE
WHO REALLY PUT A LOT OF EFFORT
INTO COLLABORATING WITH THE
STATE MAKING SURE --
THAT THEY'RE DOING THEIR SHARE
THAT TO CONTINUE YES HE FOR
COMING DOWN AS WELL --
AND HELPING TO WORK THROUGH THIS
BUT BUT LET'S LET'S NOT MAKE ANY
MISTAKES ABOUT THIS LET'S BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHY WE'RE HERE.
IT'S A VERY VERY SIMPLE GOAL AND
WE SAT IN THE VERY BEGINNING.
IT IS TO CLEAN UP THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE QUICKEST
POSSIBLE WAY AT THE HIGHEST
QUALITY LEVEL.
AND I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN BECAUSE
IT'S NOT IMPORTANT IT'S TO CLEAN
UP THIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
IN THE HIGHEST QUALITY WEIGHT.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
AFTER TODAY AND PART OF THIS
REALLY.
THIS REALLY IS IS HOLDING A
HIGHER STANDARD OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
HOLDING A HIGHER STANDARD OF
WHAT WE DEMAND IN THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND HOLDING --
HOLDING THE DETAILS HE
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS DONE IN THE FASTEST.
POSSIBLE WAY IN THE HIGHEST
QUALITY WAY BECAUSE WE DESERVE
NO DIFFERENT THAN PORTER RANCH
WE DESERVE NO DIFFERENT THAN ANY
OTHER PART IN THIS COUNTRY.
WHO WOULD HAVE THIS CLEANED UP
IMMEDIATELY --
AND I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT EAT THEM INCREDIBLE
DELAYED WHICH HAS GOT TO STOP
BOTTLES --
NO DOES THIS SCENE OF
CHRISTIANITY UNETHICAL MONEY NOT.
LOVE AROUND A SINGLE COME
PURENESS NPR MOST OF THE HE GOT
THEM TO THE GAZA SOLICIT BUT
HE'S NOT GOING TO TELL YOU THAT
I HAVE ON THIS PROGRAM MUST.
AND THE FIRST POLYGRAPH HISPANIC
YOUTH AND DOES CONSULT THOSE --
YET BUT THERE'S PEOPLE ON ONE
MORE DAY LIKE IN THE STAGGERED
THE WHICH GETTING DOWN TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT IS.
ON AN INDIVIDUAL IF THAT'LL STOP
MOST INNOVATIVE.
TOO MUCH A LEGAL AND A MUSCLE
RAPIDO POSSIVEL.
FANTASTIC RATTLES CANISTERS
COLLETTA FACT DE ESPANA JUNGLE
GOTTA YET BUT I THINK WHAT I
COULDSEE LEAVING US TO BE SEEN
VALUE.
AND IN MODEL KITS HAD DIGGING UP
ON ALSO DOES IT GIVE YOU PUT
THEM ON THE BEAT AND THE NEED
NOT.
BE IN THIS TESTIMONY THAT IS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
DOLLAR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE
WE WANT TO THANK YOU AND LET'S
GET TO WORK.
THANK YOU A FAMILY MEMBER AND
THANK YOU.
FOR SPEAKING IN SPANISH WHICH
REMINDED ME TO TELL EVERYONE
THAT WE HAVE TRANSLATION
SERVICES AVAILABLE THERE ARE
HEADPHONES IN THE BACK OF THE
ROOM -- IF
YOU SO DESIRE.
ON IT IS NOW TO INTRODUCE FOR
HER COMMENTS SUPERVISOR HILDA SO
THESE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THINK OF
FATHER BERETTA FOR OPENING UP.
THE RESURRECTION CHURCH AND TO
ALL THE PRISONERS AND TO THE
COMMUNITY FIRST AND FOREMOST.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL OUR
CHAIRMAN RICHARD BLOOM FOR
HAVING THIS UP.
AUDACIOUS.
COMMITTEE COME HERE TODAY AND
ALSO TO OUR SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON WHO HAS JUST BEEN AN
OUTSTANDING.
LEADER AND PROVEN THAT IT TAKES
IT TAKES REAL LEADERSHIP. TO BE
ABLE TO CONVENE THIS TYPE OF
ROUND TABLE DISCUSSION AND TO
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
AND TO DO IT IN A MANNER THAT
ACTUALLY HELPS TO BUILD
COALITIONS AND I'M PROUD TO BE
HERE TO REPRESENT THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES I'M GLAD.
GLAD THAT OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ARE HERE WHO ARE.
HAVE BEEN TAKING NOTES US A
STRONG LEADERSHIP ROLE AND I
WANT TO THANK DTS.
SEE FOR BEING HERE BARBER IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU HERE AND TO MATT
AND TO MISTER NICE SAMMY I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMING HERE.
BUT I THINK OUR COMMUNITY WANTS
ANSWERS AND WE DID TAKE A GOOD
TOUR OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND THAT IS I THINK THE STARK
DIFFERENCE.
TODAY.
THIS THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THROUGH ACTION THAT THE SPEAKER
RENTED AND I HAD.
THAT HE SUGGESTED HAVING THIS
HEARING OUT HERE AND HAVING
OTHER ELECTED OFFICIALS COME AND
PARTICIPATE AND NOT JUST.
NOT JUST HERE BUT ALSO SEE
VIVIDLY DESCRIPTIONS OF HOW
PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN THESE WHAT
I CALL DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS TAKING A
LOT OF TIME.
BUT I HAVE PATIENCE.
AND I HAVE PERSISTENCE AND I SEE
MY COMMUNITY IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A LOT OF OPTIMISM
TODAY.
AND I HOPE THE MOVING FORWARD WE
WILL BE ABLE TO COME TO SOME
RESOLUTIONS ON CLEANING PARKWAYS.
FINDING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND
MONEY IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
COUNTY AND DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN IN OUR POWER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE EXPEDITE THIS PROCESS IN
THE MOST EFFICIENT MANNER.
AND THAT WE CONTINUE ON IN THIS
DISCUSSION SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM OTHER PRESENTATION
THAT THE TSC WILL BE PROVIDING --
AND ALSO FOR MORE MEMBERS AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY FROM OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THIS IS THIS
IS OUR FLINT MICHIGAN.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
AND THE ONLY THING I CAN SAY IS
I'M OFTEN ASKED WHAT DO YOU
EXPECT TO SEE OUT OF THIS
HEARING.
I HOPE TO SEE SOME WISDOM.
SOME COMPASSION.
SOME RESOLUTION.
AND SOME AFFECTED PLANNED FOR
REMEDIATION.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I'M
ASKING FOR AND TO LISTEN TO THE
VOICES THAT HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PRESENT.
IN SACRAMENTO AT HEARINGS BUT
pKNOWING THAT THEIR VOICES WILL
BE HEARD HERE TODAY THAT GIVES
ME A SENSE THAT THEY ARE BEING
RESPECTED.
AND I REALLY WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
COMING HERE AND I THINK FATHER
READ IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR BEING
HERE WHICH YOU SEEM LIKE A THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ON THE
TOUR THAT WE TOOK TODAY FOLKS
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE JOINING
US THIS EVENING THAT --
ALL OF US FROM THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AND SUPERVISOR US A
LEASE OTHER FOLKS JOINED US ON A
TOUR WHERE WE SAW SOME OF THE
HOMES THAT ARE IN THE MIDST OF
REMEDIATION WITHIN A WEEK DOES
IT AT OTHER.
COMMUNITY HEALTH CLINIC GOT A
THAT'S NEARBY AND REALLY GOT A
FEEL FOR BOTH WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ITSELF SO --
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US I'M AND
NOW IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL
COUNCILMEMBER JOSE WHOSE ARE
FROM THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
CHAIR BLOOM AND OUR SPEAKER AND
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING TO THE
COMMUNITY --
HERE ARE WHERE THIS COMMITTEE
NOW HE FACES --
THIS --
ENVIRONMENTAL CATASTROPHE BUT
MANY OTHER SOCIAL INJUSTICES
THAT THIS COMMUNICATIVE USED TO
FIGHT MEANS A LOT TO OUR
COMMUNITY FOR YOU TO BE HERE --
IN IN A ROOM WHERE MANY OF US TO
DISCUSSIONS OFTEN HAPPEN WHERE
MANY PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR
ANSWERS AND DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
GO FOR THOSE ANSWERS AND HERE WE
ARE TODAY HE MEANS A LOT. TO
STRONG MESSAGE SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
MONTH'S YOUR MAHRATTA AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE RESURRECTION
CHURCH AND THE ADVOCATES WHO
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THIS ISSUE
FOR MANY MANY.
YEARS AND QUITE FRANKLY IT IS
HEARTBREAKING TO HEAR OF PEOPLE
WHO FALL ILL AND DON'T KNOW WHAT
CAUSED THAT ON THIS.
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOOKING MEMBERS ARE OUR
STRUGGLE WITH CANCER IT'S QUITE
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE WHEN
FAMILIES TELL THE CHILDREN DON'T
GO PLAY OUTSIDE.
BECAUSE IT MAY BE CONTAMINATED
WITH LET LET'S STAY INDOORS
INSTEAD THAT IS VERY
HEARTBREAKING AND NO ONE WOULD
WANT TO LIVE UNDER THOSE
CONDITIONS.
AS ICE OUT HERE SAT HERE LISTEN
TO OTHER PREVIOUS SPEAKERS I DO
AGREE WITH THEM WHEN THEY SAY IF
THE COLOR OF THESE CHILDREN WERE
ANY DIFFERENT WOULD WE HAVE THE
SAME SLOPE RESPONSE AS WE SEE
HERE TODAY.
I AGREE WITH THAT BECAUSE NO
WHERE HAD WE SEEN THIS TYPE OF
SLOW RESPONSE WHEN WE DOAGREE
IT'S ONE OF THE LARGEST CLEANUPS.
LET'S PUT ALL OF US TOGETHER AND
GET TO WORK AND MAKE THIS
CLEANUP HAPPEN.
I TAKE THIS PERSONALLY BECAUSE I
GREW UP IN A BALL HEIGHTS.
MY MOTHER STILL LIVES HERE
WITHIN THE ONE POINT SEVEN MILE
THAT IS BEING CLEANED UP AND WE
ARE OFTEN ASK OURSELVES WHAT IS
AFFECTING OUR FAMILIES THAT TO
MY DAUGHTER WHO DID CONTRACT
CANCER.
WE SEE NEIGHBORS WHO WE HAVE A
HIGHER INCIDENCE OF PEOPLE
CONTRACTING CANCER THAN OTHER
AREAS WHO DO NOT LIVE IN THIS
AREA.
GIVEN ALL THE CONTAMINATION THAT
HAS HAPPENED WHETHER IT'S EXCITE
OR OTHER AREAS.
WE NEED TO PUT AN URGENCY TO
THIS SUCH AS THE HUMAN
CATASTROPHE THAT WE ARE SEEING.
IN JUNE I ASKED DIRECTOR LEAD TO
COME TO LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL
AND APPEAR BEFORE THE PLANNING
COMMITTEE WHICH I CHAIR. TO SEE
IF WE COULD SEE SOME OF THESE
ANSWERS AND THANK YOU SO MUCH --
DIRECTLY FOR BEING THERE.
AT THAT TIME WELL WE GOT MORE
CLEAR INFORMATION WE SAW THAT
THERE'S MUCH MORE WORK TO DO.
AND WHAT WE ARE TOLD AT THAT
TIME IS THAT OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED HOMES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR CLEAN UP WE'VE
ONLY IDENTIFIED FUNDING FOR
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND
THEY'RE STILL.
FIVE THOUSAND THAT WE DON'T KNOW
HOW WE WILL CLEAN THOSE UP.
WE WERE TOLD AT THAT TIME THAT
WE WILL SEE TO CLEAN THAT UP
WELL FOLKS EXCITED IN BANKRUPTCY.
THAT IS PROBABLY NOT A PLACE WE
WILL GET THAT TWENTY WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN OF FINANCIAL
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WITH THIS
REAL TIME LINE AS TO WHEN WE
KNOW WHAT THIS WILL ALL BE.
CLEANED UP.
ON THE CITY LEVEL WE'RE HERE TO
HELP.
WE HAVE BY EXPEDITING GRADY
PERMITS I WORKED WITH THE
BUILDING AND SAFETY DEPARTMENT
TO STREAMLINE THE GRADING PERMIT
PROCESS TO DESIGNATE ONE PLAN
CHECKER TO ENSURE THAT PERMITS
ARE PROVED THE SAME DAY.
THEY ARE SUBMITTED FOR ALL THIS
WORK THAT IS BEING DONE WITHIN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
OUR HOUSING DEPARTMENT IS READY
TO COORDINATE LEAD BATE BASEMENT
IN HOMES WITH PTSD CLEANUPS WE
ARE WAITING FOR THE TSC TO SIGN
ON THAT AGREEMENT.
AND WE ARE MAKING SURE THAT
WITHIN THE ONE POINT SEVEN MILE
RADIUS THAT WE ARE FLAGGING ANY
CONSTRUCTION OR DEMOLITION.
WITHIN THOSE AREAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE REDUCE AIRBORNE DUST SO
THAT WE DO NOT CONTINUE TO
CONTAMINATE THE AREAS.
THE CITY IS HERE TO HELP BUT
LIKE ALL OF US WE ARE FRUSTRATED
WE WANT MORE IMMEDIATE ACTION WE
WANT A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST --
LET ME SAY THIS.
SEVERAL THE SPEAKERS ALSO
MENTIONED ABOUT OUR CHILDREN WHO
ARE MORE VULNERABLE TO THIS TYPE
OF CONTAMINATION.
NEWBORNS TO THE AGE OF SIX ARE
DEVELOPING THEIR BRAINS ARE
DEVELOPING FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA TELL THOSE
CHILDREN WHO WERE BORN NOW THE
NEXT SIX YEARS WE TELL THEM
WE'LL GET TO YOU? TWO YEARS
THREE YEARS FIVE SIX FROM YES WE
NOW.
WHILE WE WAIT AND WAIT AND WAIT
GET MORE DELAYS MORE DELAYS MORE
DELAYS.
THEIR LIVES ARE AT STAKE LET'S
GET TO WORK AND GET THIS DONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU COUNCILMEMBER.
THANK YOU WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST PANEL THE
PANEL IS --
ON THE STATUS OF THE EXCITED
CLEAN UP.
WE'RE OLD I HEAR FROM SECRETARY
MATT RODRIGUEZ OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
DIRECTOR BARBARA LEE WHO IS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR MOTION IS THE ME ALSO
WITH DGSE --
HE IS --
SPECIALIST AN ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
PRESENTATION AND LET ME JUST
AGAIN ACKNOWLEDGE.
OUR LEADER SPEAKER RENDON FOR
BEING HERE --
AND AS WE WERE SITTING HERE HE
LEANED OVER TO ME AND SAID I
THINK THIS IS REALLY COOL --
WE SAID YOU KNOW MY MOM AND DAD
WERE MARRIED IN THIS VERY ROOM --
IT SPEAKS TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
YOU ARE THAT WE ARE AND TO SO
THANKS FOR SHARING THAT.
WELL THAT'S HARD TO FOLLOW BUT
LET ME TRY --
I I DO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE SPEAKER.
OF FATHER JOHN IN THE COMMUNITY.
FOR YOU KNOW GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY -- YOU
DON'T LET THE LET THERE BE NO
DOUBT --
CLEANING UP THE CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES AROUND THE EXACT
FACILITY --
IS --
DETAILS HIS HIGHEST PRIORITY.
AND WE APPRECIATE VERY DEEPLY
THE CHANCE TO BE HERE TODAY TO
DESCRIBE TO YOU THE STATUS OF
THE CLEAN UP.
AND HAVE THIS DISCUSSION WITH
YOU AND HERE --
AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED --
WE HAVE THE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DNC OF ARE REALLY HERE TODAY --
IN THE DTC DEPUTY DIRECTOR MOST
AND AS YOU ME UP WHO'S BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY ON THE EX I
CLEAN UP --
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS WERE IDENTIFIED BY THE
COMMITTEE --
AND SO I WE DON'T WANT TAKE AN
AWFUL LOT OF YOUR TIME WHAT WE
WANNA DO IS DO A VERY BRIEF
POINTED CONCISE PRESENTATION SO
YOU CAN SEE WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING.
AND THEN NOW THAT WILL ALLOW YOU
TO ASK QUESTIONS AND THEN ALSO
ALLOWS HERE FROM THE US FROM THE
COMMUNITY SO --
WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER --
TO MOSAN AND THEN I WAS IN SOME
CLEAN UP COMMENTS AT THE END OF
THIS.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON AND MY
NAME IS NO SIN IS IN ME AND I'M
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FORESIGHT
MEDIATION AND RESTORATION
PROGRAM WE DO TSC.
THANK YOU AGAIN --
FOR CHAIRMAN BLOOM FOR INVITING
US THAT THIS OVERSIGHT HEARING --
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
PRESENTATION ON THE STATUS OF
THE TEARS HE RESIDENTIAL CLEAN
UP.
AS YOU HEARD THIS IS THE LARGEST
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ONE OF THE LARGEST IN THE NATION --
THE TEARS SE'S MISSION IS TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENT AND WE TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE EXITE FACILITY.
AND WE DO THAT BY RESTORING THE
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED BY RELEASES
FROM FORMER EXCITE FACILITY.
ATTACKING THE PUBLIC AND SAFETY
OF PEOPLE IN THESE COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY THE YOUNGEST AND MOST
VULNERABLE.
AND WE WANT TO ENGAGE THEIR
RESIDENTS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
AND OFFERING THEM OPPORTUNITIES
FOR NOT ONY WORK TRAINING.
BUT ALSO TO BE INFORMED AND BE
WITH US EVERY STEP OF THE CLEAN
UP.
AS PART OF THE CLEANUP TEDIOUS
HE HAS SAMPLED ALL THE
PROPERTIES IN THAT PRELIMINARY
INVESTIGATION AREA OR PA I A
WHICH IS AN AREA OF ONE POINT
SEVEN MILE RADIUS AROUND EXCITE
FACILITY.
WHERE THE PROPERTY OWNERS ARE
RESIDENTS HAVE GRANTED US ACCESS
TO CONDUCT OUR SAMPLING? TO
DATES THE TEARS HE HAS COLLECTED
SOIL SAMPLES FROM OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PARCELS
AND CONTINUES TO TAKE SAMPLES
HAS ADDITIONAL ACCESSES FOR
SAMPLING IS GRANTED TO US.
THERE ARE ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED PARCELS HOWEVER THAT
WITHIN THE PIAA THAT ACCESS FOR
SAMPLING HAS NOT BEEN PROVIDED.
DESPITE OF MORETHAN SEVEN TIMES
ATTEMPTS FOR EACH ONE OF THOSE
PROPERTIES TO GAIN ACCESS.
THE TSA HAS REVIEWED VERIFIED
AND ANALYZE MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DATA POINTS
FROM THE SAMPLES THAT WE HAVE
COLLECTED.
AND PROVIDED.
THAT INFORMATION TO ALLOW US TO
I OR TIES CLEAN UP FOR THESE
PROPERTIES.
SAMPLING DATA HAS BEEN SHARED
WITH PROPERTY OWNERS AND
RESIDENTS AND INPUT ON IT THE
TSC WEBSITES WITH AN INTERACTIVE
MAP THAT ALLOWS.
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND OTHERS
TO REVIEW THE PARCEL SPECIFIC
DATA AND SAMPLING RESULTS.
I USING THIS ALL SAMPLE RESULTS
AS OF EARLY THIS WEEK THE TSC IS
CLEANED UP OVER THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY PARCELLS AND CONTINUES TO
CLEAN UP PROPERTIES.
UNDER TO APPROVE CLEANUP PLAN
AND CLEAN UP CONTRACTS.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE CLEAN UPS
CONTINUE UNINTERRUPTED DTS HE
HAS CONDUCTED CLEANUP PLANNING
MEETINGS AND SCHEDULING
DISCUSSIONS.
WITH RESIDENTS AND HAS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED PARTS THERE'S ACTUALLY
LINED UP FOR CLEANUP WORK.
THIS PROVIDES GREATER
FLEXIBILITY FOR DTS SEAT.
CLUSTER CLEANUPS IN AN AREA AND
BETTER SCHEDULING YOU KNOW TO
MAKE THE CLEANUPS MORE EFFICIENT.
USING THE EXPERIENCE DTCS GAIN
FROM THESE CLEANUPS.
ARE WE HAVE AS OF THIS WEEK OVER
THIRTEEN CRUISE OUT IN THE FIELD.
WE'RE CONTINUOUSLY INCREASING
THEIR RATE OF OUR CLEANUPS AT
PRESENTLY WE SCHEDULE TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN PARCELS PER WEEK.
AND THIS IS INCREASED FROM JULY
WHERE WE WERE SCHEDULING TEN TO
TWELVE AND JUNE.
FIVE TO TEN WHEN WE HAD --
OUR NEW CONTRACT.
WE INTEND TO CONTINUE THAT CLEAN
UP AND ENTER UP ON INTERRUPTED
AND TO INCREASE THE CLEAN
OPERATE.
CONTINUE TO CLEAN UP FOR THE
PRIORITIZE PROPERTY.
WE ARE ALSO CONTINUING MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR CONTRACT
PERFORMANCE IN RESPOSE TO SOME
OF THE SITE SPECIFIC ISSUES AND
COMMUNITY INPUT.
BESIDES THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
OPERATOR TRAINING OR HAS WHOPPER
AND OTHER TRAININGS WE HAVE
EXPANDED CONTRACTOR TRAINING TO
INCLUDE LET CERTIFICATION EVEN
THOUGH THAT IS NOT A REQUIREMENT.
BUT ALSO WE HAVE PROVIDED --
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY TRAINING
AND PROJECT SPECIFIC TRAINING.
AND A RAMP UP PERIOD ALLOWS US
TO WORK OUT THE LOGISTICS OF
INCREASING THE RATE OF CLEAN UP --
WHILE WE PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SPECIALIZED OVERSIGHT FOR USING
OUR SCIENTISTS GEOLOGISTS AND
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST.
ADDITIONAL IMPROVEMENTS ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH FIELD%
OBSERVATION AN ON SITE TRAINING
AND FEEDBACK.
THE TSA HAS ALTERED OUR CLEANUP
PREPARATION PROCESS TO START
EARLY AND REDUCE COSTS.
AT THE INITIAL MEETINGS WITH THE
PRESIDENCY TO SEE VERIFIES FIND
ACCESS AGREEMENTS THAT.
ARE IN PLACE AND COLLECT
ADDITIONAL --
SITE SPECIFIC INFORMATION AND
PROFILE.
THIS ALLOWS US TO TIMELY PROCESS
THE INFORMATION AND BE READY FOR
COMPLETE CLEANUPS MORE
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND SAVES COSTS
THE TEARS SEAT STREAMLINE THE
LANDSCAPING SELECTION
IMPLEMENTATION. TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCY PROPERTY OWNERS
REVIEWS AND SIGNS THE
RESTORATION PLAN AHEAD OF TIME.
AND PROVIDES THE ABILITY TO GET
THE MATERIAL --
IN PLACE EARLIER HAD AS A THE
TSA IS CURRENTLY ENCOURAGING
INTERIOR CLEANING.
WE HEARD ABOUT THAT THROUGHOUT
OUR TOUR JUST TODAY EVERY
RESIDENT IS OFFERED PROFESSIONAL
INTERIOR CLEANING SERVICES AS OF
EARLY THIS WEEK OVERALL.
ABOUT EIGHTY NINE OR 25% OF THE
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY PROPERTIES
CLEANED HAD --
EXCEPT THAT INTERIOR CLEANING
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT THAT
OVERALL RATE.
IS INCREASING IN RECENT MONTHS
AND WE'RE SAYING THAT
APPROACHING ALMOST FORTY OR 50%.
DTS IMPROVED INTERIOR CLEANING
PROCESS IN RESPONSE TO COMMUNITY
INPUT.
RESIDENTS ARE ENGAGED IN THEIR
EARLY PROCESS AND WE CHANGED OUR
SYSTEM --
THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE CHANGED OUR VOUCHER --
COUPON SYSTEM WHERE WE USED TO
PROVIDE THAT TO DICK RESIDENT
AND THEY WOULD HAVE TO CONTACT A
CLEANING SERVICES DIRECTLY --
WE ARE NOW PROVIDING THAT UP
FRONT THROUGH OUR OWN
SUBCONTRACTOR AND ARRANGE FOR
THAT AHEAD OF TIME.
DTS IS ALSO EXPANDED THE WORK
FORCE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION IN COMMITTEE
COMMUNITIES OR WORK PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDED TRAINING
FOR LOCAL RESIDENTS TO SAFELY
PERFORM SAMPLING AND CLEANUP
WORK IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND SUPPORT SKILL BUILDING AND
CERTIFICATION FOR LONG TERM CARE
YEARS ENVIRONMENTAL FIELDS.
DTS HE HAS NOW EXPANDED THIS
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE SOIL REMOVAL
RESTORATION AND LANDSCAPING.
WE'RE ALSO CONTRACTED WITH
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION COURTS
TO PROVIDE SIGHT RESTORATION OF
SELECTED PROPERTIES.
AND ESTABLISHED A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT
EARLIER AND TARGETED LOCAL
HIRING REQUIREMENTS WHICH ALSO
PROVIDES A PAT THE UNION
MEMBERSHIP FOR INTERESTED WORK
GRADUATES.
AND CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
TRAINING SIR.
AS PART OF OUR COMMUNITY
OUTREACH WE'VE EXPANDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WE HAVE DIVIDED THAT
PREVENT ANY INVESTIGATION AREA
INTO SEVEN OUTREACH ZONES.
WITH DEDICATED BILINGUAL POINT
OF CONTACT FOR EACH OUT TREATS
ON BESIDES THE REGULAR TECHNICAL
ADVISORY --
EXIDE TECHNOLOGIES ISER GROUP
MEETINGS THE TEARS HE HAS
CONDUCTED ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
PUBLIC MEETINGS AND WORKSHOPS IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
INCLUDING SPANISH TRANSLATION
FOR EACH MEETING WE'VE ALSO HELD
SPANISH LANGUAGE ONLY MEETING.
READING YOUR SAMPLING RESULTS
WORKSHOPS OTHER OTHER MEETINGS
WITH.
PUBLIC LIBRARIES AND OTHER
LOCATIONS.
IN ADDITION WE PARTICIPATE IN
NUMEROUS SMALL COMMUNITY
MEETINGS SUCH AS THE ONE THAT'S
ACTUALLY HELD HERE EVERY MONDAY
AT THE RESURRECTION CHURCH.
AND THE MONTHLY MAY WITH
COMMUNITY MEETING.
AS PART OF OUR COMMUNITY
OUTREACH WE HAVE ALSO SENT OUT
MORE THAN TWENTY DIFFERENT
MAILERS TO ANNOUNCE MEETINGS
AVAILABLE YET DOCUMENTS AND
REVIEW.
COMMENTS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND UPDATES WE USE ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND A DAY
ADDRESSES IN OUR MAILING THESE --
FOR THESE MAIL OUTS.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
A PROJECT HOTLINE THAT HAS
FIELDED OVER ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED CALLS TO THE HOTLINE.
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WE
HAVE OUR SAMPLING RESULTS ON OUR
WEBSITE TO PROVIDE.
A SPECIFIC INFORMATION FOR EACH
PROPERTY.
WE'VE ALSO ACTIVELY COORDINATED
WITH ALL LOCAL JURISDICTION WITH
A BI WEEKLY CALL THAT INCLUDES
IN ADDITION TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION ALTHOUGH ALSO STAFF
REPRESENTING ELECTED OFFICIALS.
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ALSO WE HAVE COORDINATED WITH
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AS YOU
HEARD FROM --
COUNCILMEMBER WAYS ARE FOR THEIR
SUSTAINABLE LANDSCAPING PROGRAM
AND WE'RE WORKING ON A LEAD
BASED PAINT AND PROGRAMS AS WELL.
IN ADDITION THE TSA HAS
COORDINATED WITH OUR CONTRACTOR
AND ALL AL
SOME OF THE JURISDICTIONS HAVE
MODIFIED THEIR PROCESSES TO
ISSUING KREUTZMANN AND GRADING
PERMITS.
IN ONE DAY AT NO COST OF
PROVIDING OTHER OPTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE CITY OF COMMERCE ISSUES
PERMITS SAME DAY AT NO COST.
CITIES OF BELLE HUNTINGTON PARK
AND MAY WOULD ISSUE PERMITS SAME
DAY AND ALLOW BATCH PERMITS TO
BE ISSUED.
THE THE PARKWAYS I KNOW IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US AND I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF UPDATE
ON THE PARK WAYS AS WELL.
AS YOU ALL KNOW SP EIGHT FORTY
WAS SIGNED AS PART OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
PACKED AND PROVIDED. SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING FOR
SAMPLING AND CLEAN UP A PARK
WAYS IN THE AREAS OF FORMER
EXCITE FACILITY.
HAS THE EIGHT FORTY REQUIRES THE
TSC TO SAMPLE AS MANY PARKWAYS
AS FEASIBLE ADJACENT TO THE
PROPERTY IS PRIORITIZED FOR
CLEAN UP.
UNDER DTS IS CLEAN UP PLAN AND
TO CLEAN UP PART WAYS THAT HAVE
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF LEAD.
IN THE GREATEST RISK OF EXPOSURE
IN THE PRELIMINARY INVESTIGATION
AREA.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
THESE ARE THE STEPS NECESSARY
FOR DETAILS SEE TO SAMPLE AND
CLEANUP PARKWAYS.
WE NEED TO HIRE A SAMPLING
CONTRACTOR AND DEVELOP A
SAMPLING PLAN.
CONTRACTOR WILL THEN PERFORMED A
SAMPLING AND ANALYSIS BASED ON A
SAMPLING RESULTS AND RISK
ASSESSMENT DTS HE WILL DEVELOP A
CLEANUP PLAN.
AND ASSOCIATED ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS. TO DETERMINE WHICH
PARKWAYS REQUIRED CLEAN OUT THE
KNEE TSC WILL PROCURE A CLEANUP
CONTRACTOR TO PERFORM THE
REQUIRED CLEANUP ACTIVITIES.
HERE IS A ROUGH TIME LINE TO
PERFORM THE SAMPLING WORK FOR
THE PARKWAY.
STARTING THIS MONTH WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEGAN DEVELOPMENT OF A
SCOPE OF WORK FOR SAMPLING.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
PROCURE A SAMPLING CONTRACTOR
AND BEGIN COORDINATION WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTION RELATIVE TO
THE PARKWAY?
IN FALL THE TEARS HE WILL WORK
WITH THE CONTRACTOR TO DEVELOP
THE SAMPLING AND ANALYSIS PLAN.
DEVELOP A SAMPLING SCHEDULE AND
SECURE ANY NECESSARY PERMITS
FROM LOCAL JURISDICTION AND WE
BEGIN THE SAMPLING WORK IN
JANUARY.
IN SAMPLING AND CLEAN UP THE
PARK WHICH IS THERE ARE SEVERAL
THINGS THAT THE TSC NEEDS TO
CONSIDER --
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS
FREQUENCY AND RISK ASSOCIATED
WITH DEPARTMENT.
THEN THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
RELATIVE TO THE WORKERS FOR
EXAMPLE PARKWAYS HAVE.
GREATER --
UTILITIES.
UTILITIES AND WORKERS HAVE TO
ACTUALLY WORK CLOSER TO ST SO
THEY'LL BE IN THE ROADWAYS.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE TO WORK WITH
EACH JURISDICTION SINCE THE
OWNERSHIP AND MAINTENANCE OF THE
PARKWAYS AS WELL AS PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS DIFFER.
FROM EACH JURISDICTION.
THIS TABLE IS JUST A SUMMARY OF
THE INFORMATION DTS IS
ESTABLISHED BY CONTACTING YOUR
JURISDICTION.
A TO DETERMINE OWNERSHIP
MAINTENANCE RESPONSIBILITY AND
PERMIT REQUIREMENTS AS SHOWN IN
THIS TABLE ALMOST ALL PARKWAYS
ARE OWNED BY THE CITY OR COUNTY.
BUT AS THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
PARKWAY IN SOME CASES IS SOLE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE OWNERS --
SUCH AS CITIES OF BELLE
HUNTINGTON PARK IN LOS ANGELES.
WHEREAS N OTHERS --
MAINTENANCE FOR BETWEEN THE
OWNER AND JURISDICTION SUCH AS
MAY WITHIN THE COUNTY.
ALSO THE PERMIT REQUIREMENTS
VARY FROM EACH JURISDICTION AS
SHOWN IN THIS TABLE.
THE TSA WILL PROVIDE REGULAR
UPDATES TO THE COMMUNITY AND
AFTER COMPLETION OF SAMPLING OF
THE PARKWAYS TEDIOUS HE WILL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALSO SHARE INFORMATION WITH THE
PUBLIC REGARDING.
PARKWAY SAMPLING STATUS PARTLY
CLEANUP PLAN DEVELOPMENT THAT.
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THE PARKWAY.
SO IN CONCLUSION I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT DTS IS PRIORITY
IS TO ENSURE THAT THE CLEANUP
WORK CONTINUES EXPEDITIOUSLY AND
WITHOUT INTERRUPTION.
CLEANING --
ARE CONDUCTED IN A MANNER THAT
IS SAFE AND EFFICIENT AND
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
AND FINALLY THE PROGRESS THAT
THE CLEANUP IS READILY AVAILABLE
IN A CLEAR TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE WAY.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
DIRECTLY.
YEAH AFTER DIRECTOR LEE IS SO
COMPLETE YOUR REMARKS WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR QUESTIONS OF
THIS PANEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
AS WELL AS AT FATHER JOHN AND TO
ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE SHOWN UP. TO
HEAR ABOUT OUR PROGRESS.
RESTORING THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
RELEASES FROM THE EXCITED
FACILITY.
I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY DISCUSS WITH
YOU.
THE ACTIONS DTS HE IS TAKING. TO
ENSURE THAT ONLY DOES THIS CLEAN
UP HAPPEN BUT THAT WE ADDRESS
THE LARGER COMMUNITY ISSUES FOR
ALL OF THE CONTAMINATION THAT
HAS BEEN RELEASED FROM THE YEARS
OF OPERATION AT THE EXACT SITE.
DTS HE IS ACTIVELY WORKING TO
HOLD EXCITED ACCOUNTABLE AND TO
MAKE SURE THE ACTIONS IT'S
TAKING NOW.
ARE SAFE.
WE HAVE THREE IMPORTANT EFFORTS
UNDER WAY TO DO THIS.
WE'RE OVERSEEING THE SAFE
CLOSURE.
AND A REMOVAL OF ALL OF THE
TRUCTURES AT THE EXCITED
FACILITY.
WE ARE ENSURING THAT EXCITE
CLEANS UP CONTAMINATION
RESULTING FROM THE OPERATIONS AT
THE SITE.
AND WE'RE COLLABORATING WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
RECOVER THE COST OF THE CLEANUP
WORK.
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE BY
DGSE.
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW REQUIRE
THAT EGGS I'D IDENTIFIES AND
CLEANED UP BOTH THE ON SITE AND
THE OFF SITE CONTAMINATION.
THAT HAVE RESULTED FROM
OPERATIONS THAT HAVE OCCURRED.
OVER THE HISTORY OF THE SITE.
EXIDE HAS TO COLLECT DATA. TO
CHARACTERIZE THE NATURE AND
EXTENT OF THAT OFF SITE AND ON
SITE CONTAMINATION AND THEY HAVE
TO DESCRIBE OPTIONS TO REMEDIATE
IT.
DTS HE OVERSEES ALL OF THESE
ACTIONS.
AND IT'S OUR JOB TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE CLEANUP REQUIREMENTS
WILL BE.
NORMALLY THE STATE DOESN'T FUND
CLEANUP ACTIVITIES WHEN THERE'S
A RESPONSIBLE PARTY THAT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO UNDERTAKE THAT
WORK.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THIS
COMMUNITY DIDN'T HAVE TO WAIT
FOR THE REGAL LEGAL WRANGLING
THAT WAS REFERRED TO EARLIER BY
THE MANY SPEAKERS.
GOVERNOR BROWN REQUESTED IN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED A HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF THE GENERAL FUND LOAN. TO
JUMPSTART THE CLEAN UP AND THAT
WAS FOLLOWING THE APPROVAL OF
THE SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
EXPENDITURE OUT OF DTS SEES OWN
BUDGET. TO DO SOME INITIAL WORK.
THESE FUNDS HAVE ALLOWED THE TSC
TO CLEAN UP THE MOST IMPACTED
PROPERTIES SOONER.
AND TO PROTECT THOSE WHO ARE
MOST MOST VULNERABLE TO THE
CONTAMINATION.
WHILE THIS CLEANUP WORK THAT
WE'RE OVERSEEING IS UNDER WAY.
DGSE IS ALSO OVERSEEING THE WORK
THAT EXCITE IS REQUIRED TO DO.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU JUST A
BRIEF SENSE OF THE TIMELINE. FOR
THE WORK THAT'S GOING ON TO HOLD
THE EXILED ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
CLEAN UP THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
UNDERTAKING.
EXCITE IS REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
WHAT IS CALLED A RESIDENTIAL
CORRECTIVE MEASURES STUDY. FOR
THE OFF SITE RESIDENTIAL
CONTAMINATION AND THEY HAVE TO
DO THAT BY MAY TWENTY FIRST OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS DEADLINE IS
PART OF AN ENFORCEABLE ORDER.
LAST MONTH ON JULY SIXTH DTS HE
ISSUED A CONDITIONAL APPROVAL OF
EXILES WORK PLAN TO CHARACTERIZE
THAT RESIDENTIAL CONTAMINATION
AROUND THE SITE.
AND WE DIRECTED THAT THEY TAKE
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS.
BECAUSE THERE WAS MORE WORK NEED.
OUR CONDITIONAL APPROVAL ALLOWED
INSIDE TO MAKE USE OF THE SOIL
SAMPLING DATA WE'VE ALREADY
COLLECTED IN THE PRELIMINARY
INVESTIGATION AREA.
BUT WE ALSO REQUIRED THEM. TO
IDENTIFY THE DATA GAP OUR
APPROVAL AND TO COLLECT
ADDITIONAL DATA THAT'S NEEDED TO
FULLY CHARACTERIZE THE FULL
EXTENT.
OF THE TYPE AND EXTENT OF
CONTAMINATION.
DTS YOU WILL REVIEW EXCITES
PROPOSED CLEANUP ALTERNATIVES
WILL TAKE COMMENT FROM ALL OF
YOU AND FROM ANYONE ELSE WHO IS
INTERESTED.
AND THEN WILL ISSUE A
DETERMINATION ON WHAT EXCITED
NEEDS TO DO TO CLEAN UP THAT-CONTAMINATION AS WELL AS THE
TIME LINES. FOR UNDERTAKING THAT
CLEANUP.
AFTER DTS HE APPROVES CLEANUP
ACTIONS THAT EXILED HAS TO TAKE
EXAMS REQUIRED TO PROVIDE TO US
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE FOR THE
ESTIMATED COST OF ALL OF THAT
CLEANUP ACTIVITY.
IN ADDITION THE ORDER I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY PREVENTS
EXILED FROM DRAWING DOWN ON THE
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE THEY'VE
ALREADY PROVIDED TO US.
UNTIL ALL OF THE ONSITE AND OFF
SITE CLEANUP WORK IS DONE.
DTS HE CLOSELY OVERSEAS EGGS
IDEC DVDS.
AS THEY ARE UNDER WAY NOW WE
HAVE WEEKLY CONFERENCE CALLS TO
TRACK EXCITES PROGRESS ON THEIR
CLOSURE AND ON THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE PROPOSED CLEANUP
ALTERNATIVES AND WE'VE ALSO
HIRED A THIRD PARTY CONTRACTOR
WHO MONITORS EXCITES COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CLOSURE PLAN AT ALL
TIMES THAT WORK IS UNDER WAY AT
THE FACILITY.
ESPECIALLY THEY'RE CARRYING OUT
OF THE PROVISIONS THAT PROTECT
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
DID HE HAS HE IS ALSO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO COORDINATE
ACTIVITIES AND ENSURE THAT ALL
NECESSARY STEPS ARE TAKEN. TO
HOLD EXILED ACCOUNTABLE.
WE'RE ALSO COLLABORATED WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
IDENTIFY ANY OTHER PARTIES WHO
COULD BE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE CONTAMINATION IN THE
PRELIMINARY INVESTIGATION AREA
OR ANY OF THE OTHER AREAS WHERE
EXCITES CONTAMINATION MAY BE
FOUND.
IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO
ASSURE YOU.
THE DTS YEARS WORKING DILIGENTLY.
ON MULTIPLE FRONTS. TO RESTORE
THESE COMMUNITIES. TO HOLD THE
EXILED AND ANY OTHER ACCOUNT
PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
CONTAMINATION.
AND I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS MY
DEEP APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
CONTINUED INTEREST FOR THE
INTEREST OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE LOCAL LOCALLY ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
SUPERVISORS POLICE COUNCILMEMBER
FREEZE ARE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTNERSHIP YOUR
COLLABORATION AS WE WORK
TOGETHER. TO ENSURE THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE AND HEALTHY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU END UP BEFORE WE GO TO
QUESTIONS SECRETARY RETREAT AS
WANT TO HAVE SOME CONCLUDING
COMMENTS I THINK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I AND I KNOW WHAT FORM
AND SCOUNDREL LONG PRESENTATION
SO I'LL I'LL TRY TO BE QUICK
HERE.
AS AN ADMINISTRATION --
I I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT WE MAY --
AS A MINISTRATION I'D LIKE TO
THINK WE'VE MADE GREAT STRIDES
IN PROMOTING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE --
AMONG THE MANY THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING --
WE ADOPTED THE CALAVERAS SCREEN
TOOL THAT HELPS US TO IDENTIFY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
THAT WE AND STAB WHICH A VIRAL
JUSTICE TASK FORCE TO IMPROVE
COMPLIANCE WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS IN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE AND BOYLE HEIGHTS AND
CLIMB UP --
AND WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
WE'VE DIRECTED OVER ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS --
IN FUNDING --
TO DISADVANTAGE IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
NONE THE LESS I WANT TO SAY HERE
THAT -- ONE
OF MY CHIEF CONCERNS IS THAT WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO MORE TO
ADVANCE THE CLEANUP OF THE
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE X. I.
FACILITY.
AND I I KNOW THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW I CAN
SAY THAT ON AND IT'S EASIER FOR
ME TO SAY THAT WHEN I'M NOT THE
PERSON WHO IS LIVING WITH THE
CONTAMINATION IN MY YARD SO I
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION.
IN THE COMMUNITIES.
AT ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT THE IT
REALLY HAS NOT BEEN FOR LACK OF
TRYING ON THE PART OF DTS SEE --
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE MADE.
SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENTS TO
EXPEDITE THE CLEANUP OF
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES ARE
SURROUNDING THE EXITE FACILITY --
DGSE GOT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM EXCITEMENT WAS IN
BANKRUPTCY TO CLEAN UP WHAT WE
FELT AT THE TIME WERE THE MOST
CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES CLOSEST
TO THE OTHER FORMER FACILITY --
WHEN WE FOUND OUT THEY WERE
THERE ARE MORE ISSUES THERE DGSE
USE SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM
SOME OF THE EXISTING FUNDING TO
CLEAN UP FIFTY OF THE MOST
HEAVILY CONTAMINATED UP
PROPERTIES IN THE AREA?
ON IN IN TWENTY FIFTY ONE
SAMPLING HAD SHOWN UP AT THE
CONTAMINATION WAS MORE
WIDESPREAD THAN ANYBODY
ANTICIPATED --
THE ADMINISTRATION WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO SAMPLE ESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES TO CLEAN UP THE YARD
WITH THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF THE
CONTAMINATION AND THAT'S HOW WE
CAME UP WITH THAT FIGURE.
THAT FIGURE WAS DIRECTED TO THE
EVER PROPERTIES THAT WE THOUGHT
WERE GOING TO BE AT THE THE MOST
CONTAMINATED --
AND WE DID ALL THAT AND
APPROPRIATED THAT FUND FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OF BECAUSE DTS SEES
BUDGET IS ONLY OF ROUGHLY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS A TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
FEELS LIKE TEN OR TWENTY DOLLARS
HERE SOMETIME BUT TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
ANY GIVEN YEAR SO IT'S CLEAR
THAT WE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IN ORDER TO DO THIS WORK.
NOW YOU'VE HEARD WE'RE COMMITTED
TO DOING THIS VERSUS TO WORK --
THE FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED AND THEN USE TO JUMP
START THE CLEAN UP BUT RATHER
THAN WAITING FOR EXCITED TO
DEVELOP BUT ITS PLAN OR RELYING
ON A TIME CONSUMING THE LEGAL
LOVE BATTLE TO FORCE EXCITED TO
CONDUCT THE CLEAN UP.
ON AND WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS --
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA LET UP I I
YOU KNOW I WANT TO MENTION THAT
OUT OF THE TOC STAFF OF A PROXY
NINE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES FIFTY ONE
EMPLOYEES ARE WORKING ON X. SIDE.
OF FULL TIME AND WE'VE GOT OTHER
FOLKS WHO ARE SITTING IN THE AS
NECESSARY --
NOW I KNOW I WAS DISAPPOINTED --
TO WHEN THE CONTRACT THAT FELL
THROUGH THAT WAS GOING TO DO
THIS WORK BUT WE WERE COMMITTED
TO MOVING THIS ALONG AND THAT'S
WHY WE SAID OKAY WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO STOP AT THIS POINT.
LET'S PICK UP ONE OF OUR
EXISTING CONTRACTORS TO DO SOME
WORK AND GET SOME WORK IN THE
MEANTIME WHILE WE FIX THIS
CONTRACT SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN.
AND MOSAN AS DESCRIBED HOW WE'VE
BEEN PICKING THAT UP WE'RE GONNA
GET THOSE ADDITIONAL UP --
PROPERTIES CLEANED UP AND WHEN
THAT WORK FINISHES WE WILL PICK
UP WITH THE NEW CONTRACT THAT
WILL COME IN --
TO INTO BEING HIMSELF.
IN THE END I JUST WANT PEOPLE TO
BE ASSURED THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IS OUR OBLIGATION TO ENSURE
THAT --
GOING FORWARD DTS HE WILL BE
WORKING DILIGENTLY TO STRETCH
EVERY DOLLAR AS FAR AS WE CAN GO.
TO FINISH THIS WORK AS QUICKLY
AS WE THE WHOLE THE POLLUTERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR CLEANING UP THIS
MESS THAT THAT THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT INCLUDES WORKING WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
TOLD EXCITE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
COMPLETING THIS --
CLEAN UPS UP YOU'VE GOT OUR
COMMITMENT WE'RE GOING TO WORK
ON THIS WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THIS --
AND I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO THE FINISH UP HERE MAKE THOSE
COMMENTS AND NOW WE'RE ALL.
READY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THEN
I THINK YOU LET ME A KICK OFF
THE QUESTIONSBY --
SEGUEING OFF OF OF ONE OF YOUR
COMMENTS OF SECRETARY THERE HAVE
IN FACT BEEN A NUMBER OF DELAYS
HAVE BEEN VERY FRUSTRATING I
THINK TO ALL OF US AND CERTAINLY
TO THE PUBLIC.
OF WHAT ARE WE DOING WHAT CAN WE
DO TO KEEP THIS MOVING FORWARD --
SO THAT IS ON A PACE AND WE KNOW
WHAT THE TIME LINE IS AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO FACE FUTURE DELAYS --
I WOULD SAY THAT HAVING
CONTINUED MEDIUMS SUCH AS THIS
AND MOVE THE MEETINGS THAT
DETAILS HE HAS TO HAVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SHOULD HAVE IN THE
COMMUNITY IS A GOOD WAY. TO MAKE
THIS A TRANSPARENT PROCESS TO
KEEP THE PRESSURE UP ON US --
I THINK THAT REPORTING THAT TO
THE COMMUNITY ON THE PROGRESS OF
THE WORK IS AN IMPORTANT WAY
THAT IT'S THE YARDSTICK BY WHICH
WE SHOULD BE MEASURED AND MOVING
AHEAD --
I'LL LET THE BARBER OR MODES AND
THINK ABOUT OTHER THINGS THAT WE
MIGHT BE DOING BUT WE AS I THINK
CAME OUT OF MY A LOT FROM THIS
AS TIME HAS GONE ON WE'VE
LEARNED THE BETTER BETTER WAYS
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
AND WORTH CONTINUING TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO WORK ON THAT BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING TO THAT.
JUST BRIEFLY LET ME SAY THAT YOU
KNOW WE WE WENT THROUGH THE
ORIGINAL INVITATION FOR BID
PROCESS WE WERE VERY
DISAPPOINTED WHEN THE CONTRACTOR --
THAT WAS SELECTED AND AND
SURVIVE THE APPEAL I WAS NOT
ABLE TO DELIVER A CONTRACT WITH
US THAT.
MET THE TERMS OF THEIR BID AND
WAS GOING TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY AND DELIVER THE CLEAN
UP AT THE CLOCK COMMUNITY
DESERVES.
OUT WE DID LEARN FROM THAT --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH.
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AND I ACTUALLY BEEN
HIRED ONE OF THEIR EXPERTS A
CONTRACTING ATTORNEYS.
IN ORDER.
TO FIND SOME CREATIVE WAYS
WITHIN THE LAW THAT WE CAN
EXPEDITE THE CONTRACTING WERE OF
PURSUING THAT ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FRONTS WERE IN ACTIVE
NEGOTIATIONS NOW.
A WE DID AS THE SECRETARY
MENTIONED WOULD FIND A WAY.
TO BRING --
AN INTERIM CONTRACT FOR A
PLANNED FULLY AT THIS POINT AND
WE HAVE MAPPED OUT A PATH WHERE
WE WILL BE ABLE.
TO RAMP UP --
TO THE FULL PRODUCTION THAT WE
EXPECTED TO REACH IN THE CLEANUP
PLAN WE WILL REACH THAT WE WILL
MAINTAIN THAT PROGRESS EVEN AS
WE BRING NEW CONTRACTS ONLINE.
THANK YOU WE MET SOME OF THOSE
FOLKS TODAY --
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD THEY SEEM
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE AND COMMITTED
TO GETTING THE JOB DONE I WAS SO
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
HIS CAREER.
SO I'D I'D REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
DIVE INTO THE PROCESS OF THE
CONTRACT.
I WON A COMMITMENT FROM DTS SEEN
ON A REALISTIC TIME LINE AS TO
THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS THAT DID
AND MOVE FORWARD.
AND WHATWILL THAT CONTRACT LOOK
LIKE IN THE FUTURE AND WHAT YOUR
TIME LINE IS TO DETERMINE.
A CONTRACT IN AN AGENCY THAT'S
GOING TO DO THE WORK THAT'S
GOING TO BE COMMITTED TO THE
WORK THAT'S GOING TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE SOME HIGHS
AND LOWS.
IN ENSURING THAT THIS PROCESS
MOVES FORWARD IN A QUICK.
MANNER BUT THAT ALSO IS NOT DONE
IN A WAY THAT [inaudible]
IN HASTE.
BUT THAT IT'S DONE CORRECTLY
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME HONORING
THE PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT THAT
WAS AGREED UPON --
AND ENSURING THAT THE LOCAL HIRE
IS ACTUALLY A LOCAL HIRE.
SAID LIKE SOME SOME COMMITMENTS
FROM YOU IN A REALISTIC TIME
LINE.
WELL I'M ABSOLUTELY ABLE TO GIVE
YOU OUR COMMITMENT WE WERE VERY
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
THAT PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT IT
IS AS I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE.
THE FIRST PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT ANY STATE DEPARTMENT
HAS IN CALIFORNIA HAS ACTUALLY
DIRECTLY NEGOTIATED SO I WAS
VERY PROUD OF MY STAFF FOR
ACCOMPLISHING THAT --
AND WORD.
MUCH COMMITTED TO IT OUR CHIEF
OBJECTIVE WITH THAT PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT WAS THE LOCAL
HIRE COMPONENT.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
OFTEN PRIORITIZED IN PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS FOR US IT WAS
THE LOCAL HIRE COMPONENT WE'VE
WORKED OUT CAREFULLY WITH THE
UNIONS -- TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO TAKE PART IN OUR
WORKFORCE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION FOR COMMUNITIES
TRAINING HAVE A PATH TO UNION
MEMBERSHIP IF THEY CHOOSE TO
TAKE IT.
I AM WE ARE PROVIDING.
AN ARRAY OF TRAINING SO THAT CAN
WORK UP FOR COMPENSATION ON THIS
PROJECT WHETHER THEY'RE ON A
UNION MEMBERSHIP AFTER NOT SO
WE'RE WE'RE VERY MUCH COMMITTED
TO THAT IN TERMS OF THE
CONTRACTING ITSELF --
THE CONTRACTING NEGOTIATIONS ARE
CONFIDENTIAL SO I CAN'T GIVE YOU
A LOT OF DETAILS ABOUT HOW THOSE
ARE GOING WHAT I CAN SAY IS THE
PATH WE'VE MARKED OUT.
WILL ALLOW US TO MAINTAIN THE
PROGRESS ON THE CLEAN UP AS WE
TRANSITION CONTRACTS SO WE'VE
LOOKED AT WAYS TO ESTABLISH THE
CONTRACTS BRING THEM FORWARD
SUCH THAT.
WE WILL REACH AND MAINTAIN THAT --
THAT CLEAN OPERATE AND THE THE
DETAILS OF WHEN AND HOW THE
CONTRACT OR CONTRACTS ARE SIGNED
OUT WON'T IMPEDE THAT.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT AS AS AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE GOAL IS TO
HAVE NO BREAK BETWEEN THE
COMPLETION OF THE EXISTING WORK
IN THIS NEW CONTRACT --
AND SO --
YOU CAN.
I'LL GIVE YOU MY INSURANCE MY
OWN THAT I WILL ASK ABOUT THE
CONTRACT EVERY DAY UNTIL IT'S
SIGNED AND THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
IT DONE --
OKAY AND AND IF YOU WANT TO CALL
ME THAT'S FINE WELL I'LL TELL
YOU WHERE IT IS I'D LIKE TO
SUGGEST TEXTING.
THE SUGGESTION.
MS GARCIA.
YES THANK YOU I HAVE. TWO
QUESTIONS THE FIRST QUESTION WAS
NOT TOUCHED IN YOUR PRESENTATION
AND I WANT CLARIFICATION.
I HAVE HEARD THAT THERE'S A
PROPOSAL --
TO NOT CLEAN INITIALLY AND YEAH
HOMES THAT WERE AT EIGHTY PARTS
PER MILLION OR HIGHER THAT'S THE
STANDARD WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
HERE THAT'S A PROPOSAL TO TRY TO
MOVE THAT TO FOUR HUNDRED PARTS
PER MILLION WHICH IS THE FEDERAL
STANDARD.
WHAT'S THE ACCURACY OF THAT
STATEMENT AND IF WE ARE LOOKING
AT THAT WHY ARE WE WHY ARE WE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE A LEVEL
THAT THE STATE IS NOT
COMFORTABLE IN GENERAL ANYWHERE
ELSE.
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT THAT
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
GARCIA WE HAVE NOT CHANGED OUR
CLEANUP.
STANDARDS --
EIGHTY PARTS PER MILLION IS A
SCREENING LEVEL THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED FOR THE OUT BY THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT DTS USES THAT.
AT THIS SITE AND AT OTHER SITES
AS WELL --
DDS HE WAS APPROPRIATED.
MONEY TO CLEAN UP THE MOST --
IMPACTED PROPERTIES THE
PROPERTIES THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF LEAD AND THE GREATEST
EXPOSURE TO SENSITIVE
INDIVIDUALS --
WE RECEIVED ENOUGH FUNDING TO
CLEAN UP APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PROPERTIES.
THAT'S NOT ALL OF THE PROPERTIES%
THAT ARE THAT ARE TESTING SHOWS
HAVE ELEVATED LEVELS OF LEAD.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STRETCH
THAT FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE CLEANING UP ALL OF THE
PROPERTIES THAT HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION OR
LESS.
OF LEAD OR HIGHER --
AS WELL AS THE HOT SPOTS THAT
THE COMMUNITIES WERE WORRIED
ABOUT WHERE EVEN THOUGH THE OF
THE THE REPRESENTATIVE LEAD
LEVEL OF THE PROPERTY WAS.
FOUR HUNDRED THERE MIGHT HAVE OR
BELOW FOUR HUNDRED THERE MY A
SINGLE SAMPLE THAT WAS ABOVE A
THOUSAND AND WE ARE CLEANING UP
ALL OF THOSE AS WELL.
SO WE HAVEN'T CHANGED THE
ULTIMATE GOAL BUT WE HAVE INDEED --
BEEN ABLE TO CLEAN UP TO FOUR
HUNDRED WITH THE THE FUNDING WE
HAVE NOW THAT I WANT TO BE SURE
YOU UNDERSTAND ALSO.
THAT WHEN WE CLEAN THE PROPERTY
UP WE IDENTIFY THE PROPERTY
THAT'S ABOVE FOUR HUNDRED BUT
WHEN WE CLEAN IT UP WE CLEAN IT
UP.
TO EIGHTY THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION.
AND THAT LEADS ME TO MY SECOND
QUESTION WE ALL KNOW WE NEED
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAS
BEEN CLEAR FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THE ESTIMATES HAVE BEEN ANYWHERE
FROM HALF A BILLION TO UPWARDS
OF A BILLION DOLLARS.
TO JUST FOR THE CLEAN UP THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE THE HEALTH
IMPACTS AND OTHER NEAT THAT WE
HAVE ASSOCIATED WITH.
CONTAMINATION WE WE PASSED AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE WITH THAT
WHICH IS A LETTER BATTERY FEE
BILL STARTING TO COLLECT FUNDS
IN THAT CITY WHY ARE WE TAKING
THAT MONEY AND USING IT TO PAY
BACK A LOAN INSTEAD OF MAKING
SURE WE HAVE IT THERE TO WE
COULD CLEAN.
UP THE OTHER HOMES AND FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THE PROMISE THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LEAVE ANYONE
BEHIND.
THIS MAY BE A IT IT IT THIS WEEK
TO WAIT ON THOSE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
WE KNOW.
HOW MUCH WE'RE GOING TO NEED AND
AND AT THE RATE AT WHICH THAT
BATTERY BILL IS?
IS COLLECTING FINE I I HOPEFULLY
IN FLORIDA WE ARE COMMITTED TO
LEAVING THAT MONEY THERE FOUR TO
TEN THE PURPOSE AND WE DO NOT
USE IT TO PAY BACK THE LOAN
UNTIL AFTER WE HAVE CLEANED UP
ALL THESE FILMS AND WE HAVE A
LET.
ANYONE BEHIND --
INCREASE THAT FEE BECAUSE AT THE
RATE AT WHICH WERE COLLECTING
WE'RE GOING TO NEED A LOT A LOT
MORE HOW.
IT'S FRUSTRATING. TO TO COME
HOME BECAUSE THESE ARE MY
NEIGHBORS.
ODD TO SEE THE DESPAIR IN THEIR
FACE WHEN THEY KNOW THEY HAVE
NOW BEEN ENGAGED AND EDUCATED OF
THE LEVEL OF TOXICITY AND WHAT
THAT MEANS AND THOSE FORCES.
AND THEY FEEL HELPLESS TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT AND THEY KNOW
WHAT THEIR KIDS OR GRANDKIDS AND
OURSELVES.
ARE LIVING IN A CONTINUAL
EXPOSURE AT MAKING THEM SICK AND
THERE THAT I'M EXCITED WHAT'S
COMING DOWN THE ROAD WHETHER
IT'S CANCER WHAT IS THE LAST
TIME A BATH MUCH.
INDEED CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT AND YOU'RE BEING TOLD YOU
KNOW WHAT JUST CLOSE YOUR DOORS
AND CLOSER WHEN THOSE WHO WERE
JUST OUTSIDE RIGHT NOW.
AND THIS IS NOT AN EXCEPTIONAL
DAY OF HOW WARM IT IS THAT'S NOT
UNLIKE THAT OF PRAGMATIC
SOLUTION.
ON AND BOOKS ARE GONNA BE
WAITING AT THE RATE WE'RE GOING
TWO YEARS FOUR YEARS FIVE YEARS
TEN YEARS FOR CLEAN UP.
I THINK WE HAVE TO START
THINKING ABOUT THAT KID THAT WAS
BORN INTO THIS CONTAMINATION.
AT FOUR HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION OR TWO HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION AND WHAT WE KNOW IT DOES.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO WAIT TEN YEARS FOR THE
CLEANUP AND WHAT HAVE YOU DONE
TO THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE PAYING FOR
LIKE A LEADER AS TAXPAYERS.
DON'T WE OWE THAT KID BETTER.
THEY ARE NOT.
AND SO I WE ARE THINKING OF
CLEAN UP BUT WE'RE ALSO THINKING
OF OTHER CREATIVE WAYS AND WE
START THINKING ABOUT POSSIBLY WE
NEED TO HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS.
FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING MAYBE
HELP TO FUNDING FOR THAT I MEAN
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DO BUT WE
HAVE TO START THINKING BEYOND
JUST CLOSE YOUR DOORS AND CLOSE
YOUR WINDOWS AND WAIT FOR FIVE
TO TEN YEARS.
UP TO DO THIS.
AND SO IF THIS IS THE BEST WE
COULD DO AND IS AS FAST AS WE
COULD CLEAN UP I CAN'T KEEP
COMING HOME AND TELLING PEOPLE
TO SWAY.
WE HAVE TO START THINKING OF
OTHER WAYS TO DO THIS AND IF
IT'S OUR LAWS AND REGULATIONS
THAT ARE UPON THAT ONLY THIS
BACK.
WE HAVE ENOUGH TALENT
COLLECTIVELY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO BRING SOME OF THESE DOWN AT
THEM AND THEN DOWN IN THESE
EXTRAORDINARY CRISIS MOMENTS.
THANK YOU FOLKS WE'RE GONNA GET
TO MISTER SANTIAGO JUST A SECOND
I'M GRATIFIED THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE HERE TONIGHT --
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE STANDING AROUND
THE SIDES OF THE ROOM IF YOU
HAVE AN EMPTY SEAT NEXT TO YOU
TO MIND RAISING YOUR HAND SO
THAT FOLKS WERE STANDING UP
THERE ONCE IT DOWN --
CAN CAN GRAB A SEAT MISTER
SANTIAGO.
I WILL REPEAT I WON'T REPEAT OUR
ECHO WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID SO WELL BUT WHAT I MIGHT
CHALLENGE YOU WANT.
IS TO FIND OUT SPECIFICALLY AND
I KNOW YOU ALLUDED TO IT WHAT
PLAN AND HOW MANY HOUSES WE CAN
EXPECT TO BE CLEANED UP BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR AND WE'VE HAD
SOME HEATED DEBATES.
AND ALL OF OUR OFFICES ABOUT
WHAT THAT NUMBER MIGHT LOOK LIKE --
ABOUT AS WE WERE TOLD A WALKING
AROUND THERE'S A RAMP UP PHASE
NOW -- THE
LEGISLATURE'S DEMANDED MY
COLLEAGUES ARE ARE PRESSING FOR
IT.
WHAT DOES THAT RAMP BUT THESE
LOOK LIKE A TO THE VOLUME THAT
WILL BE CLEANED UP? EIGHTEEN WE
INCREASE THAT CLEAN UP.
AND A AND IF THE IF THE ANSWER
IS WE CAN'T BECAUSE OF X. Y. AND
Z. THAT WHAT WE DO ON OUR SIDE
TO CHANGE OUT LOUD TO MAKE THAT
EXPLAINS THE GO AWAY SO THAT WE
CAN.
HAVE SOME SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR --
WHAT IS THAT NUMBER AND WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE IN THE RAMP
FACE WENT?
MOSTLY NEWS TOUCHED ON THAT A
LITTLE AND THANK YOU THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND AND I THINK
IN MY PRESENTATION I DID MENTION
THAT.
AS OF THIS WEEK WE HAVE THIRTEEN
CRUISE OUT IN THE FIELD AND
THERE SCHEDULING TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN PROPERTIES PER WEEK.
SO IF YOU JUST COUNT HOW MANY
WEEKS ARE LEFT TO THE END OF THE
YEAR WE CAN WE CAN.
ESTABLISH A ROUGH NUMBER ON HOW
MANY PROPERTIES WILL BE CLEANING
BUT ONCE WE GET.
ONCE YOU KNOW ONCE WE GET TO THE
NEXT CONTRACT WE ARE PLANNING TO
WRAP THIS UP EVEN FURTHER AND GO
UP TO AS MANY AS TWENTY FIVE
PROPERTIES PER WEEK.
SO I CAN'T GIVE YOU AN EXACT
NUMBER BUT I THINK YOU CAN GET A
SENSE THAT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE
PROPERTIES THAT WE ARE OUR
TARGET TO CLEAN UP TO THE END
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ESTABLISHING
HERE.
AS OUR COMMITMENT AND AS ORACLE.
AND IF I COULD JUST ADD TO THAT --
IN TERMS OF WHAT LIMITS THE RATE
THE THE THERE ARE TWO THINGS
THAT AFFECT THE RAMP UP.
THE FIRST IS WE WANT TO EXPAND
THE RATE.
ONLY AS FAST AS WE CAN SAFELY.
INSURE THAT ALL THE LOGISTICS
ARE DONE PROPERLY THE CLEANUP IS
DONE PROPERLY IF YOU IF WE HAD
EVERYBODY OUT GOING.
FULL BORE RIGHT AWAY THERE WOULD
BE A GREATER.
CHANCE THAT THINGS WOULD NOT GO
WELL AT A GIVEN PROPERTY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT'S DONE RIGHT.
AND SO WE'RE GRADUALLY
INCREASING THE RATE TO MAKE SURE
IT'S DONE RIGHT.
THE SECOND THING THAT AFFECTS IT
IS HOW MANY ACCESS AGREEMENTS WE
ARE ABLE TO SECURE YOUHEARD --
AT MISTER SATAN IS AND HUNDRED
PROPERTIES READY TO BE.
CLEANED UP WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
PROPERTIES WITH ACCESS
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE WITH THE
LANDSCAPING SELECTED SO --
WHAT THE COMMUNITY WHAT THE
COMMUNITY CAN DO IS IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN HAVING YOUR
PROPERTY CLEANED UP AND YOU'VE
BEEN NOTIFIED THAT YOU'RE PART
OF THIS --
PHASE OF THE CLEAN UP PLEASE
WORK WITH US TO QUICKLY GET
ACCESS AGREEMENTS IN PLACE
BECAUSE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT.
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE IN PLACE IN
ORDER TO MOVE MORE QUICKLY HAVE
BEEN DOING SOME ROUGH
CALCULATIONS IN MY HEAD AND MY
SENSE IS THAT THE ANSWER TO YOU
IS WE SHOULD BE DONE WITH THAT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THAT WE
STARTED IN MAY BUY SOMETIME IN
OCTOBER.
THAT WAS THE GOALS I REQUIRE SO
THAT'S THAT TRUNKS WE WERE
TRYING TO DO BEFORE WE GOT THE
LARGER CONTRACT IN THE PLACE.
IN THE GOAL I THINK AS I RECALL
FROM THE BRIEFING DOCUMENTS WAS
TO HAVE.
THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED THAT
FIRST SET THE ONES THAT WERE
PAYING FOR WITH A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX POINT SIX MILLION
DONE.
WITHIN TWO YEARS BECAUSE THIS
AFTER I RECALL THAT CORRECT SO
THAT'S THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN ADDITIONAL ONE
FROM MAY TO OCTOBER.
AND THEN WE HOPE TO HAVE THIS
FIRST GROUP THAT'S PAYING FOR BY
THE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
POINT SIX MILLION --
DONE WITHIN TWO YEARS.
SO I'M READING THIS RIGHT
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THAT WOULD GET DONE BY
OCTOBER.
NO NO WE WE SHOULD BE HAVING
THAT.
SINCE WE STARTED IN MAY WE
SHOULD HAVE DONE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN OR SO BY OCTOBER SET TO
HIKE OVER FIFTEEN WEEK WE RAMP
IT UP FROM FIVE PROPERTIES A
WEEK UP TO NOW 212-215-
PROPERTIES PER WEEK BUT WE WE
ARE UP PROBABLY OVER EIGHTY
PROPERTIES OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN THAT.
WE WERE PLANNING TO CLEAN UP AND
SO WE HAVE CLEAN UP MY ACT OVER
AND AFTER DAD WE'RE GOING TO
RAMP UP TO THE NEXT CONTRACT
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO CLEAN UP.
SOMEWHERE IN THE FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE PER WEEK
SO THAT WILL GIVE US ANOTHER --
NOVEMBER DECEMBER YOUNG MINDS
AND AND THAT WAS MY QUESTION IF
IT'S ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN TO OCTOBER THE ESTIMATED
AMOUNT.
AND THE POSSIBLE RAMP UP FACE
GOES. TO TWENTY FIVE FOR WEEK.
AT WHEN YOU DO THE MATH ALINA
LIST MY UNLESS I MISSED
SOMETHING HERE WE COULD BE
LOOKING AT POTENTIALLY HOLDING
HOLDING THE TSA ACCOUNTABLE FOR
FIVE HUNDRED SOMEONE ONLY FORTY
IN THE YEAR.
POTENTIALLY YES BUT IT WILL TAKE
AWHILE TO RAMP UP TO TWENTY FIVE
WE WON'T START THAT
INSTANTANEOUSLY WITH THE NEW
CONTRACT [inaudible]
MISS KOREA [inaudible]
SO.
LIKE WHAT I REALLY ENJOY ABOUT
THIS HEARING IS THAT WE'RE ALL
COMING FROM VARIOUS DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES --
HE'S LOS ANGELES IS A COMMUNITY
THAT IS 20% BELOW THE NATIONAL
POVERTY LINE I'M SURE.
SOMEONE OR SOME GOGGLES AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AND SHARE
VERY SIMILAR STATISTICS.
NOT ONLY ARE WE INTERESTED IN
THE CLEANUP BUT I'M ALSO VERY
INTERESTED IN ENSURING THAT WE
ARE CREATING JOBS IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
IN WHICH THE PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY LIVE HERE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS TYPE OF
WORK AND THAT THE TRAINING IS
AVAILABLE.
SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIVE TO FIFTEEN
PROPERTIES OF WEAK RAMPING UP
FROM FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE
PROPERTIES OF WEAK MOVING
FORWARD.
HOW MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY EMPLOYED?
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
BUT WE WILL GET THAT NUMBER FOR
YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US.
YEAH SO MY ROUGH CALCULATION ON
OF HOW MANY OF OUR JOB TO BE
COMPLETE BUT TO COMPLETE PER
MONTH IF YOU'RE DOING.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY FIVE AND WE SEEM AN
AVERAGE OF TWENTY IS GOING TO BE
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
EIGHTY FIVE PER MONTH.
SENSES ARE ANOTHER WAY OF OF OF
OF LOOKING AT WITH THE GOAL
MIGHT BE HERE WHAT COURSE SHOULD
WE WE ALSO ANTICIPATE THROUGH
THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
ARE MORE RELUCTANT TO HAVE THEIR
PROPERTIES WORKED ON TO THE
EXTENT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO WE WILL ABSOLUTELY MAINTAIN.
THAT PACE THROUGH THE HOLIDAY
SEASON BUT BUT THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT FOLKS WILL BE.
I UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT COULD BE
COULD BE DIFFICULT TO HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
I DO ACTUALLY I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION ON YOUR PREVIOUS
PRESENTATION TO YOU JUST A
COUPLE MINUTES AGO.
ON PARKWAYS.
SO THE STATUS THE STATE
LEGISLATURE THE STATE ASSEMBLY
THAT WERE WORKED JUST DID A SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ADDITIONAL.
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR PARKWAYS AND
YOU MENTIONED THAT PARKWAYS OUR
PUBLIC.
SO IS IT YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE TSC WILL NOW BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS CLEANUP [inaudible]
I'M EXCITED IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
CLEANING UP.
ALL OF THE CONTAMINATION
RELEASED FROM THE OPERATIONS AT
THAT SITE.
WHETHER IT IS ON PRIVATE
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY ON PUBLIC
PROPERTY OR ON A COMMERCIALLY
OWNED PROPERTY SO WE ARE DOING
TESTING THROUGHOUT THE AREA --
DTS WILL BE IMPLEMENTING THE
CLEAN UP OF THE PART WAYS WITH
THE SIX POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED FOR THAT PURPOSE --
WE DID NOT HAVE PARKWAYS IN THE
ORIGINAL CLEANUP PLANS SO AS
MISTER MISS ME I EXPLAINED WE
HAVE TO AT THE WAY THE LAW WORKS
FOR US WE HAVE.
TO DO THE TESTING DO THE CLEANUP
PLAN AND THEN DO THE CLEANUP.
THE SIX POINT FIVE MILLION THAT
WOULD JUST APPROPRIATED FOR THE
PARK WASTE IS THAT SUFFICIENT
FOR TESTING AND CLEAN UP OR IS
THAT JUST.
TESTING IT IS FOR TESTING AND
CLEAN UP IT IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO
CLEAN UP ALL PARKWAYS IN THE
PRELIMINARY INVESTIGATION AREA
ARE WE STARTING TO DISCUSS WAYS
TO GUARANTEE THAT DIGITAL
FUNDING THAT WE NEED FOR THE
CLEAN UP SO WE DON'T EVEN THE OF
THIS PARK WITH BEHIND.
DTS HE IS ON DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO ENSURE THAT EXIDE IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR CARRYING OUT THE
CLEANUP OF ALL OF THE
CONTAMINATION THAT WAS RELEASED
FROM THE OPERATIONS AT THAT SITE --
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DO AND WE'RE DOING IT.
AS DILIGENTLY AS WE CAN AND MORE
THE GENERAL'S OFFICE TO GET THAT
DONE.
BUT I WOULD ADD THAT --
IF WE FIND OUT MORE ABOUT THIS
PARKWAY IS IF WE FIND OUT THAT
THE SIX POINT ONE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT WILL COME BACK AND
WILL BE.
OUR ENEMY TO TALK TO THE
LEGISLATURE OBVIOUSLY ABOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO DEAL WITH
THIS WHETHER WE USE.
LEAD ACID BATTERY FINDING WHERE
WITH THE FUNDING WOULD COME FROM
IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE EXTENT
OF THE CONTAMINATION AND THE UP
PARKWAYS BEFORE COULD MAKE A
FINAL RECOMMENDATION IS THAT
SOME OF THE ONE OF THE THINGS.
THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT
OBVIOUSLY --
IF I MIGHT TO ADELPHIA ON THAT
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WE WILL BEGIN OUR BUDGET PROCESS
AND NEW AS WE DO EVERY YEAR AND
TO SEE YOU ALL SOMETIME AFTER
JANUARY WHEN --
THE ASSEMBLY BEGINS ITS --
BUDGET CONSIDERATION BUT THE SEX
THINKING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET BECAUSE IT REALLY IS A
YEAR LONG PROCESS WE AND ONE
BUDGET.
AS OF THE END OF JUNE WHEN WE
PASS OUR BUDGET FOR THE YEAR AND
AS SOON AS THAT WAS OVER WE
START THE CYCLE OVER AGAIN IN
THE WORK AT THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL
AND IT -- IS
IS ON GOING SO IN THAT --
IN THAT VEIN.
LET ME JUST SAY NOW THAT WE ARE --
IN BUDGETS UP THREE GOING TO
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU WHAT THE
STATUS OF EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS
IS -- AND
WHEN YOU PROJECT --
IF IT'S SO IN THE COMING GOT A
BUDGET CYCLE IF FUNDS ARE GOING
TO BE DEPLETED AND DISAPPEAR WE
WANT TO KNOW THAT SO THAT WE CAN
AT LEAST TRY WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
OUR BUDGETS CAN LOOK LIKE THIS
YEAR.
BUT WE WANT TO TRY AND KEEP THIS
PROCESS MOVING FORWARD AND MAKE
ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE APPROPRIATE
AND NECESSARY.
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU PROVIDE
YOUR PREPARED TO PROVIDE US WITH
THAT INFORMATION.
I COULD ADD TO THAT TO FINISH
OFF ON MY QUESTION AND THE
COMMENT.
YOU KNOW THE PARK WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT THE COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN ASKING.
FOR FOR WAS THE VERY BEGINNING
AND SO WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
THAT'S BEEN ALMOST SIX YEARS.
AND WE FINALLY HAVE APPROPRIATED
THE AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT LEFT BEHIND.
AND WE KNOW THERE'S REALLY HIGH
PROBABILITY THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE ENOUGH MONEY HOW MUCH WE NEED
THIS HOLLY THE QUESTION THAT'S
OUTSTANDING AND THAT'S WHAT THE
TESTING WILL HELP --
ANSWER BUT I THINK WE CAN NOW
START. TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
KNOW WHERE WOULD THIS MONEY COME
FROM TO TO COME FROM.
OUR GENERAL FUND IS TO COME FROM
A BATTERY FIELD AND SOME
MODIFICATIONS THERE IS A COMPANY
SOMEPLACE ELSE.
AND THAT WORK SHOULD BE DONE NOW
WITH BUILDING TO BE INTRODUCED
SHOULD BE INTRODUCED IN JANUARY.
AND NOT WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE THE
EXACT ANSWER OF WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO NEED.
I THINK BEING PROACTIVE IS
ANOTHER WAY IN WHICH WE GAIN THE
COMMUNITY STRESSED --
MISS LEE AT WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
THE MEETINGS AND YOU KNOW I WILL
SAY THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
IMPROVEMENTS.
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS TO THE
BEING ABLE TO LOOK UP ONLINE
REALLY QUICKLY WHAT THE DATA
WAREHOUSE.
IT'S AN IMPROVEMENT ON THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE --
YOU KNOW HOW I MEAN I DO SAY I'M
HAPPY IN MY HOUSE IS FAIRLY
CLEAN IN MY YARD LOOKS REALLY
GOOD SERVICE WILL BE PART OF THE
WAY HER YOUNGER LOAD.
IS REALLY GOOD AND WE SHOULD NOT
FORGET THOSE.
THOSE SUCCESSES BUT WE SHOULD
NOT BE SATISFIED WITH THOSE
SUCCESSES AND AND I THINK BE
PRACTICAL HOW COMPLICATED THIS
PROCESS IS AND TRY.
TO ACT A LITTLE BIT SOONER.
OFF BUT THE COMMUNITY I'M GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE A CRITICAL
THING I COULD TO DO TO CALL YOU
AND BUT I WANT TO BE FRIENDS I
DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME.
IMPROVEMENTS BUT IT IS
FRUSTRATING AT THE PACE AT WHICH
WE ARE GOING.
AND NOW ON ON THAT NOTE WE WILL
CONCLUDE THIS PANEL AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A COUPLE OF MOMENTS I
WANT TO THANK US.
ARE UP A PANELIST DIRECTOR LEE A
SECRETARY RETRIEVED HIS AND
DOUBT DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND AS I
ME UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION FOR BEING HERE
TODAY.
WE'LL TAKE A MOMENT --
TO THIS WILL ONLY TAKE A COUPLE
OF MOMENTS TO SET UP FOR OUR
NEXT PANEL.
CAN ALL GET UP AND STRETCH IF
YOU WANT --
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
LIKE WE HAD [inaudible] THREE
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] ONE YES
[inaudible]
YEAH.
BEING A REALIST
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
.
THERE IS A BUT THE ONE VERY
[inaudible]
YEAH
YEAH [inaudible]
AND I YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT HERE.
YEAH [inaudible]
I YEAH
[inaudible]
ON
OKAY.
YEAH YEAH.
YEAH
[inaudible]
AND YEAH
.
AS PART OF YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND I HAVE [inaudible]
OKAY.
IF WE COULD ALL GET OUT THERE
AND FIND OUR SEATS [inaudible]
JOHN DID [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SORRY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF I
COULD ASK YOU TO FIND YOUR SEATS.
WE'RE GONNA START IN JUST A FEW
SECONDS HERE [inaudible]
I'M.
AS IT COOLED OFF OUTSIDE A
LITTLE BIT.
IF I CAN ASK MY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE COME BACK AND TAKE YOUR
SEATS [inaudible]
YEAH.
I KNOW YOU'RE OUT THERE
SOMEWHERE I SAW MS GARCIA.
THIS CORREO MISTER SANTIAGO.
I'M GONNA START WITHOUT YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WELL.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TURN
THIRTY SECONDS FOLKS.
I WASN'T KIDDING WHEN I SAID I'M
GONNA KEEP THIS MEETING MOVING
.
I DON'T SEE.
OUR NEXT PANEL.
I CAN HAVE YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE
IF YOU COULD ALL COME TO ORDER.
WE NEED SOME QUIET IN THE ROOM
PLEASE.
OUR NEXT PANEL IS.
IS HERE FOR US SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
SAYS BUT THEY'RE PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND THE COUNTY'S INVOLVEMENT
WHICH HAS BEEN --
PRODIGIOUS AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY AND YOU'VE
ALREADY --
MANNER AND HEARD FROM HER WE'RE
HONORED TO HAVE SUPERVISOR HILDA
SO THESE.
AND WE HAVE ALSO WITH US
DIRECTOR BARBARA FOR RARE.
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
IS EVERYBODY QUIET DOWN SO THAT
EVERYONE CAN HEAR PLEASE.
SHOW SOME RESPECT TO YOUR
NEIGHBORS IN THE ROOM.
FOLKS IF YOU HAVE CONVERSATIONS
THAT YOU NEED TO CONTINUE WITH
PLEASE TAKE THEM OUTSIDE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND SUPERVISORS POLICE THANK YOU
SO MUCH GERMAN BLOOM AND I WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND AGAIN REITERATE.
MY GREAT THANKS TO ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER RENTED FOR ACTUALLY
CALLING THIS AND ALLOWING US. TO
HAVE THIS MEETING HERE --
I'M VERY --
VERY HAPPY TO SEE THE OUTPOURING
OF SUPPORT TODAY AND I'M VERY
HAPPY WITH THE LINE OF
QUESTIONING THAT THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THESE
IMPACTED AREAS ARE RACING.
BECAUSE I TOO HAVE NOW MANY MORE
QUESTIONS BUT WE ALSO HOPE TO
ACHIEVE.
SOME ANSWERS AND AS WAS STATED
WE HAVE DOCTOR BARBER FERRER WHO
WAS ALSO WITH THIS ACCOMPANYING
US ON OUR TOUR.
OF OF VARIOUS HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE IN SOME --
PORTION OF CLEAN UP AND
REMEDIATION WE ALSO HAVE OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST DR ADAM
LOVE.
WHO SHOULD BE ALSO JOINING US HE
MAY HAVE STEPPED OUT TEMPORARILY --
BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE AS MANY OF
YOU MAY KNOW.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STILL CONTINUES.
TO SO WHEN THINGS DO HAPPEN ON
THE GROUND AND THERE ARE.
FIRES OR HAZMAT.
ACCIDENTS AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
OF THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IS
USUALLY THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND IN THIS CASE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT
LEVELS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY I'M
ALSO TALKING ABOUT HEALTH.
AND WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
TO ALSO VISIT.
A NEW.
COUNTY HEALTH CLINIC THAT HAS
JUST BEEN ESTABLISHED BECAUSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
WITH EXCITE.
IN THE PARAMETER OF THIS AREA
IT'S IMPACTED AND I WANT TO SAY
THAT THAT TOOK A LOT OF
FORESIGHT.
AND IT TAKES REARRANGING
PRIORITIES AT THE SUN WILL
CENTER.
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW.
WE NOW HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE COUNTY SERVICES THERE.
SO WE CAN DO BLOOD TESTING. FOR
FAMILIES FOR INSTANCE AND FOR
YOUTH.
AND I WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT I KNOW WE'VE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT BUT
WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO ME IS
THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COUNTY ALSO.
WANTS TO ENGAGE WITH YOU ON
OTHER HEALTH CARE OF MATTERS
HEALTH CARE MATTERS TO ALL OF US
AND I BRING THAT UP BECAUSE BACK
IN JUNE OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN MY
OFFICE TOGETHER WITH OUR COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH.
AS WELL AS WELL OVER TWELVE
HERE'S MET ON A SATURDAY.
AT SUNAL CENTER AND WE DEPLOYED
VOLUNTEERS TO GO DOOR TO DOOR WE
KNOCKED ON HOUSEHOLD DOORS.
IN FACT I KNOW OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO WAS THERE AT THE
OPENING BUT WE SPENT HOURS GOING
THROUGH OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WE TOUCHED ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU IT WAS A
IT WAS A LEARNING EXPERIENCE AND
ONE THAT WAS VERY HUMBLING.
BECAUSE THERE WERE MANY
RESIDENTS THAT WERE OF WANTING
TO TALK TO US WANTING TO HAVE
SOMEBODY EXPLAIN THAT SOMEBODY
CAME AND TESTED THEIR HOME.
BUT DIDN'T BOTHER TO COME BACK.
AND EXPLAIN WHAT THAT MEANT.
AND MANY WERE CONFUSED ABOUT THE
HEALTH IMPACTS AND WEREN'T FULLY
AWARE OF WHAT THE POTENTIAL THAT --
LEAD EXPOSURE HAS ON A PERSON'S
BODY.
AND I TOOK IT VERY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE SADLY WHAT I LEARNED IS
THAT THERE WERE.
A LOT OF MISCOMMUNICATION A LOT
OF OF I THINK INABILITY TO
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATE AND
ARTICULATE IN A CULTURALLY
COMPETENT MANNER. TO OUR
COMMUNITY IT IS PRIMARILY AN
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY SPANISH
SPEAKING DOMINANT SPEAKERS.
AND OTHERS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
I THINK WHAT I CAME AWAY WITH
WAS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
AND IT CAN'T JUST BE THE STATE
IT CAN'T JUST BE THE COUNTY.
IT ALSO HAS TO BE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND I REALLY
BELIEVE.
THAT WE SELLS A DISSERVICE IF WE
DON'T ARTICULATE.
WHAT THIS MEANS TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO PREGNANT MOTHERS WE
VISITED A HOME TODAY THAT WAS
REMEDIATED?
I WANT TO SAY REMEDIATED BASED
ON THE CRITERIA THAT.
THE DTS ASSETS AND THEY
EXPLAINED THAT THERE WAS A YOUNG
COUPLE THAT JUST PURCHASED A
HOME THERE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE CLEANUP.
THE MOTHER THE FEMALE THERE WAS
NOW GOING.
TO HAVE A CHILD.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY [inaudible]
TO HER.
IF HER NEIGHBORS AREAS AREN'T
CLEANED UP AT THE SAME RATE AND
MAGNITUDE OF HER HOUSEHOLD.
HER NEIGHBORS.
SO I HAVE TO ASK THAT QUESTION
WHEN WE SEE WHEN WE REALLY THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE CLEANING.
WHOSE HOUSE AND WHY NOT OTHERS
AND WHY NOT THE PARKWAYS.
AND I RAISE THAT ISSUE.
I WENT TO SACRAMENTO AND TALKED
WITH MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE.
AND WE WE WORKED WITH OUR STAFFS
TO TRY TO PROVIDE THE BEST
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE DON'T
THINK IT'S WORTH JUST CLEANING.
THE SOILED AREAS IN THE FRONT
YARD IN THE BACKYARD.
IF YOU CAN'T PREDICT THE YOU CAN
CLEAN THE PARAMETER THE PARKWAY
IN FRONT OF THE HOUSE WHICH WAS
DESCRIBED BY T. D. TSC IS PUBLIC
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
RE EXPLAIN THAT EXCITES
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CLEANUP OF
ANY LEAD CONTAMINATION THAT
INCLUDES IN OUR DEFINITION
[inaudible]
THE PARKWAYS.
AND WHILE THESE HOUSES ARE BEING
CLEANED AND NOW THE ONES THAT WE
DID SEE.
I MEAN I'M HAPPY ABOUT THAT I'M
GLAD THAT THAT'S HAPPENING.
BUT I'M NOT HAPPY IF WE THEN
HAVE TO GO BACK TO YEARS LATER.
AND FIGURE OUT THAT WELL SIX
MILLION FOR CLEAN UP OF PARK
PLACE IS NOW MADE AVAILABLE.
AND THAT WON'T EVEN GET TO MAYBE
THE TWO HUNDRED OR THREE HUNDRED
THAT WE DO NEED TO CLEAN SO I
I'M I'M CONFUSED ABOUT THE MATH
THERE I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE SUFFICIENT.
SO WE REALLY SHOULD BE DRILLING
DOWN I THINK ON THAT ASPECT AND
I AND I ALSO.
BELIEVE THAT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT EVENTS IN A WAY.
THAT ARTICULATES A CONCERN.
A WHAT THE DISADVANTAGES ARE IF
WE DO NOT CLEAN UP THE INTERIOR.
OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND IT ISN'T
JUST A VACUUMING EXPERIENCE IT
HAS TO BE METHODICAL IN IT HAS
TO BE DONE BY COMPETENT
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN ASSURE US.
THAT THERE IS SAFETY.
AND THAT DOES LEAD LEVELS ARE
NOT AT A HIGH RATE SO THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT I BELIEVE HAVE TO BE
DONE.
AND I AND I I WOULD SAY YES
THERE'S AN IMPROVEMENT SOMEWHAT
OVER WHAT HAPPENED.
A YEAR OR TWO YEARS AGO WHEN
PEOPLE WERE GIVEN A COUPON THAT
WAS MAILED TO THEM.
THAT WAS IN ENGLISH NOT
NECESSARILY IN SPANISH AND WAS
NOT EXPLAINED PEOPLE THOUGHT IT
WAS JUST ANOTHER ADVERTISEMENT
COMING IN THE MAIL.
IN FACT ONE OF MY ASSISTANTS IN
MY OFFICE BROUGHT ME THAT COUPON
AND I THOUGHT THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
DID THAT WE ARE DOING THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS OCCURRING
UNACCEPTABLE IN MY OPINION --
IT'S AN IMPROVED PROVED.
PROCESS NOW.
BUT MY NEXT QUESTION IS AT THE
RATE OF CLEANUP IF WE ARE ONLY
GOING TO DO TWENTY TO MAYBE
TWENTY FIVE HOUSES.
AND NOT THE PARKWAYS IT'S STILL
GOING TO TAKE US.
MAYBE FOR FIVE YEARS. FOR CLEAN
UP OF OF A TOTAL NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED OR TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED AND I WOULD SAY THAT ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE PRIORITIES
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT AND
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS.
IS TO SEE IF THERE'S A WAY TO
GET MORE CALM IS HERE.
BECAUSE IF YOU RELY ON ONE OR
TWO THAT IS INSUFFICIENT I
DIDN'T HEAR THAT DISCUSSION.
AND THE POSSIBILITIES YOU HEARD
ABOUT A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
COULD BE HIRED UP AS CONTRACTORS
WE OUGHT TO BE SOMEHOW
INCREASING.
THAT FEEL TEAM AND MAKING THAT
INVESTMENT NOW.
AND THEY'RE PROBABLY CAN BE
MONEY FOUND IN THE BUDGET I
WOULD HOPE AND MAYBE GOING BACK
TO OF WHAT -
SIMPLY MEMBER CHRISTINA GARCIA
TALKED ABOUT WAS LOOKING AT THE
BY THE BATTERY FEE THAT I
BELIEVE HAS ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY
MILLION OR MORE DOLLARS.
THERE AND EACH YEAR THAT WILL.
CONTINUE. TO INCREASE --
I THINK IT'S EQUALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO TALK ABOUT.
WHAT OUR ROLE IS AT THE COUNTY?
AND WE HAVE A ROLE.
AND ON THE BUSES WE WERE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT WHO WAS INVOLVED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
WE'RE TRYIG TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN EXPEDITE OUR PERMIT
PROCESS.
AND I THINK OUR STAFF WILL WILL
HELP TO ADDRESS THAT.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THIS --
CURRENTLY FOR A HOUSEHOLD IT IS
GOING TO BE.
PERMITTED TO BE CLEANED UP THE
GOING RATE CAN GO ANYWHERE FROM
SEVEN HUNDRED TO FOUR TO FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
PER HOUSE.
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO DO AS BEST WE
CAN TO REDUCE THAT AND THAT
WON'T BE A COST.
THAT WOULD BE PASSED ON TO THE
HOUSEHOLD.
OWNER OR TENANT IT WOULD BE IT
WOULD GO TO DO TSC.
BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE TO HAVE OUR
INSPECTORS.
OUT THERE AND MONITORING SO I I
WANT TO MAKE A COMMITMENT THAT
WILL DO WHAT WE CAN.
IN THAT MANNER --
BUT I THINK THAT THE URGENCY.
OF CLEANING UP.
CAN'T BE UNDERSCORED ENOUGH.
AND THAT WE REALLY HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND.
THAT ANY HOUSEHOLD IT HAS.
AND THE ONES THAT WE SAW TODAY
AT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
THOSE ARE HIGH RISK PROPERTIES
WITH A THOUSAND PARTS PER
MILLION.
AND THE STANDARD IS AS WE KNOW
IS MUCH LOWER.
SO WE ARE WE ARE ALLOWING FOR
THIS TO CONTINUE IN THE NEXT.
THREE TO FOUR FIVE YEARS AT THE
SAME PACE.
OF REMEDIATION I DON'T THINK
THAT IS ACCEPTABLE BY ANYBODY
WHO LOGICALLY LOOKS AT WHAT THE
IMPACT.
THAT LEAD POISONING HAS ON A
CHILD ON A PREGNANT WOMAN AND ON
INDIVIDUALS THAT REPRESENT OUR
COMMUNITY.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO YEARS
AGO TO BRING UP A YOUNG MAN I
DON'T KNOW IF HE'S HERE TODAY --
ANTHONY THINGS HAPPENING
[inaudible]
AND UP.
WHEN MEMBERS OF THE?
COMMITTEE THAT WE SPOKE BEFORE --
SAW THE PICTURES THAT I SHARED.
OF THIS YOUNG MAN.
HE LOOKED AS THOUGH HE WAS AGE.
TWELVE WAS TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF
AGE.
HAD SPINAL OF DISFIGUREMENT.
BRAIN TUMOR.
AND HAD OTHER AILMENTS HE LIVED
VERY CLOSE TO EXCITE.
NOT A BEAUTIFUL SIGHT.
AND MAYBE THAT'S WHAT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE FOR SOME PEOPLE TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE MAGNITUDE.
OF THE EXPOSURE OVER TIME.
THIRTY THREE YEARS IS ONE PART
OF IT BUT NOW A NEW LIFE A LIFE
THAT IS IS TENDER THAT'S FIVE
YEARS OLD IT'S GROWING UP HERE.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO SUFFER.
BECAUSE THIS WILL BE ONGOING FOR
YEARS TO COME.
AND I'M NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THAT WE HAVE YET TO UNCOVER
BASED ON THE CONTAMINANTS OVER
THE PAST DECADES WE WANT TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE TSC.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE WE ALSO WANT TO WORK
WITH THE NEW INCOMING GOVERNOR.
WHO IS AWARE OF THIS ISSUE AND
HAS GONE ON RECORD ALREADY
SAYING THAT HE IS VERY
INTERESTED?
AND WE WANT TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS.
SO I I REALLY.
I'M VERY VERY --
THRILLED.
DID YOU YOU HAD DECIDED TO COME
AND SPEND HOURS HERE TODAY.
AND IT IS A LEARNING EXPERIENCE
I THINK FOR MANY OF US BUT FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE HAD TO LIVE WITH
THIS.
IT CAN'T JUST BE ANOTHER DAY.
IT CAN'T JUST BE THE SAME THING
OVER AGAIN.
AND IT CAN'T BE BROKEN PROMISES
SO I WOULD ASK FOR FOR YOU IN
YOUR BUDGET DELIBERATIONS TO
HELP US. TO WORK WITH OUR
LEGISLATIVE TEAM AND WITH OUR
PROFESSIONALS ALSO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THEN -- ALSO
OUR OUR PUBLIC WORKS TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE WE WILL MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE TO YOU AND TO DTS SEE.
TO SEE HOW WE CAN COLLABORATE
AND HELP TO EXPEDITE THIS
PROJECT.
IN WAR --
NOT MORE I WANT TO SAY IN A
FASTER MANNER IN WAITING TO HEAR
THAT SOMETHING MIGHT HAPPEN.
IN MAYBE THREE TO FIVE YEARS
BECAUSE EVEN THAT IS A TICKING
TIME BOMB FOR OUR COMMUNITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SUPERVISOR.
LISTENING TO YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
THE NEXT GOVERNOR OF SENSE
YOU'RE PART OF ENTHUSIASM.
OF AND I KNOW YOU'RE BEING
PRESUMPTUOUS ABOUT WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
BUT WE WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS
POINT TO THAT NEXT GOVERNOR
MIGHT BE FOR SURE --
WE HAVE --
WITH US NOW DIRECTOR OF BARBARA
FERRER FROM THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND TO ALSO DOCTOR ADAM
LOVE WHO APPARENTLY NEEDS NO
INTRODUCTION BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A CARD.
FORM SO WE'LL ASK YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
YOUR TIME COMES THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AND I WANT THAT
ALSO THINK THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR SPENDING THE DAY
HERE.
IN THIS COMMUNITY AND REALLY
HELPING US UNDERSTAND HOW IS
THAT FOLKS IN GOVERNMENT WE CAN
REALLY BRING EVERYTHING WE HAVE
TO BEAR ON MAKING SURE THAT THE
RESIDENTS WHO ARE LIVING HERE.
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED IMMEDIATELY
I'M I ALSO --
I KNOW THAT --
YOU HAVE THAT.
MANY OF YOU GROWN WEARY --
I KNOW YOUR TIRED OF OUR
MEETINGS --
AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO THE BOTH
LAND YOUR VOICE --
AND YOUR COUNSEL --
TO WHAT'S NEEDED --
TO IN FACT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S JUSTICE --
THAT'S DONE HERE SO I WANT TO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE STILL
HERE -- AND
PLEDGE OUR COMMITMENT. TO REALLY
SUPPORTING A YOUR NEEDS --
AS YOU MAKE SURE THERE'S A A
RETURN HOUSE. FOR THIS COMMUNITY.
ON AS SUPERVISOR AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK SUPERVISOR SOTHESE --
WHO HAS REALLY CHAMPIONED THE
ISSUE?
OF FOR THE COMMUNITY SURROUNDING
EXCITED ON THE PRINCIPAL.
THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO
LIVES HERE IS ENTITLED TO ALL OF
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
ENSURE OPTIMAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AND I I AM SO THRILLED
THAT.
IN AN HONORED THAT I'M WORKING.
FOR HER.
BECAUSE SHE'S LEADING BY EXAMPLE
EVERYDAY SO THANK YOU
SUPERVISORS POLICE --
I WANNA --
SORT OF START BY SAYING IT AS
THE SUPERVISOR NOTED.
ARE THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND IN FACT THE ENTIRE
COUNTY FAMILY AND WE HAVE MANY
MEMBERS OF THAT COUNTY FAMILY
HERE TONIGHT.
US STAND TOGETHER WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO URGE THAT THE
FOLLOWING ACTIONS ARE TAKEN.
THERE'S A RAPID AND THOROUGH
CLEANUP.
OF LEAD CONTAMINATION IN THE
ENTIRE.
SURROUNDING THE EXITE BATTERY
PLANT.
THIS INCLUDES OUTSIDE OF HOMES.
INSIDE OF HOMES AND IN PART WAYS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
STAND WITH YOU AND YOUR NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
ABOUT THE CLEAN UP PROCESS AND
THAT THE RISKS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH EXPOSURE TO
CONTAMINATION FROM THE EXIDE
BATTERY PLANT.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE ACCESS TO CARE AND
SERVICES.
ARE THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS YOUR CURRENT HEALTH
NEEDS AND YOUR FUTURE HEALTH
NEEDS PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT
ARE RESOLVED.
OF EXPOSURES TO KNOWN
CARCINOGENS AND LET.
ARE CLEANING UP FROM THE LARGEST
LEAD CONTAMINATION IN CALIFORNIA.
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE.
AND SWIFT ACTION. FOR OVER THREE
DECADES EXCITE OPERATED WITHOUT
THE NECESSARY STATE PERMITS
RELEASING LEAD.
BENZENE AND ARSENIC INTO THE
SURROUNDING RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS. FOR DECADES
RESIDENTS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
WERE EXPOSED TO KNOWN HUMAN
CARCINOGENS.
AND THESE CARRY WITH THEM AN
ELEVATED RISK OF CANCER.
WELL WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
EXTENT OF THESE EXPOSURES.
WE DO KNOW THAT LEAD
CONTAMINATION ON THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTIAL LOTS.
HAS PERSISTED FOR DECADES.
RESIDENTS CURRENTLY FACE A
CONTINUING RISK OF TOXIC
EXPOSURE TO LEAD CONTAMINATED
SOILS ON THEIR OWN PARKWAYS AND
PROPERTIES.
THIS EXPOSURE CAN LEAD TO LEAD
POISONING WHICH AFFECTS THE
BRAIN KIDNEYS LIVER AND OTHER
ORGANS.
HAS BEEN NOTED BY EVERY SPEAKER
YOUNG CHILDREN AND PREGNANT
WOMEN ARE ELEVATED RISK.
AND CHILDREN WHO ARE AT RISK OF
LEAD POISONING.
FROM EITHER INGESTING OR
BREATHING LEAD FROM CONTAMINATED
SOIL IN YARDS AND THE LEAD DUST
INSIDE THEIR HOMES.
CAN EXPERIENCE HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE.
THEY CAN BE BORN PREMATURELY.
THEY CAN EXPERIENCE GROSS
IMPAIRMENT AND LEARNING AND
BEHAVIORAL DISORDERS PREGNANT
WOMEN ARE AT RISK OF BOTH
PREMATURE BIRTH.
AND MISCARRIAGE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE ARE
GROWING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EMERGENCY EMERGING RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS THAT THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD EXPOSURE.
FOR CHILDREN.
BECAUSE OF THAT I WOULD ASK US
TO LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THAT THE
CSC PROVIDED TONIGHT THEY'RE
ESTIMATING THAT IT COSTS FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PER HOUSE PER PARCEL. TO DO THE
CLEANUP AND THAT THERE ARE ABOUT
A HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
THAT LIVE IN THE AREA THAT WAS
CONTAMINATED.
WHEN I DO THE MATH AND I'M NOT
GREAT AT MATH BUT WHEN I DO HALF?
THAT AMOUNTS TO FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A PERSON.
WHO'S BEEN EXPOSED OVER THIRTY
THREE YEARS TOO EXTENSIVE TOXINS.
I THINK WE OWE IT TO EVERY
RESIDENT THAT'S LIVING HERE TO
FIND THE MONEY FOR THE FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT IT
WILL TAKE TO CLEAN UP EVERY
PROPERTY.
OF THE TEN THOUSAND PARCELS THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED ID TSC.
AND I WOULD URGE US TO ALSO PUT
ALL OF OUR BRAIN POWER TOGETHER
WITH THE COMMUNITY LEADERS THAT
ARE IN THIS ROOM.
AND FIGURE OUT AN EXPEDITIOUS
WAY TO DO THIS CLEAN UP.
WHEN I DO THE CALCULATIONS?
FOR TEN AND I CALCULATE AT THE
HIGHEST RATE OF TWENTY FIVE
PARCELS A WEEK IT WILL TAKE
SEVEN AND A HALF YEARS FOR THIS
COMMUNITY TO BE CLEANED UP.
AND THAT WILL TAKE TOO LONG.
I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH FOLKS AND
ENOUGH PEOPLE POWER IN THIS ROOM.
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO IN FACT
EXPEDITE A CLEANUP PROCESS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT AND
PROVIDE REQUESTED SERVICES TO
THE RESIDENTS OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
SURROUNDING THE FORMER ACCENT
PLANT.
I'VE GIVEN THE SERIOUS RISKS ARE
THE COUNTY IS COMMITTED TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO YOUR REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL SERVICES AND I WANNA
THANK THE SUPERVISOR.
ANDMY SISTER AGENCIES OF BOTH
THE DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES. FOR RECOGNIZING THE
NEED TO OPEN UP A NEW CLINIC IN
THIS AREA BUT ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE BRINGING SERVICES TO
YOU.
IN YOUR PLACES OF WORSHIP WERE
HERE TONIGHT I WANT TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW --
WE WILL DRY NAME ANY LEAD LEVELS
HERE -- SO
IF YOU NEED TO GET YOUR BLOOD
LEVEL TESTED WERE IN THE ROOM
NEXT DOOR.
ON AND YOU KNOW YOU JUST NEED TO
LET US WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT A BARRIER TO GETTING TESTED
IS NOT THAT YOU CAN'T GET TO ONE
OF OUR CLINICS WE ARE HAPPY TO
BRING SERVICES.
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY OUT WE
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO STAND WITH YOU.
AND LOOK AT PROCESS SEES THAT
WOULD HELP MAKE THIS CLEAN UP --
BEARABLE AN EXPEDITED.
SO WE'RE ANXIOUS TO BE HERE
LISTENING TO YOU TONIGHT BUT
ALSO AT ALL YOUR OTHER COMMUNITY
MEETING SO THAT WE CAN SOLICIT
YOUR IDEAS.
OF WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOT ONLY ARE THE OUTSIDE OF
HOMES ABLE TO BE CLEANED BUT WE
WORRY A LOT ABOUT THE INSIDE OF
HOMES.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT OVER THIRTY
THREE YEARS DUST FROM
CONTAMINATED YARDS AND PARKWAYS
HAS NOT ENTERED INTO THE HOMES.
AND I DON'T WANT ANY OF US TO
FEEL SECURE IN THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT --
BECAUSE OUR HOUSES WEREN'T
SELECTED WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM.
WITH THE IMMEDIATE THE NEED TO
PROTECT OURSELVES AND OUR
FAMILIES FROM LEAD POISONING.
WE DO THE THRESHOLD OF FOUR
HUNDRED OF FOUR HUNDRED OF PARTS
PER MILLION.
IS IS A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF THE
VERY HIGH THRESHOLD.
OKAY ESPECIALLY WHEN WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S NO SAFE LEVEL OF
LEAD EXPOSURE FOR CHILDREN.
SO IF YOUR HOME IS NOT BEING
CLEANED UP IN THE FIRST TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED HOMES.
I URGE YOU TO STILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US AND TAKE
PRECAUTIONS TO LIMIT EXPOSURE TO
THE SOIL.
IT IS NOT SAFE EVEN LOW FOUR
HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION --
SO WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU
AGAIN AS WE CONTINUE TO PAY A
LOT OF ATTENTION TO THE
STRATEGIES FOR REMEDIATING
QUICKLY. TO ABSOLUTELY MINIMISE
THE EXPOSURE TO LEAD THAT EXISTS
IN THIS COMMUNITY.
ON SO I I WANT TO JUST CLOSE BY
THANKING EVERYONE I I WANT TO
THANK OUR STATE PARTNERS.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMUNITY LEADERS THAT ARE HERE
TONIGHT --
FOR MAKING SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING US TO DO.
WHICH IS TO DO WHAT GOVERNMENT
OUGHT TO DO WHICH IS STEP IN
WHEN OTHERS HAVE STEPPED OUT SO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GO AND TALK A LOT.
RIGHT OF MY NAME'S ADAM LOVE
AMONG OUTSIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSULTANT TO THE COUNTY OF LA
AND ENVIRONMENTAL FORENSICS
EXPERT.
OFF FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE
BEEN AROUND I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE ACCIDENT SITE NOW FOR
OVER FOUR YEARS --
AND AS WE ALL KNOW IT HAS
EVOLVED QUITE A BIT OVER THAT
TIME -- MY
ROLE HAS ALWAYS BEEN JUST TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL GUIDANCE TO
THE COUNTY.
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THE
DECISION MAKING IS BASED ON
SOUND SCIENCE.
AND THAT WERE PRACTICAL ABOUT
OUR APPROACH TO IT TO GOING
ABOUT WITH INVESTIGATION
REMEDIATION SOLUTIONS AND SO.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS AS THIS
HAS INVOLVED --
THAT'S BEEN MY ROLE IS TO BE
SHARES FOR WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
ODD TO REALLY COME IN AND SAY IS
THERE ANOTHER WAY IS THERE A
BETTER WAY.
ARM AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT GOING FORWARD I DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OTHER THAN
THAT -- REAL
AGAIN I'M UP HERE PRIMARILY AS A
RESOURCE TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
COME ACROSS THAT ARE REALLY
TECHNICAL RIGHT BECAUSE AS WE
KNOW THEY CAN BE A LOT OF SORT
OF DOUBLE SPEAKING GOBBLEDYGOOK
THAT GETS HIDDEN IN THE WAY THAT
THE NUMBERS ARE PRESENTED.
AND HOW THEY'RE DISCUSSED AND TO
HAVE SOMEBODY THAT KNOWS HOW TO
SNIFF THAT OUT.
AND KNOW WHAT A WAY TO EXPLAIN A
WAY THAT EVERYBODY CAN
UNDERSTAND.
UP THAT'S REALLY WHY I'M HERE
RIGHT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SITUATION
THAT WE'RE FACING.
DOESN'T GET DELIVERED.
BY THE ABILITY TO SORT OF
MANIPULATE NUMBERS OR MANIPULATE
THE PRESENTATION.
IN A WAY THAT THAT REALLY ALLOWS
THE TRUTH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND SUPERVISORS POLICE.
GOT SOME CLOTHES AND COME YES
I'M I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T ALSO THINK OUR COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN.
HELPING US MOVE OF THE AGENDA
LONG I WANT TO PARTICULARLY
THANK OUR COUNTY COUNCIL WHO IS
ALSO HERE.
ON THAT RECENTLY AS OF YESTERDAY
HELP TO WORK OUT AN AGREEMENT
REGARDING SO THAT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY
SETTLEMENT. FOR LISA CANYON --
REMARKABLY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL ALONG WITH OUR OFFICES
WERE ABLE. TO RECEIVE OR AT
LEAST WORK TOWARDS A FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
FOR LEAD PAINT CLEAN UP. FOR THE
INSIDE OF THE RESIDENCE IS NEAR
EXCITE OR IN EXILE I DO WANT TO
MENTION ALSO THAT WE HAVE ALSO
SECURED.
THROUGH OUR COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT A THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT FINE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT. TO CONTINUE
INTERIOR CLEAN UP SO I WANTED TO
SAY THAT BECAUSE I'VE HEARD SOME
BACK.
NOISE THAT THE COUNTY HASN'T.
AND INITIALLY WHEN WE STARTED
WHEN I FIRST TOOK OFFICE ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS I ASKED ASKED
WAS OUR STAFF. TO COME TOGETHER
SO WE COULD DO SOME TESTING WE
IMMEDIATELY PUT OVER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND WERE ABLE TO SHOW
THAT WE COULD TEST AT A FASTER
RATE.
THAN THE STATE COULD AND I'M
GLAD THAT WHAT WE LEARN FROM
THAT DTS C. HAS.
HAS LOOKED AT THAT WE WANT TO BE
HELPFUL WE WANT TO PROVIDE
WHATEVER EXPERTISE WE CAN WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS BUT
IF WE WORK TOGETHER I THINK WE
CAN SOLVE.
A LOT OF THESE PROBLEMS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I THINK --
MS GARCIA HAS A QUESTION TO BE.
I DO YOU --
THIS PRAYER YOU SPOKE ABOUT THIS
FALSE SENSE OF WE ARE SAFE IF
IT'S FOUR HUNDRED FOUR FOUR
HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION AND WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT THE SAME
WAY.
YOU KNOW WE KEEP REFERRING TO
THE CHILDREN AND INTO THE
PREGNANT MOTHERS OUT THERE --
BUT I MEAN I I THINK AND ALONG
THAT VEIN.
WHAT ABOUT EVERYONE ELSE ARE
THEY SAFE AND?
WHAT ARE THE EFFECTS OF THE
CONTINUED EXPOSURE I IT'S THE
THIRTY YEARS PLUS?
YOU KNOW THE SIX YEARS THAT THIS
THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN ENGAGED AND
THEN WE'LL REPORT POSSIBLY
ANOTHER SEVEN YEARS IF EVER
THERE JUST WITH THE CLEAN UP AT
LEAST A TEN THOUSAND MEAN I'D
LIKE.
TO INVITE A DOCTOR OF RAG AND TO
COME UP ON HIS OUR TOXICOLOGIST.
HOME AND I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A
QUESTION OF THAT OF REALLY
DEMAND SORT OF A VERY CONCISE
KNOW AROUND THE TOXICOLOGY LAB
DOCTOR MAYBE YOU CAN USE THE
MICROPHONE THAT DON'T.
AT THE LECTERN [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH IT'S NOT MY CAR.
YEAH THANK YOU [inaudible]
TEST TEST [inaudible]
SO THE THE QUESTION ABOUT
ONGOING OF LEAD EXPOSURE IN THE
SITUATION AS IT IS IS QUITE A
COMPLEX ONE BUT I'LL TRY TO
CLARIFY.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT?
THE MULTIPLE SOURCES OF LEAD
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR ENVIRONMENT
IT'S IT'S REALLY QUITE --
QUITE A WIDE ARRAY AND WE OFTEN
THINK ABOUT LEG PAIN IS BEING
THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF LEAD
EXPOSURE FOR MOST PEOPLE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
AND THAT STILL HOLDS TRUE TODAY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE HOWEVER IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A DIFFERENT SITUATION?
YES THERE ARE A LOT OF HOMES
THERE THAT MAY HAVE LEAD PAINT.
THERE'S ALSO A NUMBER OF HOMES
THAT HAVE LIKE CONTAMINATION IN
THE SOIL SEMI CONTAMINATION HAS
BEEN DEPOSITED IN THAT SOIL.
ACTUALLY NOT JUST FOR THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS BUT FOR THE PAST.
EIGHTY OR NINETY YEARS THAT THAT
THAT PLAN ACTUALLY HAS BEEN IN
OPERATION JUST EXCITED TO HAVE A
PERMIT FOR THIRTY YEARS BUT HE'S
REALLY BEEN GOING ON FOR SEVERAL
MORE DCADES BEFORE THAT.
AND THE MISSIONS THAT WERE GOING
ON IN THOSE PREVIOUS YEARS WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THOSE
LEVELS OF EMISSIONS WERE AND
WHAT THE EXPOSURES MAY HAVE BEEN
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED HERE.
ALL THOSE SEVERAL DECADES SO
RIGHT NOW IT'S VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO REALLY QUANTIFY.
AND DETERMINE EXACTLY WHAT
PEOPLE'S EXPOSURES MAY HAVE BEEN.
THAT BEING SAID WHEN WE LOOK
TODAY.
IT'S A BIG MYSTERY BECAUSE WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT SOMETHING LIKE
LIKE LIKE PAINT.
WE CAN LOOK AT THE LEAD PAINT
AND WE CAN TAKE MEASURES THAT
ARE NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
PREVENT EXPOSURES TO LEAD PAINT
INSIDE A HOME AND WE'VE GOT
PROCEDURES AND PROTOCOLS FOR
THAT.
AND THEY WORK.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO LETTING
YOUR SOIL.
IT'S A BIG MYSTERY HOW DO YOU
KNOW WHERE YOUR CHILD IS PLAYING
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
IN THE HOT SPOT HOW DO YOU KNOW
THAT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO PLAY IN
THAT SPOT TODAY OR TOMORROW OR
THE NEXT DAY AND HOW MUCH LATER
THE REALLY NTERESTING.
IT'S REALLY A GIANT QUESTION
MARK AND WHEN WE GO AND SAMPLE
THESE LOCATIONS ALL OVER THE
COMMUNITY WE MAY FIND A HOT SPOT
IN ONE HOME.
WE MAY FIND THAT THERE'S NOT A
HOT SPOT ANOTHER HOME BUT THAT
HOME THAT WE DIDN'T FIND A HOT
SPOT.
MAY HAVE SEVERAL HOT SPOTS AND
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IT THAT WAY
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE NOTION
THAT IF YOU FIND A HOT SPOT IN
ONE PROPERTY.
THAT YOU MAY ACTUALLY HAVE THE
SAME KIND OF LEVEL OF
CONTAMINATION IN THE NEXT
PROPERTY.
EVEN THOUGH YOU DIDN'T
NECESSARILY FIND IT WITH YOUR
SAMPLING.
SO WE HAVE SITUATIONS WHERE ONE
HOUSEHOLD NEEDS TO BE CLEAN THE
NEXT HOME ISN'T ON THE LIST BUT
THE HOME RIGHT NEXT TO THAT IS
ON THE LIST.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE NEED
TO TAKE A MUCH MORE BROAD AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH BECAUSE
EVERYONE IS EXPOSED TO ALL THE
LIGHT IT'S NOT JUST ON YOUR
PROPERTY OR JUST ON THE PARKWAY
THAT MIGHT BE FROM YOUR HOUSE
IT'S EVERYONE EXPOSED TO ALL THE
LEAD.
SO WE NEED TO TAKE A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH BECAUSE
WE CAN'T QUANTIFY WHAT THAT
EXPOSURES GOING TO BE FOR THIS
COMMUNITY.
BUT WE ARE ALL THAT RACE
ANYWHERE IN THIS COMMUNITY NOT
JUST CHILDREN AND MOTHERS.
ABSOLUTELY ANY ALL ALL THE
POPULATIONS ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE THE HIGHEST RISK.
IN GENERAL WE WE SAY ARE THE
MOTHERS MOTHERS OF CHILDBEARING
AGE IN THE CHILDREN BUT
CERTAINLY EVERYBODY IS AT RISK
AND AND WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
END THAT HOLISTIC FASHION.
I ASKED THAT QUESTION I KNEW THE
ANSWER BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR SO LONG THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO NORMAL LIFE.
WAS STARTING TO CHANGE OUR
EXPECTATION EVER SINCE THEY ALL
WELL I'M NOT AT A THOUSAND PARTS
PER MILLION I'M ONLY A FOUR
HUNDRED TOM OKAY BUT NOW WE KNOW
THAT'S NOT TRUE ALL WHILE I'M
NOT PREGNANT I DON'T HAVE A TWO
YEAR OLD FROM.
EVEN THE ONES THAT --
GIVEN WHAT YOU JUST.
TOLD ME WHICH I JUST LEARNED
SOMETHING NEW ABOUT THE FACT
THAT YES EVEN THOUGH THE WHITE%
HOUSE OVER MIGHT NOT BE TESTING
THAT THAT THOUSAND PARTS PER
MILLION.
I MEAN IT TO THEIRS OUT AT IT IS
THAT WE'RE ALL EXPOSED.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE KEEP
SPENDING MONEY IN THE IN THE IN
THE PROCESS WITH TESTING.
WHEN WE TAKE LESS IT'S CLEAN IT
UP?
I WELL THE SCHOOL WHILE YOU'RE
LESS LIKELY TO BE PLAIN IN THAT
PARK WHERE I WAS LIKE WHEN I WAS
THREE YEARS OLD I WAS PLAYING
AND AND THE PARKWAY FLASHES THE
SIDEWALK RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOUR
HOUSE.
KIDS CALL IT WHAT IT IS I WOULD
PLAY THAT'S I LOOK IN THE TOOLS
AND THE TIME WALKING THE SAME
WAY I WOULD BE DIGGING HOLES IN
THE BACK OF OUR HOUSE.
AND YEAH MY MOM WOULD PREFER I
DIDN'T WANT TO SOUND LIKE WHAT
SHE COULDN'T KEEP AN EYE ON ME
ALL THE TIME AND SO I THINK.
WE THEY ARE ALL DOES THIS
IMPORTANT AND GIVEN THE SIGNS
THAT AN EXPERT IS TELLING THEM.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHY WE KEEP SAYING WE NEED TO
TEST AND IF THAT'S THE PROCESS
THEN LET'S CHANGE THE PROFIT
THEY THINK LEVEL THIS TELL THE
TSC?
AT THEY COULD SKIP THAT STEP OFF
AND MAKE THOSE AS YOU MAY THINK
THEY'LL EXPEDITE THE PROCESS.
ON IT AT ALL APPROPRIATE OR
MONEY INTO A MUCH BETTER PLACE.
THINKING.
I'M IN MY SECOND QUESTION IS --
WE KNOW ABOUT EXIDE WE NOBODY
EVEN THOSE YOU KNOW.
WILL PASS AND THE CANDY WITH
SOMEBODY NOW AND THEN THAT THEY
HAVE LED TO I MEAN I THOUGHT
BEING THOSE --
AWHILE AGO I EGG BUT EXCITED
WITH BRINGING US INTO THE CLINIC
EXACTLY THREE UNITS TO A HEARING
LIKE THIS.
WHAT IS?
YOU GUYS ON THE GROUND IN THE
COUNTY WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
HELP EDUCATE THE FOLKS ABOUT ALL
THE OTHER EXPOSURES TO LET OUR
OTHER THINGS AND AND HOW HE
COULD.
BE BETTER BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
EXCITED THAT'S BECAUSE ME WELL
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO FIGURE OUT
WHO'S ACCOUNTABLE WOULD WE TRIED
FOR THE CLEAN UP AND I WAS LIKE
WELL I DON'T HAVE THIRTY YEARS
THAT CATHOLIC PEOPLE KEEPING
SICK BUT ARE YOU TAKING
OPPORTUNITIES.
I AM IN THIS HOUR WE TAKE YOUR
DOING TO DO THE DIGITAL TEST --
EDUCATION AND WHAT DOES IT LOOK
LIKE YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT YOU
KNOW.
PEOPLE.
ARE JUST HOLD PEOPLE AND THEY
NEED ALL OF THEIR NEEDS
ADDRESSED IN ONE OF THE THINGS
THE COUNTY FAMILY TRIES TO DO IS.
MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
AND THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
SAYING YOU KNOW WE STILL OUT IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY WE
HAVE A TEAM WITH A PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE.
AND OFTEN A HEALTH EDUCATOR THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND GOING DOOR TO
DOOR STILL TO TALK WITH PEOPLE
ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS BUT IT'S
ABOUT YOUR BROADER CONCERNS ARE.
SOME OF WHICH ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED.
TO THE EXPOSURES YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED FROM THE X. I.
CONTAMINATION SOME OF WHICH MAY
BE RELATED TO NOT BEING WELL
CONNECTED TO OTHER SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT YOU NEED.
A THIRD AREA WHERE WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TO REALLY HELP IS TO MAKE
SURE THE PROVIDERS UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS COMMUNITY
AND THAT THEY TOO ARE SENSITIVE
TO THE EXTRA SCREENINGS THAT YOU
MAY NEED.
AN EXTRA TESTING THAT YOU MAY
NEED TO ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT
THE RISKS OF EXPOSURES ARE
TRANSLATING INTO A MEDIA.
OR FUTURE HEALTH NEEDS HOW WE'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO CONNECT MORE
KLUM.
CONNECT MORE APPROPRIATELY WITH
THE SCHOOLS IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
SO THAT THE SCHOOLS ALSO
UNDERSTAND WHAT EXPOSURE TO LEAD
MAY DO FOR CHILDREN'S LEARNING
AND HOW TO BEST MAKE SURE THAT
THE ENVIRONMENT AT SCHOOL
SUPPORT ALL CHILDREN LEARNING.
AND GIVE REALLY GOOD ACCESS TO
BOTH THE SCREENING THAT CHILDREN
NEED BUT MORE IMPORTANTLYTHE
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S NEEDED. FOR
CHILDREN TO FLOURISH AND LEARN --
SO WE YOU KNOW THIS IS FEEDBACK
WE RECEIVE FROM YOU ABOUT A
WHOLE HOST OF SERVICES THAT
YOU'D LIKE US TO DO AND YOU KNOW
GET A SUPERVISOR SO HE SAID YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LARGE COUNTY
FAMILY HERE --
AND WE'RE AT YOUR SERVICE --
IT'S OUR JOB AND AND WE WANT TO
DO IT WELL AND FOR FALLING SHORT
WE'RE ALWAYS ANXIOUS WE COULD BE
DOING. TO SUPPORT YOUR NEEDS IT
REALLY IS A NEED TO MAKE SURE
YOU HAVE ALL OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE RESOURCES
YOU NEED. TO FOR OPTIMAL WELL
BEING TO BE AS HEALTHY AND WELL
AS POSSIBLE.
GUESS MY QUESTION IS MORE
SPECIFIC FOR EXAMPLE I DON'T ADD
AND THOUGHT ABOUT THIS BUT TODAY
THEY TALK ABOUT OUR PETS AND AND
WHEN WE THINK THAT YOU THINK ARE
MY PETS BEING SICK.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT TOO HIGH I
HAVE FOUR KIDS OF MY OWN BUT THE
BIGGER CONNECTION OF YOUR PETS
ARE TRACKING IN THE DIRT WITH
THE LEAD INTO YOUR HOUSE ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
I DON'T THINK I HADN'T GIVEN
THAT ANY THOUGHT ARE YOU WHEN US
WE ARE WE ACTUALLY TALKING TO
PEOPLE ABOUT MITIGATION.
WELL I OTHER FOLKS LRIGHT SO
AND THAT'S WHY I WAS SAYING AND
I WANT PEOPLE TO BE AWARE LIKE
THE MITIGATION EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW SO
WHAT WHAT TO DO IF YOU LIVE IN
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD NOW. TO REDUCE
THE EXPOSURE INCLUDES SORT OF
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT.
MAKING SURE YOUR SHOES ARE NOT
OUTDOOR SHOES ARE NOT WORN
INDOORS THAT THEY'RE TAKEN OFF
DUSTING OFF THE THE FEET OF YOUR
PATHS.
ARE WHEN THEY COME IN SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT TRACKING IN A LEAD
US WHILE WE TALK WITH FOLKS
ABOUT WAYS TO KEEP THE HOUSE
CLEAN.
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING TO
STAND HERE AND TELL YOU TO CLOSE
YOUR WINDOWS AND YOUR DOORS --
IN IN THIS HEAT THAT THAT WOULD
BE AN IMPOSSIBLE REQUEST BUT WE
ARE GOING TO TELL YOU OTHER WAYS
TO MINIMIZE EXPOSURES WE'VE
TALKED A LOT WITH PEOPLE ABOUT
NOT GROWING VEGETABLES --
IN THEIR GARDENS ON BECAUSE WE
CAN'T ASSURE THE SAFETY OF A YOU
KNOW THAT SYMBOLS THAT ARE GROWN
IN SOIL THAT'S CONTAMINATED WITH
LEAD.
ON SO I I THINK AGAIN ON AND A
BIG SHOUT OUT TO THE TEAM OF
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES THAT DO GO
DOOR TO DOOR.
ON AND TRY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AS WELL AS THE FOLKS
THAT ARE AT YOUR HEALTH FAIRS
ETCETERA TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLEDO HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY.
OF MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND I LEFT BY NOW AND
OUR TEAM SPEAK SPANISH.
HOME SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SERVICES ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE IN A LANGUAGE THAT
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND THAT WE'RE HERE.
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND IF WE
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWERS TO HELP
FIND THE ANSWERS FOR YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS.
I AM I GUESS I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT ON THE TESTING --
IN IN THINKING ABOUT
[inaudible]
RECOVERY [inaudible]
SO.
THE ORIGINAL MONEY THAT WAS
PROPOSED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO THE CLEANING TO DO THE
TESTING AND THE CLEAN UP.
IS TO HAVE A GUARANTEE
[inaudible]
FROM EXIDE.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS
MONEY BACK.
AND SO WHILE IT IS.
WELL IT IS --
INCREDIBLY TIME CHALLENGING.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WANT TO HOLD
EXCITE ACCOUNTABLE RIGHT NOW.
THE MONEY APPROPRIATED AS
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS FOR SOMETHING
THAT A CORPORATION DID TO HARM
OUR COMMUNITY.
AND SO WE WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
IN IN A WAY THAT'S PRODUCTIVE IN
A WAY THAT HOLD EXCITE
ACCOUNTABLE IN A WAY THAT WE THE
TAXPAYER.
GET THIS MONEY BACK FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
SO RIGHT NOW THE STATE IS
PUTTING IT UP I'M SO GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THE COUNTY HAS.
ALSO ALLOCATED FUNDS I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP ON ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT FROM THE CITY
COUNCILS IN THE SMALLER CITIES
CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
THE COUNTY THE STATE OF OUR NEW
POTENTIAL GOVERNOR GETTING
INVOLVED.
IN ENSURING THAT THIS CLEAN UP
THIS EXPEDITED.
BUT WHILE THERE ARE FRUSTRATIONS
THERE ARE ALSO THE REALITIES.
OF HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THIS MONEY BACK.
MISTER SANTIAGO SHIP OF ONE I
THINK --
CALIBER SUPERVISOR ON POLICE.
UP FOR HARD WORK AND HER TEAM AT
THE COUNTY FAMILY AND YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THE POTENTIAL
POSSIBILITIES TO CONTINUE
COLLABORATING.
AND MAYBE DOING MORE GOOD LOOK
WE'VE HAD TTC IS OUTLINED A
CHALLENGE --
TO GETTING THE AGREEMENTS --
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT MAYBE THERE'S ALWAYS THERE
THAT THE COUNTY CAN HELP WITH.
IF THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE
PROPERTY AGREEMENTS TO CLEAN UP
WHEN YOU'RE WALKERS ARE OUT
THERE AND IT'S AN EFFECTIVE TOOL
AND I THINK IT I THINK IT TAKES
ON IT TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
TO GRASP THE FULL BREADTH.
OF THE ABILITY OF THE COUNTY TO
POTENTIALLY PARTICIPATE AT THAT
LEVEL BUT THERE MAY BE OTHER
GAPS.
OTHER BEEN OUTLINED AT THE
WITHERS FURTHER COLLABORATION TO
ATTACK SOME OF THOSE PROBLEMS.
AND AS I'M HERE TALKING YOU
TALKING I THINK WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A CHALLENGE NOT NONE THE
LESS TO CLEAN THIS UP AND I BUT
THERE MAY BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVE IT TO ADD VALUE TO WHAT WE
DO WHEN WE STEPPED IN FRONT OF
SOME.
A NEIGHBOR --
THERE MAY BE MAD AT CAL --
FORMS -- AND
THERE MAY BE --
I HSS OPPORTUNITIES OR MAYBE ALL
THE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE MAY
<c.red>AVE NOT TALKED ABOUT ONE WARM</c>
PART OF THAT --
CONSTITUENT --
EIGHT IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
THINK OUTSIDE OF THIS
CONVERSATION MAY WE CAN
CHALLENGE OURSELVES TO
BRAINSTORM A LITTLE BIT MORE
WHAT WE'VE GOT AT THE STATE WHAT
YOU'VE GOT AT THE COUNTY. TO TRY
TO MAKE RESIDENTS OF HOLE WHERE
IT WERE A GOVERNMENT THAT PASSES
FILL THEM AND SO THANK YOU ONCE
ONCE AGAIN. FOR YOUR
COLLABORATION.
I THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE.
AND I AM NOT ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
CAN'T AGREE WITH YOU OF I THINK
THAT OUR ATTEMPT RIGHT NOW IS TO
GET OUR BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
WE HAVE A SLEW OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH THEY'RE KNOWN AS
PROMISED ON US.
THEIR HEALTH NAVIGATORS THEY GO
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY BUT THEY'RE
ALSO HERE TODAY --
GIVING INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE EXPOSED TO LEAD
POISONING.
EXIDE WITH SOME OF THE SIGNS ARE
WHERE AND WE'VE HAD TEAMS GO OUT
PERIODICALLY AND AS YOU HEARD
FROM OUR DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
THE COMMUNICATION HAS TO HAPPEN
ONE ON ONE IT CAN'T BE THROUGH A
FLYER YOU CAN'T JUST BE GOING ON
A PORTAL IT HAS TO BE MORE THAN
THAT FOR THIS COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THEY ARE CHALLENGED.
AND THEY DO NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE REMEDIES JUST TWO
DAYS WHEN WE HEARD WHEN WE ASKED
THE QUESTION ABOUT IF YOUR SOIL
IS GOING TO BE CLEANED UP AROUND
YOUR HOUSE.
AND THE HOMEOWNER SAYS WELL I
DON'T WANT YOU TO TOUCH MY TREAT.
BUT THAT TREE IS IMPACTED BY THE
SAME LEVEL OF POISONING LEAD
POISONING AND THE HOUSEHOLD
ORDER OR TEN IT DOESN'T REALIZE.
THAT IF THEY DON'T REMOVE THAT
TREE THERE ISSTILL GOING TO BE
A LEVEL OF LET THAT IS STILL
POISONOUS AND TOXIC WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A BETTER.
COMMUNICATION PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWS FOR THAT INFORMATION TO
BE MADE AVAILABLE IN A LANGUAGE
AND IN A CULTURALLY COMPETENT
MANNER SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY HAVE CHOICES HERE.
AND FURTHER MORE PEOPLE WANT TO
HAVE THEIR HOMES CLEAN.
IN THE INTERIOR THE UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY WON'T BE
INCONVENIENCED SO WE COULD TAKE
THEM AS AS WAS SAID BY DTS SEE
ON THE GROUND.
THE PEOPLE COULD STAY SOMEWHERE
ELSE WHY THAT REMEDIATION GOES
ON AND I KNOW SOME PEOPLE DON'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THIS IS WHAT THEY DID YOU
KNOW LISA CANYON.
THEY ALLOWED FOR PEOPLE TO GO
STAY IN OTHER PLACES WHILE THE
REMEDIATION OCCURRED.
I DON'T SEE WHY.
WE HAVE TO TOTALLY BE TREATED IN
SUCH A DIFFERENT MANNER IT'S
ABOUT EXPLAINING ON A VERY BASIC
AND HUMAN LEVEL.
AND I THINK WE'RE WE FEEL
OBLIGATED TO DO TO HELP THEM DO
THAT WITH WITH THE STATE AND
WITH THE TSC AND WITH OUR LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMUNITY BASED
GROUPS.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE COUNTY
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
PATCHWORK OF JURISDICTIONS OUT
HERE -- AND
I'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT THE
CHALLENGE OF HAVING OWNERS OF
PROPERTY TO HAVE TEN AND I WHO
ARE NOT SIGNING THOSE AGREEMENTS
TO COME IN AND DO THE CLEANUP I
I THINK.
WE GOT TO THE FIRST VERY ARE
COMMITTING A LOT AND AND WE
HAVEN'T GOT INTO ALL OF THEM BUT
THAT WASN'T THERE THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF DOOR
KNOCKING WE WERE ABLE TO GET TO
BUT NOW ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
GETTING THEM TO CALL US BACK AND
THEY KNOW THAT THEY HAD THESE
LEVELS TO LET US IN TO CLEAN UP.
THERE'S LOTS OF REASONS WHY
INDIVIDUALS ARE HESITANT TO LET
GOVERNMENT INTO.
THEIR BACKYARDS FOR WHATEVER
REASON ARE INTO THEIR HOMES AND
THEIR PROPERTIES.
AND SOME OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH
CLINTON FOR SPENT --
AND SO DO WE HAVE SOME SORT OF
COMMITMENT AND THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
THOSE THINGS ARE THE I MEAN.
WHETHER.
I WON PLACES UP TO CODE WHAT I
ULTIMATELY IN ONE PLACE IS CLEAN
RIGHT NOW FIRST AND FOREMOST --
AND SO.
WHEN I'VE TALKED TO THE FOLKS
ARE LIKE WELL I'M NOT TAKING
THERE IS AND I TALKED TO SOME
FOLKS LIKE HAVE YOU DONE
ANYTHING TO YOUR PROPERTY LIKE
NO BUT I DON'T KNOW IF I BROUGHT
IT UP TO PUT EITHER?
AND I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE THE
RISK RIGHT NOW --
AND SO WHAT WHAT HAPPENS I MEAN
WHAT'S THE ANSWER TO THAT DO
THIS QUITE A FORCE FOR THE FOR
SOME PART OF IT AS A SECURITY
THAT NONE OF THAT'S GONNA.
COME INTO PLAY IN WHICH IS GOING
TO CLEAN AND WELL I WOULD.
I MEAN I I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC WORKS HERE.
WE DO SO WE CAN HAVE SOMEONE
PLEASE COME UP.
BUT THESE ARE THESE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE.
ASKED ALSO IN TERMS OF
IDENTIFYING.
IT MAY NOT LIVE IN THIS AREA BUT
WE ONLY HAVE TWO AND I THINK OUR
OTHER DEPARTMENTS CAN BE HELPFUL.
IN FINDING OUT WHO OWNS THE DEED
WHO OWNS THE PROPERTY AND THEN
CONTACTING THEM BUT DOING A
COLLABORATIVE LEAVE WITH.
THE TSC BECAUSE WE DO HAVE THE
TAX ROLLS WE DO HAVE ALL THAT
INFORMATION RIGHT AND NO ONE CAN
WORK COLLABORATIVE I BELIEVE ON
THAT ISSUE.
WHEN YOU'VE DONE SOME CONTRACT%
AND THEN THEY STILL LET YOU AND?
I YOU KNOW AND SO I GET THE
PROPERTY RIGHTS BUT I KNOW THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE HESITATION.
ON SO I DON'T KNOW THAT
SOMETHING AND I KNOW AGAIN.
IS A SPECIFIC ONLY TO THE
UNINCORPORATED --
JURISDICTIONS I KNOW YOU TO BE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT. FOR THE COUNTY
THAT'S CORRECT ONE MOTHER GONE.
PUBLIC WORKS REALLY COUNTY.
WE DON'T WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE CLEAN UP IS A PRIORITY TO
THE COUNTY TO OUR SUPERVISOR.
SO WE WILL FOCUS ON THE CLEAN UP
EFFORTS AS OPPOSED TO OUR
COMMUNITY BEING AFRAID OF A
PUBLIC WORKS GOING IN THERE.
AND FIGHT IT IN FOR ME PERHAPS
WE ASSURE THE COUNT THE
DEPARTMENT.
ALTHOUGH ALL THE COUNTY ALL
PEOPLE HERE.
THAT WE WILL FOCUS ON THE CLEAN
UP EFFORT ON OUR SITE WE'RE
DOING THE GRADING DRAINAGE
REVIEW.
OF EACH PROPERTY TO ENSURE THAT
THE THE DRAINAGES PLAYS BACK
PROPERLY.
CONDITIONS THERE THAN IT WAS
BEFORE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DRAINAGE IS --
IS PROPERLY TRAINED LIKE IT WAS
BEFORE THAT IS OUR FOCUS AND WE
WANT TO ASSURE THE PEOPLE HERE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON
THAT.
I THINK ANY OF OUR OTHER
STAKEHOLDER FROM OTHER CITIES DO
WE COULD GIVE THAT ASSURANCE
ENSURE THAT INFORMATION I DON'T
THINK WILL CAPTURE EVERYONE BUT
WILL CAPTURE A FEW MORE FOLKS TO
LET US INTO THEIR INTO THEIR
PROPERTY SO WE COULD TAKE CARE
OF PEOPLE'S PUBLIC.
OUT THERE TO HELP.
YOU'RE WITHOUT RESPONSE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE TO
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT. TO A VERY
MUCH THE PRESENTATION MADE
QUESTION ANSWERED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE A BREAK
BETWEEN THESE TWO PANELS
[inaudible]
AND CAN WE GET SET UP FOR THE
NEXT NOW VERY QUICKLY WE'LL ASK
OUR SPEAKERS SO THESE ARE.
THREE COMMUNITY STAKE. TO COME
FORWARD
[inaudible]
YES.
I HAVE. ONE LAST [inaudible]
REALLY [inaudible]
YEAH.
ON IF YOU PARK.
RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
SOME OF THE OKAY THANK YOU.
HERE FROM OUR AFRICAN UNITY
STAKEHOLDERS NOW.
AND THEN PROCEED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
IF YOU CULD TAKE YOUR SEATS
[inaudible]
AND IT LOOKS  E
WAITING ON MONSIGNOR.
LORETTA THAT I WILL INTRODUCE
WILL BEGIN THEN --
WITHOUT FULLY PAID A DEAR A
FOLLOWED BY JANE WILLIAMS.
WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU.
THINK YOU [inaudible]
OF MONSIGNOR.
IS STEPPING FORWARD NOW.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR WELCOMING US --
INTO THIS WONDERFUL ALL.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO HAVE YOU HERE.
TO ADDRESS US ABOUT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
YES I'M I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE
BECAUSE I LIVE HERE ACTUALLY SO
I'M VERY. FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN THE PASTOR HERE AND
TONIGHT.
A I I REALLY --
MAYBE MY SAY EVERYTHING I SAID
HERE.
AND TO SPEAK.
HAS BEEN ALREADY MENTIONED.
BUT THERE IS ONE THING I WANT TO
SHARE WITH ALL OF YOU AND I
SHOULD WITH SOME OF THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS IT JUST HAPPENED A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
AND IT WAS A MEETING THAT FOUR
OF US IN THE COMMUNITY WENT --
TO A RALLY --
FOR GAVIN NEWSOM OUT IN A VAN
NUYS.
AND HE HAD A QUESTION ANSWER
THING.
AND ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I WAS
ABLE TO ASK HIM WAS ESTIMATES
BUT DON'T REALIZE IT PUT EXCITE
US GONNA BE SHOULD BE ON YOUR
RADAR I WANT YOU NOT. TO TO
FORGET THAT IT'S GONNA BE A
PRIORITY IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. FOR MY COMMUNITY AND I
SHARED WITH HIM THE RESEARCH.
THE DOCTOR JOE JOHNSON DIDN'T I
JUST WISH YEAH.
SHE STILL HERE IS THERE SHE IS
RIGHT OVER THERE THE LADY SHE'S
A REAL HERO.
SHE WAS MENTIONED IN THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS ABOUT THE
RESEARCH AS HE HAD DONE.
AND IT WE JUST RECEIVED THE
RESULTS OF THE TIME.
AND SO I SHARED WITH THIS
COMMUNITY HERE MOSTLY ANGLE.
I SAID TO THEM I SAID YOU KNOW I
SAID.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT --
THE WOMEN THE COLLECTED TO STILL
HAD THEIR THEIR CHILDREN'S BABY
TEETH THEY THEY WERE PART OF
THIS SURVEY.
AND OUR BABIES TEASE WHEN THEY
WERE TESTED AGAINST OF THE TWO
OTHER SITES THAT OTHER PLACES.
OF THE OTHER BABIES TEETH OUR
BABY'S TEETH.
DESPITE THE NAME OUT OF LEAD
THAT WAS IN AN ALL BABIES TEETH
SPIKED WITH THE LEAD.
AND WHY I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT IS BECAUSE THE REACTION NOT
OF OF THE OF THE GATHERING
NEWSOME.
BUT IT WAS OF THE PEOPLE THERE
MOSTLY ANGLO PEOPLE AS I SAID.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DID THEY WENT
THERE WAS AN AUDIBLE GROAN ALL.
ONLY YOU COULD SEE EVERYBODY SAY
THAT.
HE REACTED LIKE PARENTS IN THIS
EVERYBODY OF ALL.
I'M PREACHING TO THE YOU'LL
YOU'LL KNOW WHAT THE SITUATION
IS WHO YOU KNOW IS YOU SPOKE
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT IT TONIGHT.
AND I JUST EMPHASIZE THAT
EXPEDITIOUSLY IT QUICKLY --
IT'S BEEN SIX YEARS MORE THAN
SIX YEARS NOW [inaudible]
AND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY HOMES
IN SIX YEARS IS NOT A VERY GOOD
RECORD.
HOPEFULLY I WILL BE ABLE --
TO TO TO PROGRESS AND AND AND
MAKE THAT AND I HOPE THAT THE
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THIS THE
DECISION MAKERS THAT MOST OF YOU
ARE HERE THIS PANEL.
THAT A WILL ACT AS PARENTS AND
TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO HAVE IT CLEANED UP RIGHT
LIKE RIGHT NOW LIKE YESTERDAY IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLEANED UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MAN SEEN HERE THIS IS
BY THE WAY THIS IS OUR LAST
PANEL.
AFTER THIS WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THERE ARE COMMENT CARDS THAT ARE --
BEING FILLED OUT AROUND THE ROOM
TO IT SO WE WILL.
CONSIDER THOSE ALSO.
AFTER WE CONCLUDE THIS PANEL.
AND THE NOW WE'LL MOVE FORWARD
WITH OUR NEXT COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDER PHILLY PAY AGAIN.
YES WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION FOR BEING HERE BY OUR
LIVE AND WORK IN THE CITY OF
MAYWOOD IT'S A LITTLE CITY HERE --
SOUTH OF THE OF THE US OF THE
AREA BOYLE HEIGHTS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY IS ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT IS REALLY MY BY THIS --
COMPANY EXCITE.
NOW ONE OF THE SPEAKERS BEFORE
DOCTOR REGNANT SAID THAT THIS
COMPANY HAD NOT BEEN AROUND FOR
THIRTY THREE YEARS.
EXCITED BEEN AROUND FOR THIRTY
THREE YEARS WITH THIS COMPANY.
THAT DOES LEAD BATTERY RECYCLING
HAD BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO TWO YEARS BEFORE THE
CITY OF MAY WOULD EVEN EXISTED.
AS AN INCORPORATED CITY AND MANY
OTHER CITIES IN THE SOUTHEAST
MAYBE NOT LOS ANGELES.
LOS ANGELES AROUND A BIT BEFORE.
BUT THE AMOUNT OF DAMAGE THAT
THIS COMPANY HAS DONE AND THE
PREVIOUS COMPANY THAT WERE --
PROPRIETORS OF THIS PLACE IN OUR
COMMUNITY OF EXPOSING US TO LEAD.
AND THE WAY THAT WE FOUND OUT
WAS BECAUSE DTS HE HAD NOT DONE
THEIR JOB.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF REGULATING
THE EMISSIONS FROM THAT COMPANY
IN REGULATING OTHER CLEAN ABOUT
THAT PLACE EVEN GIVING THEM YOU
KNOW TEMPORARY PERMITS. FOR
THIRTY YEARS SO THIS IS HOW WE
CAME TO FIND OUT ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AT THIS COMPANY.
BUT THE HISTORY OF THIS COMPANY
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR QUITE AWHILE.
AND IT'S NOT REALLY. TO BE
POSSIBLE TO SAY THAT THE WAY THE
OF THE CLEANUP.
SUCH A HIGH AMOUNT OF
CONTAMINATION IT SEEMS THAT
WE'RE INVITING SOMEONE INTO OUR
HOME AND THEY COULD YOU HELP ME
CLEAN UP MY PROPERTY CUT BECAUSE
AT MY HOUSE.
AND THE AGENCY IN CHARGE OF
CLEANING JUST SAYS OKAY ROAD
GOING TO CLEAN THE CLOSETS.
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE LEAD
EVERYWHERE ELSE.
BECAUSE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DGSE CANNOT GUARANTEE THAT ALL
THOSE PROPERTIES THAT ARE BEING
CLEANED UP THEY ARE GOING TO BE
LET FREE.
THEY MAY GIVE SOME GIFT
CERTIFICATE BUT THEN THAT
DOESN'T STAY IN THE GROUND
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE THE PARK
RACE.
THE LADIES IN THE WINDOW SILLS
AND THAT IS INSIDE THE HOUSE IS
THE LATEST FIGHT THE ADDICTS.
SO JUST BECAUSE YOU FINISH A
HOUSE IS NOT MEAN THAT HOUSES
LET FREE.
AND I THINK THERE WERE GIVING
PEOPLE A FALSE SENSE OF SECURITY
THING.
OKAY HE LETTERS THE TAKING OUT
OF YOUR YARD.
THAT LEAD IS GONE BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE WAY THAT.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
DOING THIS CLEAN UP.
IF YOU DON'T DO A CLEANUP BLOCK
BY BLOCK YOU DON'T DO IN A MORE
ORGANIZED WAY THAT THAT'S GOING
TO COME BACK.
AND WE HAVE THAT THAT EXPERIENCE
IN MAY WOULD.
BECAUSE WE PARTICIPATE IN THE
CLEAN UP OF A PLACE CALLED
PEDICLE WITH THE CITY LATER
BUILT A PARK.
SO WE HAD A BATTLE WITH THE PAY
FOR MANY YEARS IN THE PROCESS
THE WAY THE CLEANUP THAT SITE.
BUT THEY DID A VERY YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT A VERY GOOD JOB IN
TERMS OF THE CLEAN UP.
SO GUESS WHAT YEARS LATER IT'S
COMING BACK.
ALL THE CHEMICALS THAT WERE DOWN
THERE BECAUSE EPA DID NOT DO A
GOOD JOB OF CLEANUP NOW THEY'RE
COMING BACK AND THE RE
CONTAMINATED OUR COMMUNITY.
SO IF YOU DO A CLEAN UP ONLY IN
THE IMMEDIATE AREA AND YOU DON'T
CLEAN UP WHAT'S NEXT DOOR LIKE
TO RECEIVE THE OTHER PROPERTIES.
THAT ARE THERE YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO GET RID OF THE LET.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SEE YOU KNOW THAT MAYBE THE
STATE IN TEN OR TWELVE YEARS
WITH A CLEAR VICTORY SAID OKAY.
WE'VE DONE THE JOB WE REMOVE THE
LET BUT THE LEAD IS STILL THERE
THE KIDS ARE STILL THERE THE
PEOPLE ARE STILL THERE.
AND THE PROBLEM PERSISTS.
IN MY COMMUNITY WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT THE PROPERTIES.
THAT ARE NOT GOING TO BE CLEANED
UP ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM
THE LA TIMES PUBLISHED A COUPLE
OF MONTHS AGO. SIXTEEN HUNDRED
PROPERTIES IN THE TWO U. MAY
WHAT WILL NOT BE CLEANED UP.
IN ADDITION TO THE PROPERTIES IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
IN COMMERCE IN BOYLE HEIGHTS.
IS ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
PROPERTIES THAT WILL NOT EVEN BE
I LIVE I FOUND A HIGH AMOUNT OF
LET.
AND ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT WORKS
FOR THE AGENCY ASKED ME DID YOU
ACTUALLY PUT OUT A LEAD BETTER
YOU BACKYARD.
YOU LEAVE A BARRIER YOU ARE A
BETTER IN YOUR BACKYARD.
HOW CAN YOU EVEN THINK OF THAT
YOU KNOW WHY DOES IT HAVE A HIGH
AMOUNT OF LEAD?
IN IN THE BACKYARD AND NOT IN
THE FRONT YARD.
SO THIS IS THE TYPE OF SITUATION
THAT WE SEE IT EVERY TIME THAT
WE HAVE DEALT WITH THIS AGENCY
AND WE HAVE REALISTIC COME TO
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE BEES
PARTICIPATED IN.
PANELS AND SESSIONS AT
TESTIFYING AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON BUT WE'RE NO CLOSER TO CLEAN
UP THE SITUATION WE'RE NO CLOSER
TO MAKING.
OUR COMMUNITY HOLD AGAIN.
WE JUST CANNOT COME AND SAY OKAY
THE STATE HAS DONE THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE WE CLEANED IT UP
RECOVERED THE MONEY FROM EXCITE
I REALLY DON'T THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD REALLY
LOOK AT AND THE BASICALLY SAYING
THAT.
THE COMMUNITY IS NOT CLEANED UP
THIS IS BASICALLY WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
I HAVE GOING ON TOURS NOT
ANYBODY BY ANYBODY.
BUT WE HAVE GONE ON THURSDAY
NIGHTS HE CITES.
IN MAY WHAT THAT WERE NOT BEING
CLEANED UP ACCORDING TO ALL THE
THE REGULATIONS THAT UP DTS HE
GETS AS THAT WHICH I SAW KIDS
RUNNING ON THE PHONE.
OF THE YARD WHETHER CLEAN UP THE
HOUSE OR CLEAN THE MULTI FAMILY
PROPERTY.
I SAW ANOTHER FLIGHT WITH THE
WORKERS WERE NOW THE LEAD
CONTAMINATION THEY'RE BEING TOLD
TO DECONTAMINATE ONLY IF
SOMEBODY FEELS THAT THEY SHOULD
DO SO.
THERE'S NOT REALLY A WAY TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING THERE --
WE SAW OTHER PROPERTIES POSED TO
YOU PACIFIC.
WHERE THE DUST WAS FLYING TO THE
OTHER NEIGHBORS HOUSES?
BUT NOBODY BOTHERS TO TELL
PEOPLE AND SAY YOU SHOULD NOT
REALLY BE IN THERE OR THE PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE HOUSE.
YOU KNOW THEY SHOULD BE
EVACUATED.
NOT GIVEN OUT OF A POSSIBILITY
OF GOING TO A HOTEL MAYBE WANTED
YOU TO TELL YOUR HUSBAND UP AS A
SUPERVISOR SAID.
BEING GIVEN A COUPON BUT YOU
NEED A REAL COMPLETE CLEANUP AND
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS AGENCY.
HAS THE ABILITY OR THE WILL TO
DO IT.
WE'RE TRYING TO MINIMIZE THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT
SMALLER AND SMALLER AND SMALLER.
YOU CAN'T GO EVEN THOUGH DEVELOP
A PLAN TO CLEAN UP TEN THOUSAND
HOMES.
WHAT CAN WE DO FOR THE AMOUNT OF
ONE THAT REALLY ARE CONTAMINATED
AND THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE CONTAMINATED CAN JUST BE
CLEAN UP THE DIRT YOU HAVE TO
CLEAN UP THE PEOPLE?
AND YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT AND THE WAY
I SEE THIS PLAN.
IT'S NOT REALLY GOING TO WORK
FOR A COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR AND
FINALLY.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM JANE
WILLIAMS WALK --
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BLOOM OTHER
MEMBERS OF THAT BUT YOU SAID.
THREE I'M JANE WILLIAMS I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AGAINST TOXICS.
AND WALL FATHER THIS IS HIS
CHURCH AND WE'VE BEEN LIVES IN A
WAY.
THE ORGANIZATION AND THE
DIRECTOR OF WAS ACTUALLY FOUNDED
RIGHT HERE.
IN THIS ROOM.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WE DID
COMMENTS WITH YOU SIR UCLA
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW CLINIC.
MEMBERS OF THE MOTHERS OF EAST
LA.
AND SOME OTHER --
NONPROFIT GROUPS THAT HAVE
WORKED IN A VERY REAL JUSTICE
ISSUES IN LA.
AND AT THAT TIME WE ASKED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TO NOT REINSTATE --
EXISTING PERMITS TO TO GRANT
EITHER FINAL PERMITS SO THAT WE
COULD CHALLENGE THOSE IN COURT
OR TO PULL THE PERMITS FOR THIS
FACILITY.
SO SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
ACTUALLY BEFORE THAT TIME WE
HAVE WORKED ON THIS FACILITY.
IT WAS FIRST STARTED IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO IN NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO THERE WAS NO CLEAR
OUT THERE WERE NO AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL LAWS THERE WERE NO
HAZARDOUS WASTE LAWS.
THAT INDUSTRIAL ACTIVITIES THAT --
WERE ALLOWED WERE VERY VERY
DIRTY AND I'M SORRY THAT YOU
CANNOT SEE THE PRESENTATION I
HAVE OVER HERE.
BECAUSE I HAVE FOUR SITES THE
FIRST ONE IS --
NEAR THE CDC REPORT ON LAD
STRESSES ONE THING.
PRIMARY PREVENTION.
REVENGE EXPOSURE BECAUSE ONCE
EXPOSURE TO THIS CHEMICALOCCURS
THE EFFECTS ARE IRREVERSIBLE.
THIS IS A MAP OF THE X. I.
FACILITY IN FRISCO TEXAS.
AND I'M SORRY YOU GUYS CAN'T SEE
IT MAYBE YOU CAN.
THE PURPLE IS FIVE MILES.
OKAY THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
POUNDS OF LEAD THE ONLY OPERATED
FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR NOT FROM
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR TO TWENTY
TEN IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THEY LOG
THREE THOUSAND POUNDS OF WAS.
IT'S A TWENTY FIVE SQUARE MILE
AREA.
IT'S BEEN CONTAMINATED.
THIS IS A MAP OF THE OTHER GO
SMELTERS THE CENTER OF THE
CIRCLE IS EXCITE.
THOSE OTHER FIVE WHITE MARKS
THAT YOU SEE OUR OTHER LEAD
SMELTERSTHEY DIDN'T PERMITTED
BY THE CITY OF LA. TO BE.
IN EAST LA.
AND WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IS WE
GET PAST THE ONE POINT SEVEN
MILES AND WE KEEP GOING.
WE'RE GONNA RUN INTO DEPOSITION
FROM THESE OTHER SMELTERS.
DOCTOR LIVES HERE HE CAN ATTEST
TO WHAT THESE FALLOUT PATTERNS
LOOK LIKE.
OUR OTHER EXPERT DR WELLS HAS
BEEN A LOT OF TIME LOOKING AT
THIS.
THIS IS NOT ROCKET SCIENCE.
THIS IS PROBABLY GOING TO END UP
BEING THE LARGEST LEAD
CONTAMINATED SITE CLEANUP IN THE
HEMISPHERE AND IT'S GONNA COST
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS.
AND YET WE KEEP ASK WE KEEP
ACTING LIKE.
WE'RE JUST GONNA DO A HOUSE BY
HOUSE.
AS MANY ROLES IN.
SO THAT'S WHY SOME OF THE BURGER
SEE AND I WORKED ON THE BATTERY
FEMALE.
WE KNEW WE NEEDED A LONG TERM
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING.
WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO BE
IT'S GOING TO BE ONE OF THE
LARGEST CLEAN UP SITES IN
HISTORY THE COUNTRY.
WE'VE GOT TO STOP ACTING LIKE WE
CAN JUST GET IN AND GET OUT --
HERE'S THE CONCLUSIONS HERE'S
WHAT WE NEED.
FIRST OF ALL WE'VE GOT TO STOP
TALKING ABOUT THE CLEANUP BREAK
WE'VE GOT TO STOP START TALKING
ABOUT THE POISONING RATE.
BECAUSE WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT WE
POISON A CHILD A DAY.
JUST IN THE ONE POINT SEVEN
MILES.
IF WE LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
FRISCO TEXAS THAT NUMBER WOULD.
RISE DRAMATICALLY OKAY.
THERE IS NO MORAL CLARITY HERE
ON WHAT WE ARE ACTUALLY FACING.
WE'RE FACING A LARGE SCALE
POISONING EPIDEMIC.
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR AND YOU STILL
LAY IN PARTS OF SOUTH CENTRAL.
AND IF I WAS GOING TO COME TO
YOUR HOUSE.
AND TAKE YOUR CHILD OR YOUR
CHILD OR YOUR CHILD OR YOUR
CHILD AND POISON THEM IT WOULD
BE AGAINST THE LAW.
I'D BE ARRESTED I'D BE THROWN IN
JAIL IT WOULD BE A MORAL STAIN.
YET WE ARE ALLOWING THIS TO
CONTINUE.
AND WE'RE ALLOWING THE AGENCY
THERE PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM TO TRY AND CLEAN IT UP.
PART OF THE PROBLEM HERE IS A
SOCIOLOGICAL PROBLEM.
WE HAVE AN AGENCY WHICH I
PERSONALLY HAVE WORK WITH THIS
AGENCY SINCE ITS CREATION IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO SINCE IT
BECAME DGSE.
A SEPARATE AGENCY KELLY EPA.
I HAVE NEVER EXPERIENCED THE
LEVEL OF DYSFUNCTION THROUGH.
COUNTLESS OTHER AND BILL SUE WHO
WAS THE FIRST DIRECTOR OKAY.
THROUGH COUNTLESS OTHER
DIRECTORS REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS AND DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATIONS DOES IT WORK
WITH DGSE REALIZE THEY ARE AT
THE HEIGHT OF THEIR DYSFUNCTION.
OKAY IT'S IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO GET MORE
DYSFUNCTIONAL.
WE'RE SO LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING SOMEBODY NEW HEAD THE
AGENCY AND FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
BUT IN THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE US.
WE'RE POISONING A CHILD TODAY.
WE'RE POISONING A CHILD TODAY WE
HAVE BABIES ARE BEING BORN PRE
THEY ARE NOT ENDOWED WITH LIFE
LIBERTY OR THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS THERE BUT WHEN THEY'RE
BORN LEAD POISONED [inaudible]
SO.
WE NEED TO THINGS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE NEED A STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING.
WE NEED THE FULL BATTERY FEE
REINSTATED.
WE ORIGINALLY CREATED IT TO BE
FIVE DOLLARS AND I SEE THAT MATT
RODRIGUEZ IS HERE TONIGHT.
I GOT TO SAY SOMETHING MISTER
RODRIGUEZ.
WHEN I PHONE YOU UP I HOPE YOU
RETURN MY PHONE CALLS BECAUSE I
CALLED YOU FOR A YEAR?
ASKING YOU TO WORK WITH US ON
THE BATTERY FEE AND WE GET TO
THE VERY END OF THE SESSION.
THE WEEK BEFORE AND IT TAKES THE
SPEAKER AND THE PRO TEM GOING
INTO THE GOVERNOR'S.
HOUSE TO SAY I WANT THE BATTERY
FEE.
AND WHAT DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
DO THEY CUT IT IN HALF.
AND THEN THEY SAY THEY HAVE THE
GALL TO COME HERE THIS COMMUNITY
AND TELL US.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO THESE
THINGS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY.
I MEAN I'M SORRY BUT I MEAN IT
IS.
IT IS IT IS ORWELLIAN.
IT'S ORWELLIAN OKAY AND THIS IS
WHAT I WOULD SAY TO THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND I KNOW THAT.
THAT ROAD REDUCES HERE AND GRANT
IS HERE YOU'VE USE THIS
COMMUNITY AS A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED.
TO AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
AND I'M SORRY IF I PISS PEOPLE
OFF BECAUSE NO ONE ELSE HAS THE
COURAGE TO SAY IT.
EAST LA IS A POLITICAL FOOTBALL.
IT'S ALL ABOUT WHO'S MATTED WHO
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE KID THAT'S
BEING BORN.
BEING BORN IN THIS COMMUNITY
THAT WILL NEVER HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THEY ARE
LEAD POISONED THEY'RE NEVER
GONNA HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
AS A KID IS BORN ANY PLACE ELSE
IN LA COUNTY.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS AS THIS
COMMUNITY OKAY.
WE'VE GOT TO STAND UP ALL OF US
WE'VE YELLED WE'VE SCREEN WE'VE
BEEN TO HEARINGS WE FUSSED WE'VE
BEEN ON BUSES WE HAVE GOT TO DO
MORE.
AND WE'VE GOT A YELLOW LAB ORDER.
BECAUSE HOPE HAS TWO PARENTS.
THOSE PARENTS HER COURAGE AND
ACTION.
AND WE'RE GONNA GET A NEW
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU KNOW THE SPEAKER IS STILL
GOING TO BE HERE THESE FOLKS ARE
STILL GOING TO BE REPRESENTING
US AND WE HAVE GOT TO RAISE HOLY
HELL BECAUSE IF NOT.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SENTENCE [inaudible]
THESE CHILDREN.
FUTURE GENERATIONS DECADES FROM
NOW TO BE BORN WITHOUT LIFE
LIBERTY OR THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
THANK YOU. FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
IF IT'S ALRIGHT I THINK WE'LL
MOVE INTO PUBLIC COMMENT NOW.
AND JOHN WILL JUST TAKE A SECOND
TO GET SET UP HERE IF YOU FILLED
OUT A CARD.
THAT'S GOING TO BE BROUGHT TO ME
I THINK --
WAS ALRIGHT WITH EVERYBODY ALL
READ THROUGH THOSE CARDS FIRST --
LAST THOSE FOLKS TO SPEAK WE
WILL HAVE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYBODY WHO HASN'T YET FILLED
OUT A CARD TO FILL ONE NOW.
OR JUST RAISE YOUR HAND YOU BE
ABLE TO COME UP AND SPEAK OR WE
CAN BRING THE MICROPHONE TO YOU
IF IT'S DIFFICULT FOR YOU. TO
GET GET TO THE MICROPHONE WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM AS MANY PEOPLE
AS POSSIBLE TONIGHT AND IF
YOU'RE HERE WITH A GROUP OF
PEOPLE --
YOU MIGHT WANT TO ADD RATHER
THAN THEM COME FORWARD WITH YOU
OB.
I WHICH MIGHT GET A LITTLE BIT
LOGISTICALLY DIFFICULT IF YOU
WANT TO ASK THEM TO STAND SO
THAT THEY CAN BE ACKNOWLEDGED WE
CAN DO THAT AS WELL.
BUT IF WE COULD.
LET'S SET BEGIN WITH ERNIE PEN
TORIA FOLLOWED BY BRUCE CAMPBELL
AND JOE GONZALEZ.
AND AS I READ YOUR NAMES IF YOU
CAN STEP FORWARD SO THAT YOU'RE
READY TO STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL BE ABLE --
TO PROCEED --
TO A LITTLE BIT MORE EFFICIENTLY
WELCOME SIR.
GOOD EVENING MA'AM CHAIRMAN AND
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME'S A MESSED UP ON TIME HERE
ON BEHALF OF SECULAR SCHOOL AND
BUSINESS MANAGER LABOR'S LOCAL.
THREE HUNDRED AND I WANT TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT I THINK
IS.
THERE'S A GENTLEMAN HERE THAT
MADE MADE IT VERY CLEAR ONE OF
THE OTHER HEARINGS THAT I HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT I SAY.
FIRST OFF AS AN ORGANIZATION WE
WANT TO SAY WE STAND WITH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BECAUSE WE
HAVE SEVERAL HUNDRED MEMBERS
THAT LIVE.
IN THESE COMMUNITIES ARE OVER A
HUNDRED IN THE CITY OF MAY WITH
A LONG.
SO WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR BUT TO
TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHO
WE ARE THE LABORERS.
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE ALWAYS
ASK US SO YOU GUYS ARE IN
CONSTRUCTION WOULD YOU GUYS DO
YOU LIKE CHRISTIANS AND WE'RE
LABORS.
SOME LABORS TO CONCRETE BREAKING
DEMOLITION CONCRETE.
WE DO LET LANDSCAPE MAINTENANCE
CONSTRUCTION WHERE THE MINERS IN
THE TUNNELS.
WE DO EVERYTHING AS WE SAY THE
STUFF NOBODY ELSE WANTS TO DO
WERE MAJORITY LATINO IMMIGRANT
POPULATION WHICH IS WHY WE LIVE
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND WE NEVER GET THE CREDIT WE
DESERVE.
ON TOP OF THAT WE DO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK WHICH IS WHY
WHEN THIS WHEN THIS PROJECT CAME
FORWARD WE WANTED TO BE A
PARTNER ON THIS WE WENT OUT TO
OUR STATE LEGISLATORS AND SAID
WE WANT TO PUT PEOPLE TO WORK.
WE ARE THE MEMBERS THAT LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THEY'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE FOR A
LONG TIME.
THEY SHOULD BE HELPING TO CLEAN
IT UP AND WE YOU PEOPLE FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND GIVING THEM
CAREERS REAL CAREERS.
GOOD PAYING JOBS WE HAVE OVER A
THOUSAND MEMBERS THAT DO
ENVIRONMENTAL ALONG.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID AS
EVERYTHING HAS HAS KIND OF GONE
THROUGH.
WE WON'T TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE LED TO THE DELAYS AND
EVERYTHING WERE HERE NOW.
AND WE'RE AT WE'RE AT WAR AT AND
I HAVE TO COMMEND.
EACH ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERE THAT
FOUGHT HARD TO GET SOME SORT OF
FUNDING TO GOING TO THIS
COMMUNITY.
AND I LOVE THE FACT THAT
SUPERVISORS POLICE WORK HARD TO
GET MONEY FROM THE COUNTY
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD
BE EVERYBODY SHOULD START
WORKING TOGETHER. TO START
FIXING THESE PROBLEMS WE CAN'T
STOP AT THE YARDS CAN'T STOP AT
THE PARK WAYS WE GOTTA START
GETTING INTO THE HOUSES.
TO AND WITH THAT.
WE MADE A PROMISE THAT WE WERE
GOING TO WORK THESE WITH THESE
COMMUNITY MEMBER TO BRING THEM
IN AND GET THE CAREERS AND I
KNOW SEVERAL OF YOU GOT TO MEET
ONE OF THEM.
TODAY RAP A LOT.
AND YOU CAN TELL YOU BECAUSE ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE TRAINED
TO BE ON THIS JOB OVER A YEAR
AGO.
WE'RE WAITING FOR THIS JOB TO
BEGIN WE WENT TO THEM.
IN NOVEMBER.
AND BEFORE WE SAID WE WANT TO
PUT YOU GUESS WORK NOW WE NEED
WORKERS IN THE FIELD NOW.
AND WE DESPITE.
THE FIGHT WE GOT WE WHEN WE
PULLED HIM IN AND THEY STARTED
WORKING IN THE INDUSTRY.
THEY STARTED SEEING WHAT THIS
INDUSTRY REALLY IS LIKE.
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE IT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS FOR US IS
THAT.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXPOSED TO THESE TYPES OF
CHEMICALS FOR THAT FOR AN ENTIRE
[inaudible]
BASICALLY CAREER.
AND IT IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE TAKEN IN CONSIDERATION.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
PROPERLY PROTECTED WE TRAIN THEM
WE TRAIN THEM WELL.
BUT THE SAME TIME YOU HAVE A LOT
OF UNSCRUPULOUS CONTRACTORS IT'S
AN IT'S AN INDUSTRY THAT'S
RAMPANT WITH UNSCRUPULOUS
CONTRACTORS WHICH IS WHY WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WERE THESE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE.
AND SO WE ASK YOU.
NOT ONLY TO LISTEN TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE RESIDENCES FIND
POCKETS OF FINDING CONTINUE. TO
HELP THE CLEAN UP.
CONTINUE THE CLEANUP GOING BUT
ALSO FORGET THESE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
WE PROMISED THEM.
JOBS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CONTRACTORS DON'T FORGET THAT.
AND THE DETAILS HE DOESN'T
FORGET THAT.
SO I ASK YOU TO PLEASE ENCOURAGE
THEM TO REMEMBER WHAT WE
PROMISED THESE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
AND THAT WAS MY ALARM GOING OFF
I FORGOT TO MENTION THAT I'D
LIKE -- TO
TRYING TO HOLD EVERYBODY TO
APPROXIMATELY. TWO MINUTES SO
THAT WE CAN --
I HEAR FROM AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE. TO OUR NEXT UP WE HAVE --
MISTER BRUCE CAMPBELL.
HI THERE ARE STATE LEGISLATORS
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC I'M
BRUCE CAMPBELL FIRST I HAVE
THREE QUESTIONS I WISH.
SOME EXPERTS WERE GOING TO
ANSWER THEM.
WHAT HEAVY METALS BESIDES LEAD
AND ARSENIC WERE SPEWED BY THE
EXCITED FACILITY?
WHAT ABOUT CLEAN UP AT SCHOOL
SITES?
AND WHERE IS THE SOIL WITH THE
ELEVATED HEAVY METALS TAKEN TOO
AND DUMP THAT.
I HAPPEN TO KNOW THAT AT LEAST
THE INITIAL PHASE OF THE CLEANUP
OF PCB CAULKING AT MALIBU HIGH
SCHOOL AND SHE WOULD JOIN IN
SCHOOLS.
THE PCB IS UP TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF TIMES LEGAL LIMITS
AND RELATED MATERIAL WERE HALTED
THE CHIQUITA LANDFILL IN SANTA
CLARITA CONVENTIONAL LANDFILL
RATHER THAN A CLASS.
RATHER THAN A CLASS ONE TOXIC
DUMP.
ALSO TOXIC HEAVY METALS ARE
PURPOSELY ADDED 270% OVER 70% OF
U. S. A PUBLIC WATER SUPPLY
INCLUDING IN LA D. W. P. WATER
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND
AN M. W. D. WATER SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN RESEARCH YOU
TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS HI.
LOUIS SILICIC ACID ON THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE INTERESTED MAKE US
AND LEAD MERCURY DIESEL URANIUM
AND OTHER TOXIC PURPOSELY ADDED
EDGE OF DRAWINGS TO DRESS LIKE A
BIG WATER SUPPLY.
RICHARD BLUM VOTED TO POISON
SANMON COM O'CONNOR ABOUT THEM
IS FORTY THREE TO POISON SANTA
MONICA.
THANK YOU IT BECAUSE THIS IS.
OUT COMMUNITIES YOU DO NEED TO
FOCUS ON THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE
HERE FOR TODAY.
LET'S NOT HEAVY METALS IN
GENERAL.
THANK YOU NEXTEL WE HAVE JOE
GONZALEZ FOLLOWED BY.
EMMA HALL OF A GRANNY --
IN QUOTES AFTER HER NAME CINDY
DORIS AND TERRY CANNOT.
OKAY UGH GOOD EVENING THANK YOU
FOR SHOWING UP ALL MY NAME IS
JOE AND ALL OF THEM A LONG TIME
RESIDENT HERE WAS BORN RAISED
LIVE AND WORK IN EAST LA.
LONG TERM EXPOSURE IS INDEED A
PROBLEM.
I NOT ONLY OF LIVE HERE WORK
HERE ON THE MAIL MAN I WORK
OUTSIDE OF BREEDING JUST THESE
CONTAMINANTS IN FOR SO LONG.
IN DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT MY
CANCER IS A SKIN CANCER OR
MELANOMA I'M A DARKY AND I GOT A
MELANOMA THAT'S A RARE ONE RIGHT
OFF THE TOP IT'S INSIDE MY NOSE
IT'S A MELANOMA.
IT'S AN OUTSIDE CANCER BUT MINE
IS INSIDE THERE IS A LONG TERM
RISK CONTAMINATION PROBLEMS HERE
THIS IS JUST.
SOME OF THE STUFF FROM THIS HERE
AND A LITTLE BIT FROM LAST YEAR
EACH ONE OF THESE REPRESENTS A
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS AT LEAST.
AND THE CO PAY PLUS GAS PLUS A
DAY'S WORK OF MIST PLUS YOU KNOW
PARKING FOURTEEN DOLLARS AND
STUFF LIKE THIS IS NOT GOING TO
HAVE TO BE TOUCHED ON BECAUSE MY
HOUSE IS NOT EVEN ON THE LIST OF
THE HOMES ARE GOING TO BE
CLEANED BUT YET I WAS
CONTAMINATED IN MY OWN HOME.
OKAY SO A LOT MORE CONTAMINATION
IS GOING TO BE HAPPENING OUT
THERE.
THIS IS THE RISK OF LONG TERM
COMING OUT OF TOWN A LOT MORE
PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP
GETTING SIX US SICK I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY COME UP WITH
THIS STUFF BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY.
I HAVE NEVER STOP PAYING TAXES I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY IN HERE HAS
EVER STOP PAYING TAXES.
YOU KNOW I MEAN MAYBE I SHOULD
HAVE TO PAY TAXES FOR BEING
CONTAMINATED BY MY OWN STATE.
MY OWN STATE GOVERNMENT.
WHY ARE THEY IN CLEANING THIS
STUFF UP AND FORGIVE ME IF I
SOUND ANGRY IS NOT A GREAT
FRUSTRATION AS FRUSTRATING AS
I'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE THEY WERE
EVEN CLOSED?
AND WE'RE HERE AND AND ALTHOUGH
I'M GOING AND IT'S A PART OF
IT'S BECAUSE I'M GLAD TO SEE YOU
FOR FEAR THE OTHER PART IS
BECAUSE I'VE.
WITH INJECTED RADIATION TODAY
BECAUSE I WENT TO ANOTHER
PROCEDURE TODAY.
OKAY UP WERE WAY WAY WORSE THE
FLINT MICHIGAN FLINT MICHIGAN ON
START OF BODY YEARS AGO COME ON
WE'VE BEEN GOING ON FOR NINE
DECADES OR MORE.
OF THIS IS THE SINGLE MOST
CONTENT DID THEY TALK ABOUT HOW
MANY HOMES THEY CLAIM THEY HAVE
NOT CLEANED A SINGLE HOME IF
THEY DO NOT PLAN THE MOST
CONTAMINATED AREAS OF THE HOME.
THAT'S THE ATTIC AND THE PARKWAY
THE ATTIC EVERYTIME YOU SLAM A
DOOR THAT STUFF IS COMING DOWN
OFF THE ROOF RIGHT ON YOUR
DINNER.
RIGHT ON YOUR DINNER TABLE RIGHT
ON YOUR SOFA RIGHT ON YOUR
CARPET.
I KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
CLOCK AND I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT
HIM EITHER UP.
YOU CAN WE DO WANT TO HEAR BUT
YOU BUT WE DO HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
WRAP UP PLEASE OKAY OKAY I WANT
TO SAY TO THAT.
YOU KNOW WE HEARD A THIS IS A
LEARNING CURVE THERE'S NOT A
LEARNING CURVE THEIR LIVES AT
STAKE HERE --
LAST TIME THEY SAID WE'RE
LEARNING AS WE GO ALONG THAT'S
NOT SUFFICIENT.
WE DON'T NEED THE DTS IN CHARGE
OF THIS THEY ARE SQUANDERING THE
MONEY.
HALL THEY CAN BE IN CHARGE OF
THE MONEY WITHIN THE BATTERY TAX
AND YOU'LL FIND THESE OTHER
PLACES TO FIND OUT IN THE LAW IT
SAYS THAT THE MONEY SHALL BE
SPENT ON LEAD OF PLACES THAT ARE.
KNOWN TO HAVE BEEN BECAUSE IT
LED SO MANY OTHER QUALIFIED
CONTRACTORS WHY DO WE HAVE ONLY.
ONE YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS WHY
IT'S TAKING SO LONG THERE'S SO
MANY OTHER QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS
OUT THERE.
THAT THE THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
MANY MANY MORE ON DUTY TROUBLED
BY THE FACT THAT THE X. I.
CONSIDERS THIS AN EXPEDITIOUS
CLEANUP.
OF US FAR AS THE MOVING OUT
STUFF LIKE THAT I HAD MY TEN
YEAR OLD NEPHEW WHEN THE THEY
WERE PUT IN THE DOGS IN DOGGY
DAYCARE CENTER IN THE PORTER
RANCH.
HE LOOKED AT ME AND SAID THAT'S
NOT FAIR HOW COULD THEY PUT DOGS
IN DOGGY DAYCARE BUT I HAVE TO
LIVE IN THIS CONTAMINATION
OUTLOOK MAY HEAR AN ANSWER FROM
YOU ON THAT.
ONE YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING ELSE IT.
THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE THE
CHOICE WITH THE CLEAN THEIR
GUARDS ARE NOT THEY DO NOT HAVE
A RIGHT TO EXPOSE ME TO
CONTAMINATION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT SOMEBODY ON THEIR SIDE.
IN THE LAST LAST ONE AND I WANT
TO GO BACK AND GET A GOOD LOOK
AT THAT POINT IT IS THE LAST ONE
AND I WILL COME BACK AND GIVE A
LIST OF TWELVE QUESTIONS AFTER
BUT DONE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I WANNA GIVE MY
FELLOW VICTIMS A CHANCE TO GET
THEIR SPIEL OUT.
TO EXCITE SUED THE CITY OF
FRISCO TEXAS FOR TAKING TOO LONG
THEY'RE CLEAN UP.
I JUST WANTED YOUR TEAM TO KIND
OF PUT THAT.
IN THERE SOMEWHERE.
I'LL GIVE THE OTHER QUESTION THE
NEXT ROOM THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE A AND THE
WHOLE PLACE.
THEN KNOWN AS GRANNY THINK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK I CAME
BEFORE YOU NOT ONLY TO THIS
PANEL BUT FOR ALL THOSE THAT WE
HAVE IN THIS.
AFFECTED AREA.
I'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
ABOUT.
THE YOUTH.
IMPRESSIONS WOMEN'S I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE BOOK TOUR AGE
WHICH I AM.
WE ARE AFFECTED WE HAVE OUR
CHALLENGES AS BEING WE HAVE AN
ENTRY.
A CHALLENGE TO DEAL WITH.
DON'T FORGET US.
I HAVE.
A SUMMER.
OF GUYS SEE IT THANK YOU SWEET
HOT.
EVERYBODY'S BUT DON'T FORGET
ABOUT US.
THAT'S THE REASON THE THE DEATH
RATE THE RATE WENT UP SO HIGH IN
SAN JUAN PUERTO RICO BECAUSE A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
NEEDED SURGERY AT MY AGE AND
OLDER AND THEY WERE ON OPTICIAN
AND THEY COULDN'T GET IT BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ELECTRICITY
PLEASE DON'T FORGET ABOUT US
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHECKS IN
THE DOORS FOLLOWED BY TERRY CANO
AND YVONNE MARTINEZ ONCE.
HI IT ASCENDED ON MEANS THAT THE
CONNECTION I'M MULTIPLE TIMES.
I'M A MEMBER AND ORGANIZER WITH
EASE OUR COMMUNITIES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
I GREW UP IN.
END OF MAY WOULD.
IN MY PARENTS STILL LIVE IN THE
APARTMENT WHERE I GREW UP AND I
WANTED TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
TWO THINGS ONE BEING THE THE ONE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED PARCELS
THAT STILL HAVEN'T BEEN TESTED
OR THEY'D THERE'S NO ACCESS TO
THOSE --
WHERE MY PARENTS LIVE IT'S
THAT'S IT'S ONE OF THOSE ONE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND SO --
I ASSUME THE SITUATION MIGHT BE
SIMILAR FOR THOSE OTHER PARCELS
WHERE MY I REACHED OUT TO GET
THE SOIL TESTED.
THEY'VE TRIED TWICE BUT THERE'S
A COMP IS ON THE PROPERTY.
AND MY PARENTS ARE VERY FEARFUL
AND TRYING TO ATTEMPT TO TALK TO
THE LANDLORD BECAUSE OF
HISTORIES OF EVICTIONS AND RENT
INCREASES THAT MY PARENTS JUST
KIND OF FORT.
AND SO I HEAR IT.
I HEARD THE THE CALL FROM THE
PUBLIC WORKS AROUND NOT.
TO THREATENING LANDLORDS AROUND
CODE OF CONDUCT BUT I WOULD ALSO
WANT TO HEAR AND SEE SOLUTIONS
IN TERMS OF PROTECTION FOR
RENTERS --
AND ALSO IN DOCUMENT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A IN
A AREA WHERE A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
ALSO UNDOCUMENTED AND THAT'S AN
ADDED FEAR.
ALL WHEN IT COMES TO THIS ISSUE --
AND WE WISH THAT SHOULDN'T BE A
BARRIER TO HAVING A CLEAN HOME.
AND SO THAT'S ONE ISSUE THE
OTHER ISSUE IS AROUND CURRENT
USE THAT WE HEARD AROUND FUNDING
BEING TAKEN FROM THE BATTERY
BILL. TO PAY BACK THE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX MILLION
[inaudible]
AT WHEN THE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION WERE
ALLOCATED IT HAD BEEN PROMISED.
THAT THOSE FUNDS WERE GOING TO
BE RICH TAKEN FROM THE FOLKS
THAT COMMITTED THIS ATROCIOUS
CONTAMINATION.
RIGHT BUT IT WAS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS WOULD BE
PAYING THAT BACK.
AND SO WHEN THE MONEY IS BEING
TAKEN FROM FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
COLLECTED FROM THE BATTERY BUILT.
IT'S PUTTING THE BLAME ON THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAD BEEN IMPACTED.
AND IT ALSO FEELS LIKE LIKE MY
LOAN COLLECTOR OVER A BILL
COLLECTOR WHEN THE FOR THE JOB
ISN'T EVEN FINISHED HOW IS IT
THAT FUNDS ARE ALREADY BEING
COLLECTED.
WHEN THAT WE STILL HAVE HOMES
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN TESTED WE
STILL HAVE HOMES THAT ARE
CONTAMINATED?
AND NOT ALL OF THESE HOMES HAVE
BEEN CLEANED UP I HOPE THAT.
AS AS REPRESENTATIVES YOU YOU
WOULD JOIN A COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IN THIS FIGHT --
AND AND I I WAS LIKE WHY DID YOU
ALLOWIT TO HAPPEN HOW YOU
RECTIFY THAT.
MAKE SURE THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN AND GET THAT MONEY BACK --
BECAUSE I WAS MANY THAT THE
COMMUNITY ONE AND JUST TO END
HERE --
THOSE FUNDS THAT WERE TAKEN FROM
THAT I THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
DISCUSSING THAT THEY'RE BEING
USED.
BY AN ADDED INTO JERRY BROWN'S A
SURPLUS.
WHAT HE CALLS A SURPLUS FOR A
RAINY DAY?
WHEN IT'S BEEN RAINING IT'S BEEN
POURING LEAD?
ON US FOR DECADES AND WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THE SUNSHINE.
SO I WOULD REALLY HOPE THAT YOU
JOIN COMMUNITY IN THIS FIGHT.
AND GET THOSE FUNDS BACK AND GET
MORE FUNDS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
TERRY KENNAN.
OKAY HIGH --
TERRY KANO.
OF FIRST I WANT.
TO FORGIVE ME IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO BREATHE BECAUSE I AM A SEVERE
ASTHMATIC.
TAKE YOUR TIME THINKING
[inaudible]
WHEN?
AFTER FIGHTING THIS FOR TEN
YEARS.
THERE ARE SO MANY POINTS.
THAT.
WE WANT TO TOUCH ON SO I'LL GO
WITH SHE'S A COUPLE [inaudible]
TO ONE IS. FOR YEARS I ASKED DTS
SEE.
WHAT?
ARE YOU GOING TO DO FOR THE
HEALTH AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALL THIS
DOCUMENTATION ALL THIS THIS
LITERATURE GOING OUT OF HOW LATE
CAN CAUSE THIS THIS AND THIS.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU I'VE
LIVED IN THIS COMMUNITY FOR
FORTY SEVEN YEARS.
I AM THE EFFECTS OF LONG TERM.
EXPOSURE TO LEAD AND NOT JUST
LEAD BUT ARSENIC BENZENE
EXCELLENT CHROMIUM ALL THE OTHER
CHEMICALS THAT DTS SEE IT DOES
NOT WANT TO FOCUS ON THAT HAS
CAUSED MY WHOLE FAMILY TO BE
SICK.
I HAVE BEEN THAT CHILD BECAUSE I
WAS BORN INTO THIS.
IN THIS COMMUNITY.
WHO THAT PREMATURE CHILD AND I
WAS BORN PREMATURELY I WAS THAT
FIVE YEAR OLD?
DIGGING IN THE DIRT.
I WAS THAT PREGNANT WOMAN WHO
HAD TO PREMATURE BIRTHS BOTH AT
SEVEN MONTHS.
BOTH OF MY CHILDREN HAD TO BE IN
AND I SEE YOU [inaudible]
AND I WAS THAT SENSITIVE.
RECEPTOR THIS SENSITIVE PERSON
IN HERE.
MY BODY IS BROKEN AND DAMAGED
BEYOND REPAIR.
MY BROTHER WHO SPOKE EARLIER HIS
HAD HAS CANCER HE IS BEYOND
REPAIR.
MY PARENTS WHO PASSED AWAY
BECAUSE OF THE CONTAMINATION ARE
BEYOND REPAIR.
I DON'T SEE HOW DTS THESE
ALLOWED. TO CONTINUE TO BE THE
LEAD AGENCY.
ON ON THIS CLEAN UP WHEN YEARS
AGO I HAVE ASKED AND I AND I DID
SOME RESEARCH IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
FASTER. FOR US TO GET CLEANED UP
ON A LARGE SCALE THE CORRECT WAY
IF WE WOULD HAVE DECLARED THIS A
FEDERAL EMERGENCY.
SO THEY DDS HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
EXCUSE OF HIDING BEHIND RED TAPE
AND AND AND LAWS AND WHAT THEY
CAN AND CAN'T DO.
AND THE NEXT THING IS.
DTS THREE AFTER ASKING THEM WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO DO FOR THE
HEALTH AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS.
AND GETTING NO RESPONSE WHEN I
FINALLY GOT ONE THEY SAID ALL
THAT'S NOT OUR PROBLEM.
THAT'S THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
IS PROBLEM.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH DID NOT
CAUSE THIS.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
DOES NOT HAVE THE FUNDS. TO HELP
THE HEALTH AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS
WITH MEDICATIONS COPAYMENTS
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE INSURANCE.
INHALERS I SPEND OVER TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
ON MEDICATIONS.
AND I HAVE INSURANCE.
CHILDREN NEED SERVICES AND AND I
HAVE TO SAY I REALLY WANT.
TO THANK DEPARTMENT HEALTH
BECAUSE YOU GUYS HAVE JUST COME
IN AND GIVEN ME HOPE.
AND TAKE IN WHAT I AND MY
CONCERNS AND ARE YOU GUYS ARE
TRYING TO DO THE BEST THAT YOU
CAN.
WITH WHAT YOU HAVE.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH THE THEY'RE
REFERRING TO PROGRAMS AND
AGECIES THAT WERE ALREADY
OVERWHELMED AT BEFORE THE
REFERRALS.
AND WHEN I HEARD ON THE NEWS
THAT.
PART OF THAT HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION FOR THE GAS COMPANY.
MESSED UP.
WAS GONNA GO TO HEALTH STUDIES
AND TO HELP.
IN SERVICES FOR THEM.
I CRIED OUT HER FRUSTRATION.
BECAUSE THEY WON'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE AND PEOPLE GOT NOSE
BLEED AND I'M SORRY NOBODY
SHOULD HAVE TO SUFFER FOR ANY.
ANY CORPORATE MISS DOINGS.
BUT WE'VE WE'RE DYING HERE AND
NO ONE IS ALLOWED IN ANY MONEY.
FOR HEALTH STUDIES.
I AM BEGGING FOR HEALTH STUDIES
TO BE DONE BEFORE THE LAST OF US
LONG TERM EXPOSURE RESIDENTS.
ARE GONE WE ARE THE PERFECT
PEOPLE TO DO THESE HEALTH
STUDIES ON THE COUNTY NEEDS MORE
MONEY FOR ALL OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT THEY'RE REFERRING.
TO AND THAT MONEY SHOULD COME
FROM THE BATTERY TAX.
MONEY IT SHOULD GO THERE NOT TO
DO TST WHO TOLD US JUST LAST
MONTH [inaudible]
THAT.
THE WAY THEY INTERPRET THAT BILL
IS THAT THEY CAN USE IT HOWEVER
THEY WANT TO AS LONG AS IT'S
GOING TO LEAD.
SO TO TELL US THAT YOU WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO CLEAN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
BUT THE MONEY THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO COME TO CLEAN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD THEY'RE DECIDING
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO USE IT
ELSEWHERE TO INVESTIGATE OTHER
PLACES.
ALL OVER THE STATE AND LEAVE US
IN THIS CONTAMINATION I REALLY
DON'T THINK THAT IN MY LIFETIME.
I WILL SEE THE COMPLETION OF
THIS.
YOU COULD WRAP UP BUT DON'T MAKE
IT.
I WOULD DO SOMETHING.
ENACTED LAWS.
GET THEM TAKEN OUT OF LEAD
AGENCIES DO SOMETHING BECAUSE
THEY HAVE IMMUNITY.
THERE IS NO THEY THE PEOPLE FROM
FROM FLINT MICHIGAN THOSE PEOPLE
WENT TO JAIL.
DTS THE WHO ALLOWED THIS TO
HAPPEN HAS IMMUNITY AND THERE'S
NO INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO MAKE
DECISIONS.
IN OUR BEST INTEREST PORTER
HURRY REMOVE THAT IMMUNITY.
AND LET'S SEE HOW FAST THE
MOVEMENT.
THANK YOU VERY COMMENTS --
VON WATTS.
FOLLOWED BY MARY ANGELA RINCON.
SERAPHINA AND MONEY BELLEFONTE.
HI MY NAME IS YVONNE MARTINEZ
WATSON -- MY
FAMILY HAS VERY DEEP ROOTS HERE
IN EAST LA.
MY PARENTS WERE MET AND MARRIED
IN EAST LA --
I'M HAVING TROUBLE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I ALSO HAVE.
VERY BAD AS MOST.
I WAS ACTUALLY BORN WITH.
OF MR DURING THE MILLENNIUM
[inaudible]
UP.
I'M ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
FOR THE SIERRA CLUB ANGELES
CHAPTER.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT --
I'VE BEEN COMING TO THESE
MEETINGS FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND A
HALF NOW.
AND ALL THESE PEOPLE SITTING
BEHIND ME.
THESE PEOPLE ARE HERE THE ONE
YOU JUST LISTEN TO THOSE THOSE
PEOPLE ARE MY HEROES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING TO LIVE
WITH THIS.
AND THEY HAVE TO LIVE WITH IT
EVERY DAY.
AT FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO SAY.
I APPRECIATE THE LADY THAT CAME
UP AND SAID DON'T FORGET ABOUT
THE ELDERLY.
PLEASE DON'T FORGET ABOUT PEOPLE
LIKE ME WITH A SMIRK.
PEOPLE WITH COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEMS.
OR ANY OTHER PROBLEMS.
BECAUSE THIS SORT OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION WILL AFFECT
EVERYBODY THAT HAS THOSE KIND OF
PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS OR
PROBLEMS.
SO IT IS A MUCH MORE EXTENSIVE
PROBLEM THAN JUST.
CHILDREN.
AND AND A PREGNANT WOMEN --
I ALSO WANTED TO SAY THAT UP
WHEN YOU DO.
WHEN THEY OFFER THE INDOOR CLEAN --
I WAS THERE IN PORTER RANCH. TO
TESTIFY.
AFTER THE RELEASE OF CANNIBAL
OUT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THE
PEOPLE IN PORTER RANCH WHEN THEY
WERE OFFERED CLEANING INSIDE
THEIR HOMES.
THEY WERE SUSPICIOUS.
AND THE REASON WHY THEY WERE
SUSPICIOUS IS BECAUSE WHEN YOU
COME IN AND YOU CLEAN THE
INTERIOR OF A WHOLE.
WITHOUT FIRST TAKING SAMPLINGS.
IN THAT HOME.
YOU'VE JUST DESTROYED EVIDENCE.
SO I'M JUST HOPING THAT BEFORE.
PEOPLE GO IN TO DO PLANNING ON
THESE PHONES WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THAT SHOULD BE DONE.
BUT IF YOU REALLY WANT TO HOLD
EXACT ACCOUNTABLE.
DON'T DESTROY THE EVIDENCE YOU
NEED TO DO THAT.
SOMEBODY HAS TO GO IN THERE AND
DO SAMPLING.
THAT WILL HOLD UP IN COURT.
BECAUSE I CAN GUARANTEE YOU
THEY'RE GOING TO FIND A WAY TO
WEASEL OUT OF THIS.
THEY'RE ALREADY TRYING TO DO
THAT I JUST KNOW IT.
I ALSO WANT TO SEE THAT.
YOU NEED TO HOLD THE TSC
RESPONSIBLE [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
THEY WERE THE AGENCY THAT WAS
RESPONSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS COMPANY WAS DOING THINGS IN
A RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
AND THEY FAILED THE FAILED
MISERABLY.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
THEY WERE STILL RESPONSIBLE.
SO I AM JUST APPALLED.
BUT THEY ARE EVEN INVOLVED IN
THIS AT ALL.
I MEAN WHY WOULD YOU PUT IN THE
THE THE FOX IN CHARGE OF THE HEN
HOUSE.
AND THEY GIVE THE MONEY TO DO IT.
I'M ASKING YOU PLEASE WE NEED
THE MONEY TO DO THE CLEANUP TO
GET ALL THE PLACES CLEANED UP
NOT JUST SOMEONE.
BUT ALL OF THEM.
BECAUSE YOU GET THIS WORK IF
THIS WAS A NUCLEAR CONTAMINATION
ISSUE.
WOULD YOU BE SATISFIED IF WE ARE
THE PROPERTY WAS CLEANED.
OKAY YOU GO NEXT DOOR TO A
NUCLEAR WASTE SITE.
THAT WOULD NOT BE ACCEPTABLE AND
I GUARANTEE YOU IF THIS WERE
HAPPENING IN PORTER RANCH.
YOU WOULD HAVE DOZENS OF
LAWSUITS FILED AGAINST THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
SO PLEASE FIND THE MONEY.
GET THIS CEANED UP.
DO RESPONSIBLY.
AND PLEASE THESE ARE PEOPLE'S
LIVES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
AND THESE PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE
JUST AS VALUABLE.
AS ANYBODY ELSE IN THE CITY OF
RALEIGH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AREAS OF A WRINKLE.
GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS MY
DEBATE BECAUSE THE YOUNG I AM A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I'M ALSO A CO
CHAIR FOR THE ACLU SEVEN TO ONE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ACTION
TEAM.
NOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ASK
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW WHY IS LABOR
INVOLVED WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
MOVEMENT.
YOU KNOW.
WE ARE AWARE AND SMART ENOUGH TO
KNOW THAT THOUSANDS OF OUR S.
YEAH YOU MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES LIVE AND WORK IN
NEIGHBORHOODS CONTAMINATED BY
THE EXCITED.
AND HERE'S A MAP AND FIGURED
MAYBE SHOW IT TO THE AUDIENCE
OVER THERE.
TOO SO THEY CAN SEE HOW MANY
MEMBERS WITHIN THE EXCITING AREA
LIVE.
LIVE THERE SO THIS IS IMPORTANT
FOR US.
MANY OF OUR OUR MEMBERS WORK IN
SCHOOLS HOSPITALS AND CLINICS
THAT TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE
POISONED BY EXIDE ONE IN
PARTICULAR IS A COLLEAGUE OF
MINE AND ARE AND WHO COULDN'T BE
HERE TONIGHT AND SHE GREW UP IN
THIS AREA.
SHE WAS UNABLE TO HAVE CHILDREN
AT THE BEGINNING AND WAS
[inaudible]
GRATEFULLY.
PREGNANT TWICE SO SHE HAS TWO
CHILDREN THAT ARE NOW IN A YOUNG
ADULTS HOWEVER BOTH OF HER
CHILDREN SUFFER FROM MEDICAL
CONDITIONS.
SHE WILL NEVER BE A GRANDMOTHER
AND ONE OF HER WORRIES IS WHO IS
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF HER
CHILDREN WHEN SHE'S GONE.
SCO YOU SUPPORTED THE BILL FOR
THE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE ALSO PARTICIPATED
HUNDREDS OF OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATED IN THE HISTORIC
JUNE TENTH NEIGHBORHOOD OUTREACH.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THE PACE
AND SCALE OF CLEANUP IS
INADEQUATE.
THE AREA TO BE CLEANED UP MUST
BE EXPANDED AND THE FUNDS
COLLECTED MUST BE USED
RESPONSIBLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SERVER RIDIN.
HIGH MY NAME IS FANNIE --
I'M A FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR AND
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT I'M A
LITTLE HEIGHTS RESIDENT.
AND I'M.
ALSO A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND A
COMMUNITY FARMER BUT TODAY I'M
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING OVER TWO
THOUSAND SEIU MEMBERS.
AND THAT'S NOT THE MARKERS THE
CAPTAIN -- I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT.
WE BELIEVE EXCESS SHOULD BE A
BATTERY TAX IN ADDITION TO
CLEANING UP GOES FACTORIES.
SPECIALLY DOLLS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AND MONEY FROM THE TAX SHOULD
NOT BE DIVERTED TO OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT ADDRESSING
THAT ACID BATTERY MEDICATION.
DTS HE MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR ADHERING TO A STRINGENT
SCHEDULE FOR CLEANUP.
RESIDENTS OF THE COMMUNITY NEED
TO HAVE A MEANINGFUL ROLE IN
DETERMINING WHETHER THE CLEANUP
IS PROCEEDING.
ADEQUATELY.
THE REMOVAL OF CONTAMINATED SOIL
FROM THE PARKWAYS BETWEEN THE
STREET AND THE FRONT YARDS THE
REMOVAL OF LEAD DUST FROM THE
HOME INTERIORS.
VERIFICATION TESTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE INTERIOR OF THE
HOME IS SAFE FOR OCCUPANCY.
A BLOCK BY BLOCK STRATEGY FOR
CLEANUP TO MINIMIZE THE RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH STATES CURRENT
PARCEL BY PARCEL.
APPROACH AND LASTLY LIKE MISTER
YOU GOT SOMETHING TO STATE IT
HOW CAN SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN I HSS PROVIDERS CAN STEP
IN AND MAKING A LASTING IMPACT
IN ASSISTING IN THAT EXCITE
CLEAN UP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SARAH RIVERA.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT MY NAME IS
AKBAR GUY AND I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT --
SEIU LOCAL NINETY NINE WE ARE
EDUCATIONAL WORKERS WORKING FOR
ELLIOTT LAUSD WERE CLASSIFIED
WORKERS.
AND WE WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
I WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT.
I WORK WITH KIDS WHO ARE DEAF
ANDHARD OF HEARING WHO ALSO
HAVE.
PHYSICAL AND SOME MENTAL
DISABILITIES [inaudible]
AND THEY LIVE IN IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT AFFECTED AND I
WORK WITH.
FLOOD ASSISTANCE WHO ACTUALLY GO
TO THIS CHURCH.
SO I AM GIVING THEM THE VOICE.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BE HERE.
AND WE ARE THE SECOND --
LARGEST MEMBERSHIP OF THE LOCAL
THAT IS AFFECTED.
BY THIS SO I NEED YOU GUYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS ISN'T
DOESN'T AFFECT ANY MORE PEOPLE
THAT I WORK WITH AND I CARE
ABOUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOHN THEIR MENU.
ROGER NEWER AND MARTHA JIMENEZ.
MY NAME IS JOHN SIR MANUAL.
I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS.
I NOW LIVE IN THE CITY OF
COMMERCE.
I'M A MEMBER.
OF THE EXITE WORKERS AND
COMMUNITY COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THE DEVELOPED.
ALTHOUGH THE RACISM BY A
CONTRACTOR IN PHASE ONE OF THE
TESTING PROCESS OF EXCITE.
THE COMPANY THE DGSE.
CHOSE WAS RACES.
ALL THE ADMINISTRATORS HAD NEVER
BEEN IN CALIFORNIA.
HAD NEVER SEEN A MEXICAN INNER
LIFE.
HOW COULD SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HAPPEN?
SO DO TSC IS NOT A GOOD.
AGENCY TO TO RUN THIS PROJECT
[inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
THE CLEAN UP HAS TO BE.
INTERNALLY AND EXTERNALLY INSIDE
THE HOME.
IN OUTSIDE THE HOME HAS TO BE
COMPLETE.
IT HAS TO BE QUALITY WORK OUR
COMMUNITY OUR COMMUNITY DESERVES
THAT.
WE WANT THAT AND WE DEMAND THAT.
WE NEED TO BE TREATED AS EQUAL
AS ANYONE ELSE.
ON THE WORK WITH OF THE TESTING
I WAS IN PHASE ONE I'M I'M IN
ONE OF THE WORKERS.
WHEN WE FINISHED IN APRIL OF?
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT TOOK DTS.
OVER A YEAR TO GET US BACK IN
THE FACE TO DO THE CLEANUP.
THEY DELAYED AND DELAYED.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT PROCESS?
THE WORKERS SPACE.
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS AN ALARM HAD
TO DO SOMETHING ELSE.
A LOT OF THEM FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN THEIR LIVES.
FELL IN LOVE WITH A NEW ISSUE.
A LOT OF THEM HAD NEVER WORKED
ON A PROJECT ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECTS.
BUT ONCE THEY GOT INVOLVED ONCE
THEY INTEGRATED WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
THEY SAW ALL PURPOSE IN THEIR
LIFE.
AND THEY WANTED TO GO BACK TO
WORK.
AND DID YOU EVER SEE DISMANTLED
[inaudible]
KILLED IT.
SO WE CAN HAVE AN AGENCY THAT
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT US.
ALL THEY CARE ABOUT USER
APPARATUS.
BUILDING THEIR POWER BASE AS YOU
CAN SEE THE DATE.
AND I TOLD HIM DIRECTLY.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
IS GENERAL BUT I THINK IT'S TRUE
[inaudible]
I I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE.
POLITICAL FIGURES YOUR POLITICAL
OFFICIALS.
WE'RE PART OF A MOVEMENT THAT'S
DEVELOPING IN SOUTHEAST LA.
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE QUESTION
OF IMMIGRATION.
OF CIVIC.
ENGAGEMENT.
AND WE'RE ALSO OUR BIGGEST
COMMITTEE IS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE.
SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING.
AN ALLIANCE BETWEEN THE LABOR
UNIONS AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
MOVEMENT. TO GIVE IT POWER
INTEGRATE THE CHANGES UNDER BACK
OUR PEOPLE.
AND THE STRUGGLES WERE EXCITE IS
PRIMARY.
HEALTH ISSUE.
IT HAS TWO APPROACHES WORK FROM
THAT ANGLE IT HAS TO START FROM
THERE.
BUT THEY DON'T LOOK AT THE MONEY
THEY LOOK AT THE POWER.
WE CANNOT STAND FOR THAT
[inaudible]
SO THIS [inaudible]
THIS.
THE BENTONVILLE JUST I'M ALMOST
AT THE ENDING THANK YOU WILL BE
AUGUST.
TWENTY SIX AT AT THREE OF AT
FORTY I THINK IT'S FIFTY FOUR
HUNDRED PACIFIC BOULEVARD.
IN HUNTINGTON PARK.
AND THAT'S JUST ONE OF MANY
EVENTS WERE BUILDING THIS
MOVEMENT. FOR OUR COMMUNITY CAN
HAVE.
A BIG PART OF THE DECISION
MAKING ON THIS ISSUE WERE ALWAYS
LEFT OUT.
THIS PROCESS IS NOT GOING TO DO
IT OUR PEOPLE HAVE TO BE
PARTICIPATE.
BECAUSE WE'RE WORRIED.
WERE PART OF THE PROBLEM NOT
PART.
WHAT WERE DIRECTLY AFFECTED?
THE SOLUTION IS GOING TO COME
FROM US BECAUSE WE HAVE THE MOST
PASSIONATE RATHER MOST DESIRE TO
FIND A SOLUTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS SIR --
WHAT TIME IS THAT AMOUNT
[inaudible]
RIGHT BEFORE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU ROGER NOR IS NEXT UP.
BY ROGER NORFOLK I WORK RECORD
BY A METAL ROD WAS MORE OF A
DESIGN REALLY CAN WHILE THE
MICROPHONE AT SORRY.
I WAS ON DISABILITY FOR AWHILE
BECAUSE I HAD A HEART PROBLEM
AND AND MY BOSS TOLD ME. TO SET
THE REAL SIMPLE GO TO THE
OUTSIDE.
ID THE COMMUNITY OVER THERE
BECAUSE IT'S MESSED UP THE TSC
AREA WAS THE LAST STRAW FOR MY
BOSS WAS WHEN THEY TOLD ME THAT
COMMUNITY JUST TO HAVE YOUR KIDS
STAY AWAY FROM SAM.
THE SOIL BARE SOIL WHICH IS A
JOKE I MEAN THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE
THE KIDS PLAY.
SO WHEN WE WENT IN DA WE DID
SOME RESEARCH WE SAW FATHER JOHN.
GOING TO THE SUPERVISORS DONE AT
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MEETINGS OR WHATEVER.
SAME WITH THE WHOLE CONGREGATION
I MEAN PORSCHE CARS AT THE
CONGREGATION AND NOBODY LISTENED
NOBODY LISTENED.
PORTER RANCH LIKELY HAPPEN SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE SOMETHING
REPORTER RASHES NOTHING I MEAN
THEY THAT'S GAS THAT DISSIPATES.
OR WHATEVER SO I MEAN IT'S GONNA
WHATEVER OVER HERE IS THERE IS
IT DEFINITELY TESTING IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT.
BEFORE THE DO THE CLEAN UP AND
DAY AND IF THEY'RE GOOD TO GO IF
THERE CAN ONLY DO. FIVE FIVE
PROPERTIES TENT AT PROPERTIES
DOWN AND THEY'RE GONNA GO ALL
THE WAY UP TO EIGHTY OKAY THEIR
JOB I MEAN THE WAY THEY'RE GONNA
CLEAN UP IS GOING TO BE CRAP.
OKAY THERE'S NO POSSIBLE WAY
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
EIGHTY AND HE HAD THE SAME
QUALITY.
IF IT DIDN'T A PLANT THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE SETTING IT UP WHERE
THEY'RE DOING IT ONE BY ONE BY.
ONE LOOK IN THIS PROCESS BECAUSE
I TEACH ASBESTOS I TEACH
DISCUSSES WORKERS I ALSO TEACH
THE LEAD BASED A THE LEAD
INSPECTORS.
KIND OF LEAD WORKERS AND ALSO
THAT MONITORS HATE IT TO PASS
THE STATE TEST AND THERE IS NO
POSSIBLE WAY IS BEST AS IF YOU
HAD SIX SEVEN SAMPLES OF ONE
BUILDING MATERIAL AND ONE OF
THEM IS HOT.
ALL HOT YOU KNOW WHY BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA MISS A WHOLE BUNCH
OKAY UNIT AS A WHOLE BUNCH AND
IT'S NOT CLEAN.
IT THESE IT THAT JUST BECAUSE
ONE HOUSE THEY CAUGHT IT IN
ANOTHER HOUSE THEY DIDN'T CATCH
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT I MEAN COME
ON THINK ABOUT THIS.
I MEAN ANYBODY THAT THINKS OF
CARTOONS IF IT'S LET'S OVER OKAY
YOU'RE GONNA MISS SOME.
OR WHATEVER AND THEY ALL YOUR
HOUSE IS CLEAN IT AIN'T CLEAN
COME ON AND SAY THE NEXT THING
IS THAT WHEN THEY'RE DOING THE
IS THAT THE CLEAN UP.
AND THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THINGS FIRST THE LOOK FOR IT TOO
FAR BESIDES LOOK AT THEMSELVES
AND THEN YOU GUYS GIVE THEM THE
MONEY AND IT'S A LITTLE OKAY
POOR WRETCH WITH A LOAN.
EDDIE THAT THE GAS COMPANY PAID
OFF ME THEY'RE PAYING THEM AND
THAT'S IT WOULD'VE OVER HERE
IT'S A LOAN. TO WHO DOES WHO
OWES THE LOAN.
AND IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT I'M
SORRY FROM IT TAKES A COUPLE
SECONDS THE MORE.
OKAY.
HERE'S ANOTHER PROBLEM.
ARREST ME OKAY THERE'S ANOTHER
PROBLEM IS THAT WHEN YOU GUYS
ARE DRIVING WHEN DOES THE DUMP
TRUCKS ARE GOING TO FORTY TON
TON TRUCKS.
ON PRIVATE STREETS YEAH YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A FORTY TON BEAT TO IT.
FORTY TIMES DUMP TRUCK IT CAN GO.
TO A FORTY TON DUMP TRUCK CAN I
CAN CARRY UP TO FORTY TIMES.
THE AVERAGE FOR EIGHTEEN INCHES
FOR EIGHTEEN INCHES OF SOIL IT'S
ANY ABOUT SIXTY TIMES FOR EVERY
HOUSE OKAY THAT MEANS THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE A FORTY TON A
DUMP TRUCK COLLECTING FORTY
TIMES AND DRIVING A PRIVATE
STREET ON YOUR PRIVATE STREETS.
DRIVING DRY IT'S A ONE HALF WITH
THESE.
TRUCKS FOR EVERY SINGLE HOUSE ON
YOUR STREET ALONE IT'S GONNA
RACK YOUR SEWAGE LINES IT'S
GONNA WRECK YOUR WATER LIKE IT'S
GOING TO WRECK YOUR STREETS
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE POTHOLES AND
NOBODY'S EVEN PAYING ATTENTION.
CERTAIN THEY'RE GONNA WRAP UP.
AND THIS IS GONNA BE A NIGHT
GUYS HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TWENTY FIVE HOUSES AT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A HOUSE.
IN THERE NOT CLEAN EIGHTEEN
INCHES BY THE WAY THEY'RE SAYING
THAT IN THE BACKYARDS BECAUSE I
ASKED HIM.
WAVE IF YOU GUYS WANT TO SPEAK
TO THAT EVALUATE THE JOB SITES
IF YOU GUYS WANT THE JOB SITES
YOU CAN'T GET A BATTLE IN THE
BACKYARD.
OKAY SO WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO IS
THAT THEY'RE DIGGING AND YOU
KNOW WHY PEOPLE GET BUSTED FOR
MURDER BECAUSE OF A SHALLOW
GRAVE YOU KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO
GET TO DIG I I SHALLOW GRAVE
EVEN.
AND THIS THIS WASN'T A BIG
EIGHTEEN INCHES NO NO NO THEY'RE
GONNA GET.
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND THE ONLY
HAVE TO DIG UP TO THE FIRST
ROUTE WITH THE RULES AND THEN
THEY STOP YOU DON'T THINK IT'S A
VERY BRIEF COMMENTS ARE AWESOME
DOWN AND SAVE IT IS SAYING THAT
HE WILL HAVE.
MORE TO GIVE US A FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND THERE ARE RAPING YOU
GUYS SO PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE
DON'T LET THEM DCS HE'S GONE
ALREADY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MARTHA JIMENEZ.
WELL THE BY TERRY MARQUEZ AND
JOSE I'M AN ARROW.
YES MY NAME IS MARK THE
HUMANNESS I AM PART OF THE
HISTORY CONSUL FOR EXIDE I
REPRESENT THE ENDING CORPORATE
IT AREA.
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY I AM HERE
TO CONSTITUTIONALLY DEMAND FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
TWO PLEASE ASK THE DTS SEEK TO
CONTINUE HAVING THE REQUIRED
EXCITE PUBLIC ADVISORY COUNCIL
MEETINGS AT DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
THIS BRINGS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE PROCESS OF
THE CLEANING UP OF THE HOMES AND
THE EVENTUAL DISMANTLING OF EX
NOT USED TO HAVING THINGS DONE
HELLO SCHOOLTEACHER.
WE ARE TIRED OF NOT HAVING BEING
PART OF THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS WE ASK YOU TO PLEASE
TAKE NOTE OF THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IF THERE
ARE RETAINED MANIFEST REQUIRE
WHEN DOING THE CLEANUP OF THE
PRIVATE HOMES AND PARK POLICE.
JUST LIKE THERE ARE FOR THE
EVENTUAL DISMANTLING OF EXCITING.
SEES MANY FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO THEWORSE LEVELS OF
TOXICS WITH THE EXCITED BY YOUR
MEANT TO CATASTROPHE.
WHAT CAN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
DUE? TO LEGISLATE AND INCLUDE
ALL THE AFFECTED PERSON SEEM TO
I HIT BY LIST.
SO THAT IN THE FUTURE THEY MAY
HAVE A MEDICAL RECORD INORDER TO
FILE. FOR FUTURE REPARATIONS
BECAUSE THESE.
DAMAGE TO THEIR HEALTH.
IT'S THE WORST KIND THAT ANYONE
CAN IMAGINE.
ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WITHIN THE CONTRACTS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE PUT IN PLACE.
FOR HIRING THEIR RESOLVE CITY
TRAININGS AND BEST WORKER HEALTH
AND SAFETY PRACTICES FOR ALL THE
WORKERS EITHER WORKING IN THAT
IS MENTALLY PROCESS FOR EXCITE.
OR IN THE HOMES.
THIS IN THE PAST HAS NOT BEEN OF
SERVICE AS YOU HAVE HEARD AND WE
WANT TO SET A NEW PRECEDENT.
PLEASE TAKE NOTE OF THAT AND
FINALLY I REQUEST FOR GOVERNOR
BROWN TO ALL THE KEY.
AS PART OF THE LEGACY SINCE HE'S
ALREADY LEAVING.
AN EXTRA MATCHING FUNDS FOR THE
EXITE CLEAN.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SURPLUS FIND.
JUST AS IT WAS SAID BEFORE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING DIES
HARD IN YEARS TO OUR COMMUNITY
WE WANT YOU TO CONTINUE HAVING
THIS TYPE OF MEETINGS.
AT LEAST TWICE A YEAR SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ANY CAN BE
ROTATED ALL OVER IN THE
DIFFERENT.
AREAS THAT YOU REPRESENT WHERE
WE ARE AFFECTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TERRY IS A MARQUIS [inaudible]
MARCUS MARCUS.
SORRY ABOUT THAT WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CARRIE
MARKET SOARED THREE SOME MARKET.
PRESENT IN THE MOTHERS TO BE
STILL A PRISONER I BOIL HIGH
STAKE HOLDERS OF LITIGATION.
WELL I STAKEHOLDERS ASSOCIATION
NOT TOO MANY PEOPLE KNOW.
BUT WE ARE MEMBERS THEN WE ARE
FOR FIVE GENERATIONS IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS.
AND WE ARE HALF MEXICAN.
HALF IRISH HALF JEWISH HALF
JAPANESE WE HAVE THE MIXTURE AND
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF IT.
EXITE HAS ALMOST DESTROYED OUR
GOLD IN OUR DREAMS HERE BOYLE
HEIGHTS [inaudible]
MY HOUSE.
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE.
I HAVE A BUTTERFLY GARDEN I HAVE
A ROSE GARDEN.
I HAVE EVERYTHING FOR MY
GRANDCHILDREN THEY TO COME AND
PLAY IN EXPERIENCE NATURE WHAT I
WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE NATURE
THEY CAN'T DO IT ANYMORE.
BUT BE SITES THAT.
I HAVE BEEN IN EVERY MEETING YOU
SEEN ME.
MY FACE IS.
USING EVERY MEETING HERE
RESURRECTION EVERY IT'S LIKE
MEETING IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO DO IT.
JUST LIKE.
THANK YOU SUNDAY I WILL THANK
YOU. FOR BEING THERE FOR US.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU.
I WILL FIGHT FOR EVERYBODY IN
THE ONE POINT SEVEN MILES.
AND MY GOD GET IT DONE.
I AM BEYOND THE ONE POINT SEVEN
MILES IN MY HOUSE WEST CHECK.
I AM TWO MILES.
FROM EXCITE AND MY HOUSE IS.
DOUBLE A DIAL UP OVER A THOUSAND
OKAY.
IT IS CONTAMINATED AT A VERY
HIGH RATE AND WHERE I'M JUST A
FEW BLOCKS OFF THE GRID.
AND I'M NOT WE'RE NOT EVEN
FIGHTING FOR THAT YET WE WE WANT
THE ONE POINT SEVEN MILES.
AND THIS THING ABOUT.
THE LONG STOP CALLING IT A LONG.
IT'S OUR MONEY.
OKAY YOU GOT IT OFF THE GENERAL
FUND THAT'S OUR MONEY I DON'T
KNOW WHAT GOVERNOR BROWN THINGS.
BUT THAT'S OUR MONEY.
THEN JUST BECAUSE WE FIND IN
WORK. FOR THAT FEE.
BATTERY FOR THE MONEY TO COME IN.
THEY WANT TO TAKE IT RIGHT OUT.
KEN COULD YOU WAIT THREE YEARS.
AND DON'T BE SO STINGY.
A LITTLE CLEAN UP WHAT WE NEED
TO CLEAN UP.
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
HOW THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
HOW MANY YEARS HAVE WE GONE ON
THIS?
AND THEY HAVE ONLY.
CLEANED.
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY SIX I DON'T
CARE.
I DON'T CARE HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU
NEED TO HIRE WHAT IS IS THAT
THEY CAN HIRE ENOUGH PEOPLE THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TEAMS WELL
WE'RE GETTING TO BE TEN TEAMS
NOW.
WILL KNOW WHY DON'T YOU HAVE
MORE TEAMS THE MONEY'S THERE WE
ALMOST RAN OUT OF TIME FOR USING
THAT MONEY AND THANK YOU SUNDAY
I WILL FOR GOING OUT THERE AND
EXPANDING THAT DATE.
THAT IS DO YOU MIGHT NOT THAT.
THAT'S THE DSC.
ALL.
THE B. DO YOU SEE I WHICH
BARBARA LEE WAS STILL HERE SHE
NEVER ENDS UP.
AT THE END OF THE MEETING BUT
STILL HER.
BARBOUR.
WELL YOU NEED TO HEAR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE YOU
NEED TO HEAR THIS BARBARA.
WE CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER.
OUR CHILDREN ARE IN BAD TOXIC
SOIL.
THEY'RE NOT IN THE HOTEL LIKE.
LIKE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE DONE.
THEY'RE THERE EVERY DAY.
AND IF YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO KEEP THE CHILDREN IN FINE.
NO THEY'RE NOT.
THEY STILL HAVE TO GO TO SCHOOL
THEY HAVE TO WALK THROUGH THIS.
AND PLEASE.
MAKE SURE SOMETHING THAT WILL
PLEASE.
YEAH THEM TO GET IT DONE AND GET
IT DONE NOW.
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE I AM AN ARROW.
AND YEAH SHEEN LEAVE AFTER.
THOSE ARE THE LAST NAMES THAT I
HAVE IF YOU WANT TO SUBMIT A A
CHIP IT'S NOT TOO LATE.
ALLOW ME TO SAY AND DTC ASKED US
TO KEEP THE PRESSURE ON SO I'M
GOING TO DO JUST THAT --
DTC SOMEONE FROM THE T. SAID
THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE WORRIED
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO LET UP.
NOW WE'RE NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT
IT FEELS LIKE YOU HAVEN'T
STARTED --
YOU'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH FOR US
TO FEEL THAT WAY --
WHAT WE HEAR WHEN YOU GUYS
REPORT OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
FROM WHAT I WOULD CALL LIVE?
WE HAD THREE DOCTORS AT LEAST WE
HAD AN EXPERT INSTRUCTOR ON LET.
BASICALLY TELL YOU THAT WOULD BE
TO SAVE OUR LIVES.
INCONSISTENCIES.
THEY DON'T THINK THEY'RE GONNA
CLEAN UP TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
PROBABLY TWO YEARS FOR HOW LONG.
HE SAID THAT TO DATE AND THE
MATH THAT THREE PEOPLE POINTED
OUT DOESN'T ADD UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THE PROPERTY TWO YEARS IT
ADDS UP TO FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS.
THAT'S WHAT DOCTORS HAVE SAID
RIGHT NOW.
HOW CAN YOU TRUST THE THC?
BROKER CO REP CAREER REFUNDABLE
WHEN YOU HEARING PEOPLE TESTIFY
THAT WHAT THEY'RE SAYING MARKET
LAG.
AND IT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT WERE BEING EXPOSED.
AND IT'S NOT JUST BABIES IN
FRONT OF THE ACTUALLY IT'S ME
TOOL.
HEALTHY PERSON WHO'S.
FUTURE IS BEING LIMITED BECAUSE
I LIVE IN A SITUATION WHERE I
MAY BE EXPOSED TO DANGEROUS
LEVEL OF THAT.
THIS IS CLEAR THAT THE SITUATION
IS OUT OF CONTROL AND YOU'VE
HEARD YOU NOW KNOW THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO COST IS OTHER PEOPLE
ARE BEING CHARGED TO CLEAN IT UP.
WHY ARE YOU CALLING FOR A CHANGE
IN WHO MAKES DECISIONS?
I HEAR PEOPLE IN THE COUNTY AND
I HEARD INSTRUCTED TO HAVE MORE
CLARITY THAN THE PEOPLE FROM THE
ATSC.
WHY AREN'T THEY THE ONES
DECIDING WHAT THE WHY ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK DECIDING?
WHAT'S BEST FOR THAT TO BE DONE
IN THE HOME.
WHY ARE YOU GUYS STILL GIVING
THE TEA IS THE MONEY?
WHY DO YOU STILL TRUST DTS SCENE
WHEN WE [inaudible]
DON'T ANYMORE.
ALL OF US YOU HEARD I HAVEN'T
HEARD ANYBODY SUPPORT PTSD HERE.
YEAH WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT
THEM MAKING DECISIONS ON HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO CLEAN IT UP
WHEN THEY HAVE FAILED.
THE NUMBER THAT THEY SHOW UP
PROBABLY HAVE TO BE CLEANED UP
OR IN THE THOUSANDS.
THE NUMBER THAT HAVE BEEN
CLEANED UP ON THE LITTLE
HUNDREDS.
THE NUMBER THAT THEY'RE SHOWING
US MONTHLY ARE IN THAT TEAM.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS OF AND WORLD CAME WITH
SEEING TWENTY HOW DOES THE WEEK.
I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE ANYBODY HE
WAS OKAY WITH THAT.
ARE YOU GUYS OKAY WITH THAT.
THANK YOU SIR AND FINALLY --
YASHIN.
CO.
FAMILY MEMBERS AND I CHAIR.
I'M I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY
NEPHEW JOSEPH WHEN I KNOW HE'S A
FORTY YEAR OLD NOW.
I'VE.
DECEMBER MENTAL JUSTICE WORK AND
ACTUALLY WENT TO GO VISIT YOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
I'M SO HE ACTUALLY WAS WORKING
ON THE ORCA BILL VERY PASSIONATE
JUST LIKE YOU UP OR BECAUSE HE
LOVES WORK AS AS FOR THREE YEARS
LATER.
HE HAS AN AUTOIMMUNE DISEASE HE
WAS RAISED IN THE CITY OF MY
WHAT.
I'M STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW GOING
TO SCHOOL --
HE HAS EVERYTHING FROM A
BLEEDING NOSE TO VOMITING
HEADACHES NOT ABLE TO GET UP OFF
THE BED BECAUSE HE'S SUFFERING
FROM ALL THESE ILLNESSES RIGHT.
IN ADDITION TO THAT ASTHMA SO
PERSPECTIVE I WOULD LOVE FOR
LAUSD TO SIT DOWN THIS TABLE AND
DISCUSS HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
HANDLE TH SITUATION OF THE
INFLUX OF CHILDREN THAT ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW IN SCHOOL.
TO DO THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WE'RE FACING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
HE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE OTHER MOMS
ARE ALSO LOOKING INTO --
EITHER A SPEAKING TO THEIR
DOCTORS BECAUSE ONE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD THE MEDICINES AND TO
FINDING OTHER ALTERNATIVES SUCH
AS HOMEOPATHIC --
OPTIONS BECAUSE AT THIS POINT IS
GETTING PRICEY FOR OUR FAMILIES
AND OUR COMMUNITY SO I'M I WOULD
LOVE FOR LAUSD MORE SPECIFICALLY.
TO COME AND SIT IN THE TABLE SO --
LIKE MY NEPHEW WAS HARASSED FOR
A FEW YEARS BECAUSE HE COULDN'T
DO HIS HOMEWORK SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS THAT BECAUSE HE WAS
STUCK.
IN BED AT HOME SO DOES BEING
REALISTIC ABOUT WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE AT A AT A HOUSE THAT WITH A
CHILD IS STRUGGLING.
THROUGH ALL OF THIS I'M JUST
PUTTING A PERSPECTIVE THAT HE
HE'S A GIFTED CHILD STRUCK.
HARD CORE WORKER WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO ON HIS HOMEWORK NOT LAZY
IF AT ALL AND BUT I'LL JUST TELL
YOU THIS MUCH PLEASE TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT THE CHILDREN
ARE STRUGGLING AND THEY'RE
TRYING -- TO
DO THE BEST THEY CAN BUT THEY
NEED OUR HELP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO ADD COMMENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO PLEASE STEP UP
TO THE MICROPHONE [inaudible]
SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST ON
BEHALF OF THEY ARE AFFECTED
COMMUNITY THE PRESENCE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL [inaudible] FOR
I NEXT MEETING.
BECAUSE HE'S SUPPOSED TO GIVE US
FEEDBACK ON WHAT IS GOING ON HOW
HE'S WORKING WITH THE TWO SEE.
I'VE BEEN ASKING FOR THIS FOR
THE LONG* BUT I AM
REQUESTING CONSTITUTIONALLY TO
HAVE THE PRESENCE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOW IT WAS SET
UP.
THANK YOU VERY EASILY THE ICE
HARD IN YEARS TO OUR REQUESTS.
THANKS THANK YOU.
I'M.
NOT REALLY.
SURE YOU'RE GONNA BUT FROM WHAT
I WOULD ASK QUESTIONS AND YOU
CAN THINK OF THE ANSWERS AND
PERHAPS PROVIDING INTERNET ARE
YOU HAVE YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT NO NO BUT ALREADY.
WHAT'S THAT NO ONE ELSE IS
WILLING TO SPEAK RIGHT NOW NEEDS.
WHICH WHICH MEANS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONCLUDE THE PUBLIC
HEARING PART OF THAT A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TO SQUEEZE ONE ADDING
ONE YEAR'S WORK LIKE COMMENT
THAT I WANT I WANT TO CUT YOU
OFF BUT BUT ONE MORE QUICK
COMMENT.
OKAY AMENDED WITH THIS AND THEN
IT'S VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
SQUEEZE EIGHT YEARS OF
FRUSTRATION OF BITE.
INTO THE TIME RESTRAINTS ARE
GIVEN US AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
VERY UNFAIR AND TALK ABOUT
RACIAL THAT'S JUST SO UNFAIR.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS THAT OF MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE THAT.
MS GARCIA. ONE THAT I THINK
EVERYONE.
BEING DEBATED COMMUNITY AND ALL
OF THAT THAT WE DON'T CARE.
WHAT YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
SORT OF THING?
THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT.
THE MILLION BETWEEN ONE FIFTY
THREE AND THE OTHER THE ABILITY
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THE INTENTION
OF THAT BUILDING UP BUILDING OUT
HALF.
HE PAID BACK OF THE BUILDING
AFFIRMATION THAT.
WE KNOW WE HAVE MORE AFFECTED
HOMES OUT THERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND JANE WILLIAMS TALK ABOUT THE
ATROCITIES OF MATCHES HAVING
THAT WHEN THE BECAUSE IT
HAPPENED WE WERE NEGOTIATING
THAT.
ATROCITY ALSO WHEN OUR MONEY IS
BEING TAKEN AWAY --
INSTEAD OF TO THE LEFT THERE SO
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN USE
IT FOR ALL OF OUR HOMES IF WE
HAVE A RAINY FUN FOR THE STATE
WE COULD HAVE A RAINY FUN FOR
THIS COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHAT
THAT BILL IS ABOUT.
ON AND SO I HOPE THAT MOVING
FORWARD WE GUARANTEED THROUGH
LEGISLATION.
THAT THAT MONEY CANNOT BE USED
TO PAY BACK THE LOAN UNTIL
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN CLEANED UP.
THROUGH LEGISLATION.
THAT IS THAT WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED AND NOT JUST THE DOLLARS WE
HAVE NOW.
WORSE OFF IN THE NEAR FUTURE
THAT BILL IS GOING TO BE CUT
EVEN FURTHER BECAUSE IT'S PART
OF IT SUNSETS.
AND I HOPE THAT WE ALSO DO THE
OPPOSITE COMMUNITY TO
LEGISLATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOES NOT SUNSET.
ON AND IT'S USED FOR ITS
INTENDED PURPOSES WHICH WAS TO
CLEAN UP EXCITED THE OTHERS
MONITORING SITES ARE ALSO FROM
BATTERY --
CONTAMINATION IN THE AREA
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST EXCITED.
AND SO I THINK IT'S FRUSTRATING
TO COME HERE AGAIN.
IT'S FRUSTRATING AS AN AUTHOR OF
A BILL THAT PROMISES COMMUNITY
THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT. TO THEN HAVE IT BE
USED OTHERWISE AND SETTLED
MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE THE FOCUS
TO FIGHT TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
NO ONE SAT BEHIND THE DEFINED
TOGETHER TO FINE TUNE THAT BUILD.
ON AND MAKE SURE THAT WE DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND AGAIN WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW
WE CAN JUST FOCUS ON THE MOST
CONTAMINATED HOMES WE CAN'T JUST
FOCUS ON THE MOTHERS.
AND BABIES WE CAN'T JUST FOCUS
ON BOYLE HEIGHTS VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK THAT
BULL HEADEDNESS DONE.
BUT IT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN JUST
THE SALLY AMPLE HIGHLIGHTED
INCLUDES MADE WOULD HIDING THEM
PART.
BELL CLIMBERS WHO KNOWS WHAT'S
OUT THERE I THINK WE NEED TO
REPEAT ALL THEIR NEEDS HAVE NOT
WE'RE GONNA FORGET THEM AND
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THEM BEHIND.
ON SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CREATIVE AND I THINK
FINALLY WHATEVER.
LAST WEEK OR SAID ABOUT.
WE NEED TO ALLOW THE COMMUNITY
TO BE PART OF MAKING THE
DECISION.
IS NOT JUST BECAUSE WE KNOW
BETTER BUT THIS IS OUR HOME IN
OUR BACKYARD WE SHOULD HAVE
SOMETHING IN THIS CITY NEEDS TO
BE A COMPROMISE.
YES COMPROMISE BOTH WAYS AND
MAYBE WILL TAKE SOME OF WHAT THE
OTHER SIDE IS SAYING BUT A
HASSLE.
IT'S BEEN MOSTLY WENT AWAY ON
AND SO I HOPE THAT FOR THOSE OF
THE TERM POWER WE START TO LET
THEM SET THE AGENDA A LITTLE BIT
MORE BECAUSE MAYBE WILL HAVE.
LESS ANGRY PEOPLE AND MAYBE
WE'LL HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE A
LITTLE MORE UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
WHY THE PLUSES AND TINGS GET A
LITTLE DELAYED.
IF IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THEIR TERMS I THINK YOU ALL FOR
STICKING AROUND.
THIS LONG IT'S IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY AND AND I'VE ONLY BEEN IN
THIS FIGHT FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
WHO'S BEEN THIS FIGHT FOR MUCH
LONGER.
MS GARCIA --
WHICH YOU MIGHT --
JUST LETTING EVERYBODY KNOW WHAT
IT MEANS THAT THE BILL SUNSETS
BECAUSE THERE THAT I DON'T.
MEAN THAT IN A COUPLE YEARS PART
OF THAT HE WILL NO LONGER BE
COLLECTED --
AND SO WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
COLLECT THAT UNLESS IT'S
EXTENDED BY.
AND THEN I WILL BE INTRODUCING
LEGISLATION TO EXPEND THE FUNDS
THAT I WILL BE IT'LL INCLUDE TO
EXPAND HOW MUCH WE COLLECT.
AND ALSO TO GUARANTEE THAT IT
STAYS IN THE MY PEERS IN THE
NEXT GOVERNOR I WILL BE ON BOARD
FOR THAT BUT WE'LL NEED ALL YOUR
HELP WITH THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE THAT
STAYED FOR THE DURATION OF THIS
HEARING --
AGAIN MY NAME IS WHEN YOU GOT A
DEAL I AM RECENTLY ELECTED --
THINK ANOTHER JOB NOW FOR SEVEN
MONTHS.
AND INHERITED THIS IS HUGE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE AS A A SOME
OF THAT GREW UP IN THIS
COMMUNITY THAT LIVES IN THIS
COMMUNITY WHO HAS FRIENDS AND
FAMILY AS I MENTIONED IN MY
EARLIER REMARKS IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS PERSONAL.
AND PART OF HAVING A SEAT AT THE
TABLE IS ENSURING THAT WE ARE
FIGHTING. FOR OUR COMMUNITY IN A
WAY THAT'S REPRESENTATIVE OF
THAT COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE --
I DO WANT TO PUT SOMEBODY A
SOMETHING THAT THAT SOMEONE SAID
EARLIER THAT REALLY STUCK STUCK
WITH ME.
SOMEONE SAID HOPE HAS TWO
PARENTS COURAGE AND ACTION.
AND I REALLY DO WISH AND MAYBE
IT WAS JUST THE FORMAT AND HOW
THIS WAS ALL DONE BUT AS
DIRECTOR BARBARA LEVY AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR MOST IN THE SUNNY ARE
STILL HERE.
AND THEY ARE LISTENING I REALLY
WISH THAT YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN ON
THIS SIDE SO YOU COULD HAVE SEEN
THE FACES OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE ACTUALLY ARE GIVING THEIR
TESTIMONY BUT I DO HOPE.
THAT.
WELL THERE'S THEY'RE SITTING
DOWN AND THEY'RE LISTENING WHICH
MEANS SOMETHING.
I HOPE THAT YOU LISTEN TO THE
COMMUNITY AND I HOPE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO COME BACK.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY OF US
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD THE
TSC ACCOUNTABLE.
I IN ENSURING THAT THE CLEAN U
IS DONE IN A MORE SPEEDY FASHION.
THAT THE WORKERS ARE TAKING CARE
OF THAT THE COMMUNITY IS TAKING
CARE OF AND THEN WE START
LOOKING AT THE HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS.
THAT THIS COMMUNITY HAS FACED
FOR DAY AND PART OF THAT IS A
HUGE RESPONSIBILITY TO THAT
DEPARTMENT.
AND SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
EVERYONE THAT.
STATE THAT WILL CONTINUE IN THIS
FIGHT AND KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL OF US IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE THAT.
UNDERSTAND AND WANT TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND AGAIN THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN FOR THE HEARING BECAUSE
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN OFTEN AND SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
THAT OF THE PEAKER WHO IS HERE
WITH US EARLIER IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE BEEN IN THIS FIGHT MUCH
LONGER.
THAN I HAVE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MISTER SANTIAGO.
WILL ALTHOUGH YOU'VE BEEN IN
THIS FIGHT FOR VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME YOU'VE BEEN PRETTY
FIERCE AT IT SO I WILL.
I WILL SAY THAT --
SINCE SHE GOT TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND WE BEGAN TO TALK THAT WAS
ONE OF THE ISSUES.
BUT BUT YOU KNOW.
I THINK -- I
THINK WHAT WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR HERE --
FOR THIS COMMUNITY WITH THIS
COMMUNITY'S BEEN FIGHTING FOR
HERE --
DOESN'T STOP TODAY.
AND WE'VE.
WE'VE GONE AFTER A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT.
SOME FOLKS SAID THAT WE WANTED
MORE DOLLARS ABSOLUTELY WHEN WE
STARTED THIS AND AND MY
COLLEAGUES HERE CONTEST WE ASK
FOR TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION. FOR THE FOR
THE HONOR FOR THE PARK WAITS.
YOU KNOW WE WEREN'T SUCCESSFUL
BUT WE GOT SIX POINT.
FIVE YOU KNOW NEXT YEAR WE COME
BACK AND WE SHOOT FOR MORE.
AND DO WE WILL CONTINUE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
A WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
UNTIL WE HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES
TO CLEAN UP THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
NOTHING DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE'VE ALWAYS SAID OF WHAT WE
ALWAYS WORK TOWARDS.
BUT I'M CALM PRETTY CONFIDENT.
ABOUT WHAT THE TYPE LEADERSHIP
THAT THAT WE HAVE HERE THAT WILL
CONTINUE THAT FIGHT.
AND I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT
THIS COMMUNITY WHAT WILL FIGHT
WITH US AND CONTINUED UNTIL
EVERY HOUSE IS CLEAN.
AND UNTIL WE DO JUSTICE AND
UNTIL FOLKS WHO RAN EXCITE.
HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED FOR THE
CRIMES THAT THEY'RE DONE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
AND IN MOST HEARD SOMEBODY SAY
DETAILS OF COURSE WERE.
ABSOLUTELY PART OF HAVING THESE
MEETINGS HERE.
IS TO HOLD EVERYBODY ACCOUNTABLE
FOR CLEANING UP THE REASON WE
STARTED THE COMMUNITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
AND IT WAS A VERY CLEAR LOUD
MESSAGE.
FROM THE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WE
ALL REPRESENT HERE THAT THERE
WASN'T ANY COMMUNICATION.
AND SO WE FIGHT EXTREMELY HARD
TO GET COMMUNICATION GOING.
PART OF THE BUDGET HEARING WE'RE
HAVING HERE US SO THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM FOR HAVING THIS
HERE.
IS IS THE IS THE HOLD IS TO
INCREASE ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND TO HEAR IT ON RECORD THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CLEAN UP THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD AND WE'RE GONNA DO
ALL THAT WE POSSIBLY CAN.
LOOK THERE'S BEEN SOME STUMBLES
ALONG THE WAY NODE.
BUT HERE'S THE CATCH THE
COMMITMENT THAT I HEAR VERY LOUD
AND STRONG IS IT ISN'T A
MOMENTARY ISSUE.
IT'S NOT A SOUND BITE.
WASN'T JUST A PRESS RELEASE OR
PRESS CONFERENCE.
THE LONG TERM COMMITMENT TO GET
THIS PLACE CLEANED UP AND I AND
I IN AND AND AND AND I KNOW THAT
I CAN.
I CAN SPEAK FOR MY CALL BUT I
KNOW THAT I CAN SPEAK FOR THE
SENTIMENT.
THAT WE ARE IN THIS UNTIL THIS
THING IS CLEANED UP.
AND IT DID THEN THAT WILL BE
HERE NEXT YEAR AND WILL BE THE
FOLLOWING YEAR.
SAME WITH YOU.
SOMEONE THANK EVERYBODY HERE AND
AND REST ASSURED THAT.
WE WILL DO ALL THAT WE POSSIBLY
CAN. TO GET THIS COMMUNITY
CLEANED UP AND GIVE IT JUSTICE.
ONCE AND FOR ALL THANK YOU.
WELL THERE'S NOT MUCH THAT I CAN
ADD TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY SAID AND SAT UP VERY
ELOQUENTLY AND VERY WELL THERE'S
AN OLD TO US SAYING THAT NOTHING.
GOOD EVER CAME WITHOUT A
STRUGGLE --
THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE OF THE
STRUGGLES.
OF FROM WHICH I THINK A GOOD
WILL ULTIMATELY COME BUT IT HAS
BEEN A LOT OF WORK AND HAS BEEN
A LOT OF EFFORT.
TO BUY ALL OF YOU AND MANY
OTHERS AND IT WILL CONTINUE TO
BE SO AND I URGE YOU TO STAY
ENGAGED INVOLVED --
THIS HEARING HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO IT IS ONE OF THE
FEW OCCASIONS WHEN WE'VE REALLY
BEEN ABLE TO BRING TOGETHER THE
COMMUNITY AND THE AGENCIES --
AND TO ALL TO THE EFFORT OF
RESPONDING TO THIS ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER THAT IS AFFECTING YOUR
COMMUNITY.
SO WE WILL STAY ON THIS ARE --
JOB IS OVERSIGHT --
IT IS --
PROVIDING THE COMMENTARY AND
MAKING SURE THAT YOU ARE LISTEN --
TO SO THAT WE CONTINUE TO DO A
BETTER AND BETTER AND BETTER JOB.
OF ACCOMPLISHING THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING THAT TOXIC FREE
ENVIRONMENT FOR YOU HERE IN THE
HOMES IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT
YOU LIVE IN.
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU AGAIN --
TO ALMOND SENIOR AND THE
RESURRECTION RESURRECTION CHURCH --
FOR PROVIDING THIS.
THIS BEAUTIFUL FACILITY AT THAT
IS SO MEANINGFUL TO THE
COMMUNITY AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU AGAIN PLEASE BEAR IN
MIND THAT WE DO HAVE HEARINGS --
COMING UP NEXT YEAR THAT TAKE
PLACE.
IN SACRAMENTO I KNOW IT IS
DIFFICULT TO GET THEIR BUT YOU
ARE INVITED TO COME LISTEN TO
THOSE HEARINGS PARTICIPATE IN
THEM WITH PUBLIC COMMENT.
LIKE YOU DID TONIGHT --
AND DOES SO --
UP ADVOCATES AMONGST YOU --
WILL OUT OF THE WHERE OF THE
DATES WHEN WE HEAR THE SPECIFIC.
ISSUE AGAIN AND PROVIDE OUR
REGULAR OVERSIGHT TOUGHER DGSE
AND OTHER IMPORTANT AGENCIES
THANK YOU AND GOOD EVENING WE
ARE ADJOURNED